character john paul van
[Music]
neil sheehan author of a new book a
bright
shining lie john paul van an american
vietnam
why'd you write the book
well there are a number of reasons um
first of all i
as a reporter never could escape from
vietnam
i went there first as a as he it was my
first assignment 1962 as a wire service
reporter i spent two years there went
went back to new york got a job with the
new york times
was sent back to vietnam for a third
year came to washington 66 to cover the
pentagon with all the war anti-war
protests etc
and then one day found myself in at
arlington cemetery at the funeral of a
friend john van
and
realized that i wanted to leave
something behind other than another
magazine article and another or another
newspaper story and i felt that through
him i could write a book that would
really tell the story of the war
so how long have you been working on
this book
it took me 15 years to write it
and that spent another year going to
press
it it was uh i was as impetuous as
robert mcnamara and thinking at the
beginning that i could do this work in
three to four years
that is write a biography of john vann
and the history of the war which is what
the book is it's the two combined tell
his tell the story of the war through
the man and tell the story of the man
through the war
but it turned out to be a vastly greater
task than i had imagined i also had some
setbacks i had an auto accident in 74
that took a year out of my life and i
had to lecture to earn a living and that
sort of thing but basically most of
those 15 years went into that book
what's the origin of the title of the
book a bright shining lie
it's it's from a remark by john vann uh
when he came back here in july of 1963
he
said to a u.s army historian we too
were had been among the we too were to
all the visitors who came out there
among the bright shot one of the bright
shining lies
and so i
i used that because he had said it
and because also uh
it it to me reflected the ironies the
many many ironies of the war and the
many many illusions of the war it was to
me a very apt title
uh
because the the
uh
our war our venture in vietnam was
fueled by by many many illusions and and
the title is meant to reflect those
ironies
it's it's not a simple title in other
words
who was john paul van
john van was the closest we came in
vietnam to an american lawrence of
arabia
he was an extraordinary character uh at
least to me he was an extraordinary
figure
i met him when i first went there in
in
1962 and
as a as i said as a young reporter on my
first assignment for united press
international
he was lieutenant colonel in the army
and he was the senior adviser to the
south vietnamese infantry division
in charge of the northern mekong delta
and he left the army after that first
year
under controversial circumstances he got
into an argument with the commanding
general as to whether we were losing the
war winning it van said we were losing
the commanding general said we were
winning van left the army
and then he went back as a pacification
adviser a civilian for aid in 65 and he
finally rose to be
the first civilian
to command troops in wartime as a
general to command the command in war as
as a general in the general officer's
position
and then he was killed in june of 72
after the better part of 10 years there
and i went to his funeral at arlington
because he was he was a friend
and it was like and when i walked into
the chapel
it was like going to a very strange
class reunion
i got there only about 10 minutes before
it started and the chapel was already
full
and uh
ev and this man had paul had drawn
together all
everyone or almost everyone who was of
significance
in that war
that is a great many of them i mean here
was william westmoreland was the chief
pallbearer of this former renegade
lieutenant colonel who retired from the
army in 1963.
daniel ellsberg was over on the other
side sitting next to the family
edward kennedy came in a few minutes
before the
the the service began and i thought of
the one kent the kennedy who had turned
against the war the second kennedy the
one kennedy who had started us into
vietnam john
and the second one bobby who'd been
murdered after he and uh in the election
of course of 68 and after he turned
against against the war and then edward
who who'd known john vann
and so i i felt that you had the feeling
keen feeling in that chapel that we were
burying more than john van we were
burying a whole era that
era of self-confidence that
the mindset of that
era henry lusso boastfully called the
american century
the self-confidence and the
arrogance if you will that had led us to
vietnam we weren't burying the united
states of america obviously we were
burying a frame of mind a mindset that
that would mark this country and and and
and i
the it struck me that if i wrote a book
about this man who was an extraordinary
character in himself in his own and who
had spent the better part of 10 years in
vietnam who summed up the american
adventure there in his life and his work
i could also write a book about the war
that people would understand because
they would be seeing the war through a
man
and they would be under they would be
coming to grips with this experience in
a human way
because van was it was a way to tell the
story
got open to the book where the picture
and the audience just saw the picture of
uh
the van family and richard nixon and the
story about this particular event
uh it's a little bit out of context with
all that we're going to talk about but
it's probably worth telling now as we
head into this first who's in this
photograph
well uh
here you have over to the uh uh
it would be of course
my left
so let's go left to right you have his
oldest brother frank
his younger brother uh um jean his
sister dorothy lee and then his son
jesse
belong here with the long hair then he's
since cut his hair but jesse then had
long hair and he left half his draft
card on his father's coffin and he was
going to give the other half to richard
nixon but he and he was stopped from
doing it because he was told they were
going to abort the ceremony they weren't
they weren't going to go forward with
the medal ceremony if he insisted on
giving the other half to the president
so he agreed not to this is the day of
the funeral it's the day of the funeral
this is the ceremony at the white house
after the funeral at arlington
during which nixon awarded uh
posthumously to the eldest son uh the
presidential medal of freedom um this is
his wife or his righteousness his former
wife right and then the next son tommy
and then peter the youngest son who
who still got in his hand the flag from
the coffin mary jane his former wife and
then president nixon and his heart in
that picture because it's blown down to
see
his face but the president's got a kind
of queasy nervous look on his face and i
think he was still a bit nervous about
what jesse might do even though jesse
had agreed not to
to
hand him half of this draft card and
then you have john allen the eldest son
who
received the medal on behalf of the
family
nixon posthumously awarded john van the
presidential medal of freedom which is
the highest civilian decoration you can
receive and the second highest um of our
of all our awards the highest is the
pres is the congressional medal and then
here's melvin laird than the secretary
of defense and william rogers it was to
me a sort of it was an extraordinary
picture because it it summed up in some
ways the the conflicts of that era uh uh
a a war hero with a son who was who was
who was personally
very much opposed to the war
opposed to it to the extent that he was
willing to to go to jail because jesse
would have gone to jail or certainly he
would have committed he had already
committed one crime mutilating his draft
card
it was against the law to mutilate your
draft card and
he was about to call attention enough
attention to that
by handing the other half to the
president
so it was to me an extraordinary that
was
when i looked into this funeral i didn't
know that at the time i'd gone to the
chapel obviously this had occurred after
the chapel when the family had gone to
the white house but later on when i
interviewed them all i realized that the
funeral was more extraordinary for other
reasons as well
because our audience has seen brent
scowcroft so often tell us the brent
scowcroft story and how he played a
factor that was
brent groscroft who's now
a retired lieutenant general from the
air force and who's
associated with henry kissinger in
in new york and kissinger associates and
who later became president ford's
special assistant for national security
affairs
brent scowcroft was then president
nixon's military aide his senior
military aide
and when they discovered that this young
man had left half his draft card on his
father's coffin
and uh the family was waiting in the
roosevelt room to go into the oval
office for the ceremony which the medal
would be rewarded and the young man had
the other half in his suit coat pocket
and he was going to hand it to the
president
they
when this was discovered first it was a
furious argument within the family
because the other members of the family
did not want jesse most of them did not
want jesse to go to do this to to to
hand the president the other half of his
draft card and and they felt spoil his
father's funeral and ruin the medal
award ceremony but they couldn't
persuade him or hadn't succeeded in
persuading him and so the eldest son
john allen went out and told one of the
civilian officials and in charge what
was happening
and
they called scotchroft and he told
scowcroft what was happening and
scopcroft is a very calm man he's very
calm very precise man and he went in and
told the president that there'd be a
slight delay
there was a problem he'd have to settle
it and then he went into the roosevelt
room where the family was gathered and
he
called jesse aside took him aside took
him by the arm and said look if you're
going to do this we're going to have to
call off the ceremony because there's no
way we can go ahead with this ceremony
if you're going to do this
and by this time jesse had been battered
enough by the members of his family so i
think he was willing to resist them
excuse me willing to listen
and he said okay i won't do it.
and then scowcroft
uh uh turned to his oldest brother john
allen and said willie or won't he and
john allen said well if he says he won't
do it he won't do it so scovcroft
decided to let the ceremony go forward
and he told me afterwards that during
the ceremony he had his eye he was not
he is not in this picture of course he
was standing on the other side of the
oval office
with his eye on jesse through the whole
ceremony
asking himself well i uh i wonder if he
if he really will keep his word and
won't do anything because it was
it was good judgment on the part of
skokroth to let it go forward but at the
same time there was there was some risk
and it was probably good judgment on the
part of president nixon to let it go
forward he was taking a risk to he could
have been very embarrassed and i think
that's why he was somewhat nervous
during the whole thing this funeral was
in 1972. it was in 1972 and the picture
you just showed was the
uh ceremony at the white house after the
funeral when the whole family was driven
over to the white house from arlington
cemetery for the for the awarding of the
of the medal posthumously because
president nixon himself did not attend
the funeral what were you doing then
i was then a reporter for the new york
times
i had the year before uh obtained the
pentagon papers for the times
and uh
the intervening year had been one of of
of turmoil and i was just about to
settle back into work
as a daily reporter
when i went to this funeral
of a man who'd been my friend
because i i had gotten to know john
i thought quite well as a young reporter
in that first year i'd gone to vietnam
and i'd seen him since then
and i had not thought he would die in
vietnam
none of us did he took so many risks
that after a while his friends began to
think he was
that the odds as he said did not apply
to him and one day i picked up the paper
and he and and there was the news that
he was dead
he died on the ninth he was killed on
the ninth
uh and so i went to the funeral on the
16th along with all those other people
in that chapel there were a lot of other
faces of people involved with vietnam
who were not famous but who were well
known
who gave the eulogy that day the eulogy
was given by a guy named robert comer
ambassador robert comer who had headed
the pacification program in vietnam
uh and he gave a very good very fine
eulogy he was he he and van were friends
that was another thing that was so so
striking about it bob comer had played a
major role in vietnam another one of the
pallbearers was was william colby who
later became head of c.i.a who played a
major role in vietnam
the chapel was just filled with these
people
and so
i had that sense then that that if i
wrote a book i wanted to
i had spent my career
involved with vietnam not because i was
obsessed with the war but because i
couldn't get away from the war i said i
i was sent from vietnam home in 66 to be
the pentagon correspondent in the
washington bureau of the times
then they sent me to the white house in
1968 for the last six months of
johnson's administration
when johnson was driven from office by
the war
then came the pentagon papers in 1971 i
i could never get away from this war it
had dominated my newspaper career and i
wanted to leave behind something that
would we're doing that would endure
and
going to that funeral gave me the
feeling that well gave me the idea that
if i if i wrote a book about this man
i could really tell the story of this
war and perhaps help this country to
come to grips with the war with this
very painful experience that had divided
us
more profoundly than any war since the
civil war
and we had obviously not come to grips
with it at that point and i don't think
we still have i've come to grips with it
i hope the book will help people to come
to grips with it uh because i think we
have to somehow redeem vietnam if we're
withdraw wisdom from from the war but
that um
that was uh going to that that that
chapel simply because i was the friend
of a friend of john van
uh was what set me off now i thought i
knew him it turned out i didn't know him
he was a lot more complicated than i had
realized
all of his friends thought that we they
knew john vance turned out that no one
knew john vance
let me stop you there and uh and ask you
this because
if you look at this book and you
and we'll show the audience in the back
you've shown each division how each
section how you sourced it and
but let's not just go through the
particulars
350 interviews
385
almost 400 individual in-person
interviews yeah some of them now we were
over the phone some of them were where a
very a small number were brief exchanges
over the phone or
or in person or were letters but
many of them went on most of them were
substantial
and many of them went on for days at a
time
um i think
if you check i think i i
acquired about 670 tape cassettes
the reason i did so much interviewing
for the book
was that i realized when i began i
realized before i started my research
but i
my the experience of doing the research
deep in my conviction
that much of the history of this war had
never been written down
that it existed only in the minds of
people
uh in their memories and perhaps in some
cases notes and diaries they'd kept
their letters but that in most cases it
hadn't been written down
and that one of my tasks was to capture
this history
to capture the history of the war before
it disappeared
as people as people's memories faded as
they moved on etc and i thought a
reporter was uniquely qualified to do
that
so that i interviewed at such a length
because it was absolutely necessary if
you look at the documents of vietnam
you find
that unlike world war ii
what you find in the official documents
about vietnam is the thinking of the
people at the top
they tell you what they thought they
don't tell you the realities what was
happening
on the ground because in vietnam the
people at the top didn't know what was
happening
on the ground
and so i i i interviewed as extensively
as i did for that reason
and it was it was very fruitful a lot of
people were terribly good to me for
instance
ambassador bunker
the light ambassador bunker
when he was negotiating panama canal
trading
would give me an hour every uh month or
two
and i had 11 sessions with him when i
was in vietnam on two research trips for
the book in 1972 and 73
i'd spent days with people
who were fruitful somebody who was
important who was really telling me
something that was useful i'd spend two
three days with the person interviewing
them and tape cassette after tape
cassette
and it was it was extraordinarily
valuable i couldn't have written the
book without the interviews i had a lot
of documentation as well i had his
papers
i had
his family turned all of his papers over
to me and the documentation was
extremely valuable too but the
interviews were real adjunct to it what
did you do with all those audio tapes
you keep them i've kept them and they'll
eventually go to the library of congress
some of them will have to be sealed
because there are some private things in
there
but
they'll all go to the library of
congress they were i didn't transcribe
them all i i didn't have the money to do
the funds to do that i did get summaries
made of them often with
the subjects and
and you know side a tape one side a
footage x
x subject and so years later i could put
that tape in a machine and go back and
listen to it
and it was very laborious to sit there
and listen and spend two or three days
taking the details off the tape
because i you don't have secretarial
help you got to do this all yourself
but it was extraordinary valuable
because i don't take shorthand
and the tape recorder catches things
that you don't even catch in shorthand
so that it would they were a wonderful
memory bank
of events
for instance there's there's an
extraordinary rescue of the advisors at
a place called tan can in 1972 by van
when he snatches them right out from
under uh of the north vietnamese tanks i
played the tapes i'd done with his
helicopter pilot and with the senior
advisor there and there were these these
and and i had made those tapes at the
time when they when when when this event
was very vivid in their memories uh and
uh with the senior advisor it was only
months
afterwards and with the pilot it was a
couple of years afterwards and the tapes
were extraordinary and they they
they they helped me to to to gather
detail if you will to to retain detail
the tape recorder is a wonderful memory
device it can be a trap for you if you
depend on it i didn't depend on it i
used my notes primarily but it was a
wonderful memory device
when did you make your first interview
and when did you make your last in order
to get this book done
i did my first interviews with the
american family
shortly after the funeral when i was
thinking of doing the book his american
his american family
i should say the american family because
john van left two families
one was a vietnamese family and the
other an american family
uh and i
i i i interviewed the american family at
uh at the point when i was trying to
make up my mind whether i whether i
ought to write the book or not
and i i called them first i spoke to his
former wife and i asked whether she
would cooperate with me uh i told her
that if i undertook the book
i would
have i would i would ask her to be
absolutely honest with me be absolutely
open
and the other members of the family as
well
and that i would then write the book and
they would have no control over it
and they would have they would not see
it ahead of time they would have no
prior censorship no censorship no prior
approval etc and i did not want to
undertake the project unless everyone
was willing to agree to this and i would
also ask them to give me his papers and
i spoke to his oldest son as well
and i spoke to the other members of the
family i called and called them about
this and they all agreed said yes his
wife her former wife was the first that
said she she cooperate she was she was
very open to having a book done
so i went out to colorado where they
most of them were and i interviewed
first his former wife
mary jane van
who knew him better than anyone else
because they had married when they were
young and
he had talked to her more about his
childhood
than he had to anyone else and he was
the product as you know of an
extraordinarily
painful childhood of a mother who
rejected him and it was cruel to him
and um
she
she first uh
my interview with her my interviews with
her first of all
lasted for days
she was absolutely honest with me she's
a woman a strong woman of great moral
courage and she was very open and i
spent days talking to her and she first
came
i first learned through her what a
really complicated man he was
and he fascinated me even more as a
result of those interviews i realized
that i was
that this was much more even than the
story of vietnam that it wasn't a it was
a kind of
that it was an american saga if you will
the story of how we got to vietnam as
well this is his mother and his wife
right here his uh that that's right
that's the picture at the wedding and
that's his mother uh and
john van as a young man when he was an
air corps a lieutenant navigator in the
u.s army air corps in world war ii and
that's his his bride to bear about
that's probably that photo was probably
taken the day before the wedding and
here they are at at the wedding in in
uh rochester new york and on october 6
1945 that photograph those photographs
were from mary jane his former wife she
gave me her wedding album
has she seen this book yet
she hasn't seen the book she's seen the
new yorker series she hasn't seen the
book but she'll be she'll be getting one
soon in the mail from me if she had any
reaction
she liked the series in the new yorker
uh she she uh
she's a as i said a very strong and a
very uh
honest and
a very forthright woman
and uh she had made up her mind that she
was willing to tell the tale
uh this was back in 72 originally and
she's she's remained that way ever since
i mean we're going to talk about john
van in some detail in a later
discussion but
she was
divorced from him at the funeral and
went with the family to the oval office
why
well because i think
if you were
first of all um i think if you were to
put it emotionally
she was divorced from him in fact but
not uh but not emotionally i think at
that point in her life she was probably
still in love with him i think she was
she told me she was and i believe she
was
um she really
the divorce had been an act of
frustration
she lived in denver and he lived in
vietnam yeah and and uh it had been a a
a as you as the readers will see when
they read the book of an extremely
troubled marriage uh and um
she had finally out of frustration asked
for a divorce but they had only been
divorced about let's see they divorced
in october 71 and he was killed in june
of 72.
those are your first interviews what
were your last and what at what date did
you finish all your interviews before
you wrote this book i kept interviewing
i did most of my interviews first of all
i rushed off to vietnam after
interviewing
members of the family here back in 72
back in 72 i rushed off to vietnam uh to
do six three months of interviews there
with three americans and the vietnamese
who fought his last battles with him
before they moved on
to other things and before that very
fragile society of south vietnam came
apart because i had a sense that it was
going to disappear as it did in 1975 so
i wanted to talk to them before this
happened
and then i i interviewed except for the
year i lost with the auto accident i
interviewed until about 76 when i
started writing 75 76 i began writing
but then i kept up the interviews uh
as i would get to a section and i would
need to fill in
i would go to people
additional people and i would interview
for that section
and one of the reasons it took so long
was that i discovered that this canvas
first of all this man was much more
complicated than i had ever imagined and
that required a great deal more
interviewing and a lot more research
than i had ever thought
and secondly the war
had gone on for 30 years and it was a
lot and it was a lot more complicated
than i had imagined so i kept up the
interviewing through the years
not with the intensity i did in earlier
years because i was writing but i would
as i got to a section as i said i would
do
interviews to fill in those research
holes and sometimes they'd be extensive
again i'd take two three days out and
interview someone
so the interviews continued on through
the years
as i would need something i would i
would turn to someone and i would do it
although the basic interviewing was done
in the 1970s
is there a particular section of this
book that your favorite
i guess my favorite would be
the the funeral itself which
maybe one reason being that it was the
easiest to write i wrote it back in 1976
and it didn't ever change it
substantially
the difficulty was in finding the
structure of the rest of the book i had
an enormous struggle
to find to come up with a structure that
worked for the rest of the book that is
to meld biography the biography of this
man in the history of the war
my favorite sections within the book
then vary
this
book five on his childhood and youth
is is to me a favorite section
we're talking with neil shan author of
this new book by random house a bright
shining lie
john paul van an america in vietnam
[Music]
this conversation with author neil
sheehan will re-air tonight at 1 10 a.m
eastern time that's 10 10 for our west
coast viewers
a reminder to our audience that this
interview is the first in a five-part
series focusing on mr sheehan's new book
the bright shining lie john paul van and
america in vietnam
this coming friday evening at 8 30
eastern 5 30 pacific following the final
interview in the series we'll air a
round table discussion with a group of
military officials who offer their
reaction to the book
then on sunday at 6 pm eastern we'll
open our phones to hear what you thought
about the series the book or perhaps the
war itself these five interviews with
former new york times correspondent neil
sheehan premiere each evening through
friday at 8 pm eastern 5 pacific time
in just a moment president ronald reagan
[Music]
stay tuned to c-span for complete
unedited coverage of the
[Music]
presidential coming up next we'll air
the second in our series of interviews
with neil sheehan the author of a bright
shining lie john paul van and america in
vietnam
he covered the vietnam war for the new
york times and his new book is a
biography of the senior american advisor
in vietnam john paul van it's also a
history of american involvement in the
vietnam war
our interview looks at america in
vietnam
neil sheehan
author of the book a bright shining lie
john paul van in america in vietnam when
you hear the word vietnam what's the
first thing that comes to mind
the
wasted gallantry
the sacrifice
in vain
provided of course we don't draw some
wisdom from it but but the tragedy
of it all is what comes to mind
the inevitability of it because it was a
war toward which we were
headed as a nation there was a great
inevitability about it
uh but all of those things come to mind
to my mind the the the the the names on
the wall
down there at the memorial
uh the
the the sadness always comes to mind at
the same time uh uh you you have that
it's it's even sadder because of all
because of all that that gallantry that
went into it all that self-confidence
and that was wasted
how old were you and when was the first
time you set foot in the country
i was
let's see i was born in 1936 and i went
there in 1962 so i was in my mid
twenties
uh
my mathematics is so poor that i can't
add it up for you right now it's off the
top of my head
but uh
i was sick
yes that's right it would be and uh i
was it was my first assignment for
united press international i just got
out of the army in tokyo where i took my
discharge i was out of the army two
weeks
when my boss the head for asia left to
note my typewriter one night in tokyo
and said how was your french
and
come and see me in the morning i said
how was your french come and see me in
the morning i was working the night
shift so i stayed over to see him when
he came in in the morning
and he said how'd you like to go to
saigon the fellow down there had
resigned
and i said i'd love to go to saigon
and he said well
get ready to go
so
about a week and a half later i was in
saigon i spent two years there two years
in vietnam just a picture of you that's
a picture of me with a a vietnamese
south vietnamese general named zukwu
dong
this is the during my third year in
vietnam when i was there with the new
york times for the new york times there
was a minor civil war going on in da
nang which is a port up in the north
where the marines were located
between it was the civil war was between
two factions on the saigon side
a group of reporters got trapped in
pagoda
that picture of me i was talking to that
general trying to get the saigon inside
to stop shooting so we could get those
reporters out of that pagoda
and actually we were talking in french
which was the language that he knew best
um he had served in the french army
and he was the commander of the
vietnamese airborne division when you
were first there what was the status of
our involvement in vietnam
we
when i first went there
it was the outset of the chemic what
would call the kennedy commitment it was
john kennedy's john kennedy had sent
military advisers
uh pilots air force pilots who were
flying planes with vietnamese markings
on them and he had sent helicopter
companies to tran to fly
vietnamese troops out in out for us into
assault operations but essentially the
war was being fought through the saigon
army uh through the saigon forces who
was who was president of the company of
negotiating was still the president and
that was before we decided that
the united states decided not just the
news media
that he was
no longer useful that he was helping to
lose the war and
he was overthrown in an american
instigated coup in in
in 1963 but he was still the president
then still very much in charge is still
uh with full backing of the united
states but
the the guerrillas had had um because of
his own abuses and incompetence
the communist revolution in the
countryside had grown to the point where
he his regime was in danger of being
overthrown that's why those american
advisers had been sent there were
several thousand then but it was the
beginning then um
not many americans had been killed when
i went there perhaps less than 20 had
been killed how many other reporters
were there when you got there very small
number then remember any of them oh sure
uh most of them have stayed friends of
mine over the years there were less than
a dozen of us then uh david well david
halverston wasn't there when i first got
there there was a man named homer bigger
who was an older reporter
who was on his last foreign assignment
he was one of the most he was probably
the most distinguished foreign
correspondent of his times the time
magazine no he was with the new york
times he worked
for that for the herald tribune and won
two pulitzer prizes
so he had two new york times reporters
no he was he preceded david halperstein
and then albert he left and david
halberson came in september
and was there for most of the time i was
for most of my subsequent time
halberstown for the times malcolm brown
who's now with the new york times and as
a science writer he was ap then he was
ap peter arnett who's now with cnn uh
was also with the ap photographer no he
was a reporter a man named horst foss uh
a german a
a born who
uh photographer who worked for the upi
in in africa covered the the the war the
the revolution of the turmoil and the
belgian congo which is now zaire
was the
or shortly became
the photographer for the ap and won two
pulitzers in vietnam
um he's now in london uh
the uh there's a fellow named john
sharkey uh who was with uh nbc and then
the some well-known outsiders would come
in outsiders in the sense that they
weren't based in the country but they
frequently came through bernie cal with
nbc
uh peter callish who is now retired with
cbs a good friend of mine named charlie
moore who was then the chief
correspondent for time uh
but the resident correspondents were a
small group less than a dozen and all we
competed with each other quite intensely
uh we were friends uh you were upi and i
was upi right how much did your editors
back here in the united states at that
point care about the story
the story really was a secondary story
uh
during my first six months there
the country was focused on other foreign
policy crises cuba
berlin
those were the main focuses people
hadn't really understood
that there was a that we had gone to war
in vietnam that john kennedy had
committed the arms of the united states
and he had begun to spill american blood
and he had planted the flag they didn't
really understand that malcolm brown of
the ap in frank in fact one day got a
letter addressed to him uh uh of of
saigon french indonesia
rather than saigon french indochina
it wasn't until the battle of opbak
in january
1963 which to which a full section is
devoted in this book
and you asked me about favorite sections
sessions earlier that's one of my
favorite sections if you will because
it's uh it's a battle and it it
i identify with soldiers having spent so
much time around them it wasn't until
the battle of opbach in january 63 when
the saigon forces were defeated in a
very decisive way
by a small group of
guerrillas humiliated if you will this
american-backed army with its armor and
its artillery and its aircraft was was
defeated by a battalion of gorillas in a
in a battle it was a fiasco on our side
that in effect illuminated the war uh it
caught heads caught headlines in this
country
and got on television although print was
much more important than television has
than than it is now television was
coming into its own
and that began to i think after that the
country began january of 1963 the
country began to realize that we were
involved in a war in vietnam and then of
course came the buddhist
crisis that is the buddhist revolt
against siam
burning the monks the suicides by the
monks and then the overthrow of siemens
and the war continually worsening
from about january 63 forward people
began to understand that we were we were
really involved in a major crisis and it
began to dominate the news for somebody
that might get your book which is
published by random house
what style did you use to write this
story
i know that in the back you have
each
each section uh the sources and the
material and all that stuff but what
kind of is it a narrative
it i i deliberately wrote this i wrote
this book for the general reader because
i wanted to try to write a book that
would help people
for the general reader
my countrymen in general
to come to grips with this war and so
this book is deliberately written with a
with what i hope is a powerful narrative
a driving narrative
that
that that retains suspense and narrative
force
uh
i felt that that was the
way a reporter ought to write a book
that
that is the kind of training a
journalist gets and i was influenced in
my writing very much
by truman capote's book in cold blood
i read that when it was published first
in the new yorker and then in book form
and he made me realize that you could
write a book
about real events
with the
a book that would have the narrative
drive of a novel
and yet
uh would be about real events which are
often much more interesting
than those that appear in a novel and
certainly it's true at least i think in
the case of vietnam now it's much more
difficult to write that way
and to to retain truth and to retain
subtlety and to retain all of the
complexity
that you want and i was writing about
a biography of a very complicated
character and a history of a very long
war but it's written deliberately with
with what i hope is narrative drive
because i wanted people to read this
book i didn't want them to i did not
want to write a scholarly book it would
have been easier to do scholarly in the
sense of a form with footnotes
etc
there are no footnotes in the book there
are those notes you mentioned of course
are note source notes at the back
because i wanted to give full
documentation for what i'd written but i
deliberately kept it to source notes at
the back because i did not want anything
to get in the reader's way
as i said it made it much more difficult
to write but i hope
i hope it was worth it one of the things
i noticed in the bibliography uh when
you referred to
things to write i think
see if i can find it here
maybe it's not the bibliography uh
someplace in here you i saw the name
susan sheen any relation yes of course
susan is my wife
what was it i saw back here something
that you saw in the acknowledgments a
tribute to susan
i saw that but there was some other
place the book is dedicated to her and
to my daughters and to my mother and
mother-in-law and then uh you probably
saw in the acknowledgments that susan
had read uh had read all the drafts and
edited them and and uh
typed some of them uh susan and i uh
susan was a staff writer for the new
yorker when we met in 1964
and
has won susan won a pulitzer prize in 19
pulitzer 1983 for for non-fiction for a
book called is there no place on earth
for me it's a study of mental health and
schizophrenia and she has always edited
my stuff and i've always edited her
she's kidding
kitty is my mother-in-law
uh who's been a wonderful
person to me and so the book was
dedicated to susan and our two daughters
maria and catherine my mother and kitty
susan's mother
but susan and and susan and i uh uh have
always worked with each other i mean
excuse me we've always
edited each other's material encouraged
each other
and i think edited each other's material
honestly and critiqued each other's work
honestly let me read
something that i just
i saw when i read part of the book and i
wrote down something that you wrote
uh a lot of it's a
philosophical statement he said that by
the end by the second decade after world
war ii
the dominant characteristics of the
senior leadership of the american armed
forces had become professional arrogance
lack of imagination
and moral and intellectual insensitivity
let me read just a little more
it also touched the civilian
bureaucracies the cia the state
department and the lesser civilian
agencies that joined the armed services
in managing america american overseas
interests for the president the
attitudes had spread as well to the
greater part of the political academic
and business leadership of the united
states you want to expound on that a
little more sure one of the reasons we
we went to vietnam in all of our
self-confidence
and all of our ignorance if you will
was that
the pro the enormous success this
country had in world war ii the great
miracle
of world war ii the great moral crusade
that it was
and the economic success that followed
world war ii
led to a kind of moral torpor
an intellectual torpor
americans cease to think imaginatively
the american generals in vietnam thought
they'd prevail simply because they were
american generals
they'd ceased to realize that you could
lose a war
the american civilian leadership
assumed
that because its generals had four stars
and said they knew what they were
talking about that they really didn't
know what they were talking about
our leadership
what what had happened to us was that we
had was was it was a process that has
happened to european countries that but
that had never occurred
it happened to that excuse me that had
never happened to the united states
before
was that we had gone through that
historical process of becoming a great
power
and as a result of it we had we had our
we had we had become an arrogant our
leadership become arrogant and
self-satisfied and and unthinking this
is a process which has happened to other
countries it happened to the europeans
prior to world war one
and led to that enormous tragedy
that began in 1914
and the same kind of thinking led us to
vietnam
and for us vietnam was a kind of mini
world war one
uh uh it was it was uh a pro an
experience of of great pain
and uh great disillusionment i hope
it'll be an experience from which we'll
draw wisdom but prior to vietnam
americans
the american leadership of that period
and americans in general
assume that we were an exception to
history
that your leadership couldn't become so
self-confident that it would become
filled with that it would be driven by
illusions
that your uh
uh your industries and we're having this
problem obviously with our industries
your industrial management could become
so self-satisfied that it would
lose its competitive edge
and so that those sentences you read are
meant to sum up the mentality of the
leadership that took us to war in
vietnam the mentality of generals who
thought they were going to win as i said
simply because they were american
generals with four stars in there on
their shoulders our leadership in world
war ii was quite different than that
they were very keenly conscious of the
fact that they could lose
because they were little men going up
against big men we've forgotten that
since but we were the little men in
world war ii going up against these big
professional germans who were the world
champions
and and eisenhower and patton etc were
very conscious of the fact that they
could lose and that's one of the reasons
they were such fine fine fine generals
and very conscious of the fact that you
could not waste soldiers that the
soldier would would sense this right
away and he wouldn't follow you
patton was was so effective because he
was a winner
uh and but also because he was conscious
of losing
that he could lose by vietnam our
generals had ceased to be conscious of
that and so they they lost their grip on
reality uh what's one of the most
striking things about the war in vietnam
is that um
it's fought with a total sense of of uh
that that this fought with a total sense
of of of unreality illusion and what's
ironic about it i don't want to go on
too long but what you see when you read
this book is that anyone who challenged
this system
and you have a series of figures who did
first of all you have john van
who says we're losing the war in vietnam
this is 1962-63
who was he telling that to he was
telling that to his superiors general
harkins who was the commanding general
he went back to the pentagon and
tried to tell it to the joint chiefs of
staff and maxwell taylor canceled his
briefing
his scheduled briefing what year is that
63
uh the report is reporting it we assume
that
if you
let me just show the audience's photo
and tell us who this is so that's
general harkins here who is the
commanding general in vietnam in 6263
and
next to him is general wheeler the late
general wheeler who was at that time
chief of staff of the army when that
photo was taken in 63 and later became
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
general harkins was the top man he was
the top man in vietnam in 62-63 and john
paul van at that time was a lieutenant
colonel and the
adviser to the vietnamese division in
the northern mekong delta
and van said we were losing the war
and he
he had good reasons why and he wasn't
the only one who said we were losing the
war most of the advisers in the field
were convinced that that we were losing
but general hawkins wouldn't listen to
them
uh he uh he we thought at the time
that is
the reporters thought
we that general hawkins was was so
optimistic because he felt that he ought
to put the best face on things we
thought he had some sort of grip on we
had we thought that privately he had
a grip on reality that he he had some
understanding of what was going on in
fact when i got at the secret records
later on
the records of the internal discussions
the strategy conferences in honolulu
with between with robert mcnamara the
secretary of defense and general hawkins
and the rest of the military
hierarchy assembled i realized that
these men believed these illusions they
really thought they were winning the war
because here was a top secret conference
uh which i hadn't seen before uh the
records of it and they were they were
they were uh spouting these same uh
illusions that that they were giving us
in press conferences which we regarded
as an insult to our intelligence because
we were
young reporters were going on into the
field seeing what was happening talking
to advisers like van van hapen to be the
most
brilliant of the advisors
and the most outspoken
but the others were were also speaking
to us and uh we we thought that these
faculty optimistic uh remarks by general
hawkins were were simply an attempt to
fob us off it turned out that he
believed these illusions
and that uh and it was striking then
after
uh
the kennedy commit the excuse me the
advisory phase of the war that president
kennedy started failed and we then they
had to send the american army and the
marine corps to vietnam prevent the
saigon regime from collapsing
uh westmoreland began to acquire the
same set of illusions
despite the
the uh uh the the despite his own
experience at watching harkins uh um
westmoreland was then fueled by the same
illusions and anyone who challenged the
these was was crushed first you see van
uh attempting to challenge it and his
briefing for the joint chiefs is
cancelled by maxwell taylor who did not
want to hear bad news
he was convinced he was winning the war
let's go back to that for sure the uh
the john paul van briefing was to take
place where july 1963 this is very early
on in vietnam no he was by this time he
was back in this country he finished his
first year in vietnam
and he had decided to carry on a crusade
at the pentagon
to convince the military leadership of
the country
that we were losing the war in vietnam
and that if we did not change policy we
would lose it
and he started out
first he asked to they had a program at
the pentagon to allegedly learn lessons
from vietnam by
by
brief by by by interviewing returned
advisors it's called debriefing and
military slang he went
to the debriefing officer and asked to
be debriefed and he was informed that he
was not going to be debriefed at the
request of the commanding general in
saigon
so
uh he went off and started briefing
himself
and uh he gradually worked his way up
from his own section to where he was
talking to other to to generals in the
pentagon and he finally encountered a
general who who thought he really had
something to say and that was a man
named harold johnson who subsequently
became chief of staff of the army
and johnson threw another and another
senior general had a briefing schedule
for the joint chiefs which van was going
to present his case
essentially the briefing said that
harkins was
that we were losing the war and
everything general harkin said was an
illusion
and maxwell taylor
who had put harkins into vietnam
persuaded kennedy
to appoint him the commanding general in
vietnam general hawkins was one of
general taylor's proteges general taylor
had enormous influence on the army
leadership of that period and that
most many of the figures who dominated
the army were proteges of general taylor
and he cancelled the briefing
he had the briefing cancelled
at that time the secretary of defense
was robert mcnamara secretary of state
was dean rusk right
uh and uh the president was still john
kennedy and what did those three men
feel about this effort in vietnam at
that point they thought again that they
had the situation under control was john
paul van the lone voice at that point he
was the lone if you will he was the most
outspoken the center uh within the
system at that point but he wasn't the
lone voice because
what he was saying
inside you could read in print in the
news columns because the advisors were
talking to us
let me back up for one moment
uh there's a considerable misimpression
about the role of the press in vietnam
all along and particularly in this early
period
the reporters who went to vietnam early
on like myself were not anti-war
dissenters
we were very much in favor of american
intervention in vietnam we had the same
set of illusions everyone else did
what we wanted to what we felt was our
was our duty
excuse me we felt our duty was to report
the truth so that the president would
know what was happening in vietnam the
president and the rest of the leadership
and win the war
and the advisers in the field like john
van told us look this isn't working
the policy isn't working we're losing
and here's why
and we were writing these stories
and uh and they were being denounced let
me ask you about the statement you made
earlier about john paul van you said he
was brilliant
yes he was a brilliant soldier how did
you determine who was brilliant and who
wasn't well
by comparing it with us with his
contemporaries
um
he stood out among the field advisors
then uh you've got to remember this was
a small war effort 62-63
there were perhaps 3 500 advisers on in
the field
and we got to know a lot of these men
because we we spent most of our much
most of our time in the field you went
right out in the middle of the battles
we went out and yes
and and got on a helicopter and and and
would spend days walking with uh with
with with arvind battalions any
restrictions on you at that point
no restrictions really there were
restrictions at the beginning kennedy
administration the first would not let
us go out in operations but then they
lifted the restrictions and let us go
there was pressure
on the advisors
to
get us to write optimistic stories
but once you get on the field that was
abandoned these ten were young captains
and majors and lieutenant colonels
and they weren't about to
to try to hide the truth from they
didn't try to hide the truth from us
in fact they discovered that we were the
only people who would listen to them
the commanding general in saigon
wouldn't listen to them when they told
him things weren't working
that the arvind would that the south
vietnamese army wouldn't fight the zm
regime was deliberately holding
deliberately holding it back from
fighting
uh that they wouldn't take on the
communist guerrillas because ziam wanted
to preserve his army as a force in being
to preserve his regime
the americans thought of the army the
south vietnamese army is the force of
which to fight the communists jim saw it
as a force to keep him in power
and so he had a he had a secret order
out to his commanders not to take
casualties and the advisers couldn't get
them to tangle with the with the
guerrillas and they would tell us this
and so we were reporting this because we
thought that if we got the facts out
that someone in authority back here
would listen
was anybody reading what you were
writing back here they were reading it
and they were denouncing it i mean
uh uh general hawkins was was uh and the
ambassador
were denouncing what we were saying
anybody in congress reading it and
responding some of them were where were
were were raising doubts remember who
they were uh uh well it started out with
with uh with people like who
many of them
began to use it for their own purposes
uh because they turned against the war
um uh it would
at the beginning it would i i can't
remember the congressman in
well let me give you an example yes mike
mansfield who was senate majority leader
mansfield came out on a mansfield was
one of those who had been an original
backer of xem
and mike mansfield came out and he's
hardly a radical current ambassador to
japan right and he was then senate
majority leader
and he came out on a trip
and he decided
that the
that the reporters were reflecting what
the advisers in the field were saying
and that what the american ambassador
and the commanding general was saying
were not correct and he handed in a
report to president kennedy to this
effect and it didn't change things
when you sat down to write this book
some 15 years ago and you said it has
taken you 15 years to complete it
who did you have in mind to read it
what would make you the most
happy if what kind of person read this
book
i would be most happiest i guess if
people read this book who
who
whose
sons and first of all
i would hope i would i would be most
pleased if the veterans read it
because it was their war
but also it was the war of a lot of
other people in this country the mothers
who sent their sons off the mothers and
fathers who sent their sons off their
sisters and and wives and and others who
knew them i would i would be
i i would hope that the cadets would
read it i would hope that that
also i would be most pleased if young
people like my daughters for whom
vietnam is history would read it
and and and that it would would
bring a wisdom to them that an earlier
generation didn't have
we're talking with neil sheehan
author of a bright shining light
john paul van and america in vietnam
published by random house
we'll be back with the third in our
series of interviews with neil sheehan
after we take a short break
c-span is the cable industry's public
affairs network
since 1979 c-span has provided
nationwide audiences and insiders look
at
[Music]
this afternoon c-span is airing a series
of interviews with neil sheehan the
author of a new book entitled a bright
shining lie
john paul van and america in vietnam
the book is not only a biography of john
paul van one of the senior american
advisors in vietnam for nearly a decade
it's also a history of american
involvement in the vietnam war
our next interview with mr sheehan looks
at the role the media played in covering
the vietnam war
[Music]
you know she and author of a bright
shining lie john paul van in america in
vietnam
what role did the press play
in the war
at the beginning i suspect the press
helped us
to go to war in vietnam
uh
the
the press was in general the
the news media of this country in my
opinion
tend to be
quite conventional
they reflect conventional ideas
they are not
the
cabal of liberal plotters that the right
wing would have us believe at least that
thus that thesis doesn't stand up to
reality in my experience in the
beginning
you you have
first of all
let's take my help myself and the small
group of reporters in saigon
we were objecting to the way they were
the world was being fought because the
advisors in the field the military
advices in the field were telling us
that it was being lost but our objective
was to help the country win the war we
thought it our duty to report the truth
so that we could win if you take the
press back here
they were by and large uh accepting what
the kennedy administration was saying
and then later on what president johnson
was saying i'll give you a very good
example of it the tonkin golf incident
of august 1964.
that was a wonderful case of news
management where
the administration had inadvertently
provoked a clash between the
vietnamese between north vietnamese
torpedo boats and our destroyers
they announced that the attack had been
unprovoked even though they knew at that
point they had inadvertently provoked it
no one's in the news media question
their version of events
uh and the the uh uh tonkin gulf
resolution sailed right through the
senate in fact it was sponsored by
senator fulbright who also didn't
question at that point uh and if you
watch um
uh walter cronkite
if you watch the recordings of cbs
evening news
walter cronkite sounds like a pentagon
spokesman in 1965 and 1966 and i hope
i'm not in making mr cronkite angry by
saying this
but he's essentially uh
repeating in an enthusiastic way what
what what what he's being told it is
only after 1968
after tech 68 the communist head
offensive of 68 which disillusioned the
general public
that you find
a an anti-war bias
coming into the news media in general
you find figures like cronkite really
questioning the war
and that was crushed again by agnew and
nixon in 69 and 70 with their attacks on
the press and you don't find it really
asserting itself again until 72 when the
country
begins to absolutely get fed up with the
whole thing and there's another crisis
in vietnam so that
the the role of the media initially was
i think to help us get in and that they
reinforced what they what the the
administration
was trying to do
uh and then you do i think find the
media reinforcing
uh
the the
the course of getting out of vietnam
which was inevitable in any case because
we had lost the war by
by tech 68
and the television reporting and news
reporting reinforces that impression by
reflecting but it was reflective of
reality i do not think the media
got us out of vietnam a lot sooner
in fact nixon was able to persist in the
face of an unpopular war i think they
did help finally to get us out yeah but
they were not a controlling factor the
news media were a contributing factor i
don't think they ever are a controlling
factor a fellow that i knew who's now
deceased worked for a major network used
to tell the story
that in order for him to get his
film at that time on the evening news he
would leak a story to a print reporter
in vietnam so that by the time the film
got back on an airplane his editors in
new york
would feel like they could put it on
because it had already been news did you
ever find people when you're with the
new york times or even upi
uh
using that
as a legitimate reason to continue
publishing any story of any kind well
i did with the print media we did not we
with the print media we we tended to
fuel each other only by competition if
somebody
got a story that somebody else didn't
have of course then your boss wanted to
know why you didn't have it but i found
that in that period of time and that's
early when print was still was still
much more powerful than it is now
i did find often the television was
driven by print yes uh television
editors the senior people in new york uh
would open up the he would look at the
front page of the new york times and if
the new york times was running the story
prominently they wanted it yes
television people told me that
uh i was frequently told that that
and of course the wire services played a
major role in two with with because a
lot of papers did not have foreign
correspondence and and and uh
if the wire services
were running a story in a strong way yes
then it certainly did affect television
coverage because i think it gave the
television
it's the
television reporters told me it gave
their editors confidence that this is
what we ought to be running on our on
our evening news show etc or in our
morning news show
i think print did affect television much
more than it then than it probably does
now but again i do want to say that
let's take the converse of the myth that
the media
lost the war for us in vietnam
if it weren't for these for all of this
bad
report that is bad news reporting we
would have won
let's take the converse of that
let's say that uh the
print reporters had written nothing but
optimistic stories the sort of thing
that would come up that would please the
pentagon as a press release let's say
that television suppressed all of those
ugly pictures of bodies of burning
houses
let's say they even suppressed gaffes
like general westmoreland giving a press
conference at the american embassy in
saigon uh with the bodies of the
vietcong sappers who had penetrated the
cop up littering the place right after
they'd announced that 67 of the
population was living under american
security etc
uh
i think the result would have been that
the american public would have ceased to
believe
its own media because this is what's
happened in other countries this is what
we would have ended up with pravda prior
to
mikhail gorbachev and glasnost
people in the soviet union don't didn't
believe what they read in their own
newspapers or saw on their own
television and this has happened before
in world war one the british and french
and german press
almost universally lied about what's
happened what was happening in the
trenches
and their own public
and particularly their own soldiers
ceased to believe what they were reading
because they knew it was lies
the word gets back
uh and so i think the the the war in
vietnam would have ended as it did
without
the news media the news media hastened
us in and hastened us out but they
didn't affect the they didn't determine
excuse me
determine the outcome in your 860 page
book
a bright shining light john paul van and
american vietnam obviously john paul van
plays a major role the purpose of our
discussion right now i want to talk
about
how john paul van used you or how you
used him
or better put maybe the interaction of
the two how did you all come to get so
close to one another and not just you
but the rest of the press well in the
beginning as uh the press corps was very
small it was less than a dozen of us
and
the main action was occurring in the
northern mekong delta south of right
south of saigon because that area had
not yet fallen to the communist
guerrillas and van was the senior
adviser to the vietnamese division that
was assigned responsibility for the
whole of the northern delta so it was
and reporters follow a story
it was natural that we would go down and
cover events that were occurring in the
seventh division area
and when we discovered that this senior
advisor to the division there was an
extremely bright lieutenant colonel this
fellow right here in the middle i want
to destroy and that's daniel ellsberg
standing on his left that's right it's
daniel ellsberg over on on john van's
left holding a carbine that's the fall
of 1965 when band had gone back to
vietnam as a civilian
uh in the pacification program and was
pacification advised in a very insecure
province out west just west of saigon
where that picture is being taken that
was a um
dan ellsberg had just come over there
as a member of general edward lansdale's
team
and he'd gone out to hounia to travel
around the province with john van and
that's when the beginning of their
friendship occurred okay i didn't mean
to interrupt but i wanted the audience
to see what john paul land looked like
and you were starting to talk about how
you got to know john paul van the the
the reporters
went down
uh to to his area to cover the war
because that's where the the real action
was occurring as i said reporters cover
a story a follow a story and that's
where the action was and we just we we
discovered that this man uh who was the
senior advisor this lieutenant colonel
was the senior adviser of this division
was an extremely bright man
uh who very quickly
came to understand the realities of the
war to the extent of an american could
understand it in that period of time he
could analyze it with much
much more precision than anyone else
and he began to to teach us an awful lot
about what was happening in vietnam and
it made sense
because let me give you an example
the ordinary advisor would say to you
we're losing a lot of weapons to the
outposts we're supplying the south
vietnamese militia in the outpost the
guerrillas come along and they overrun
the outpost and capture the american
weapons
john vann had gone around and made a
study of exactly how many outposts there
were in his area
and exactly how many weapons were
flowing through them and he would sit
you down and say now look if we continue
to supply the
south vietnamese militia at this rate
with 700 plus outposts in my area we're
going to start pumping an enormous
number of weapons thousands of weapons
into the communist guerrillas and we're
going to end up with an enemy who's far
more powerful because far more better
armed than the than the guerrillas we
face now who are using these old french
weapons from the french indochina war
this country that is the united states
we the united states of america are
arming our enemy
and uh giving them far better weapons
than they already have and we're going
to change the whole the whole kind of
we're going to change the world we're
fighting we're we're creating a monster
here
john could do that sort of thing he had
those insights and so we were drawn to
him and also he was a very he was a very
uh he was a fearless man
physically fearless man he was always
out in the field
uh uh and uh
he had great charisma to him uh and and
you're drawn to a person like that was
the attitude of the general harkins at
that point could you go see him and
would he explain to you what was going
on at first john john van was managed to
kill so many vietcong that he was
general hawkins favorite advisor as i
say in the book
uh because uh general harkins uh
general harkins initially ignored
the
things that displeased him general in
charge in vietnam
right the commanding general he's he's
passed away
he died a number of years ago but but he
was then the commanding general of
vietnam he'd been senior staff aide to
george patton during world war ii
but he was quite different than general
patton
uh he he
at first van was his favorite advisor uh
because van was getting was killing so
many gorillas
until uh
the battle of opback occurred january 63
and the saigon side suffered a really
stunning defeat and all the warnings van
had been
sending general harkins in his
after-action reports came true band kept
saying that this army is not fighting
won't fight and disaster lies ahead then
van wen
then van started really opening up to us
uh and telling us what he really
that is he he began to open up to us
about about
uh he began to leak to us
uh leaked storage
he began to leak his reports to general
harkins
uh he would sit you down and he would he
would lay out for you what he was
telling general harkins lieutenant
colonel
taking on the commanding taking on the
commanding general by leaking reports to
you right he was willing to do it well
how would you publish this what would
you say in your story we would attribute
them to an american advisor or american
advisers uh we tried to disguise it as
much as we could did they know right
away who was doing it maybe general it
became pretty obvious very quickly
who
was the source of a lot of the reporting
coming out of the northern mekong delta
because van didn't try to hide it in
fact we tried to we cautioned him we
said john
don't be so bold about this thing uh uh
we'll we'll disguise it more you're
getting yourself in deep trouble
professionally because when a lieutenant
colonel takes on
a four-star general
even if he protects himself to some
extent by denying he's leaking things
and even if the reporters protect them
there are private ways unofficial ways
in which revenge can be taken and we
kept saying to john look but he he
insisted on on he was quite bold about
it he he said no no no no he wanted to
i'm not you're not hurting me anymore
that i want to be hurt it turned out as
i explained in the book there were
personal reasons why he no longer felt
he had a career in the army and he was
willing to throw it away but he also did
have moral courage he was willing to
take on the commanding general because
he thought
the commanding general was losing the
war who else was john paul van leaking
to
besides you david halverston new york
times new york times uh in fact
halberston was the was the reporter whom
van focused as i say in the book
halberson was the reporter whom van
focused on most to whom with whom he
became closest
because john's first of all john was an
enormous source to us
uh he was edu he educated us he was a
source of information but john very
quickly sensed that what david
halvestone wrote
was the most had the most impact because
because the new york times was was the
most powerful paper in the world
particularly in that period of time the
president of the united states read what
david alveston wrote and if you uh uh if
you talk to david halberston and he he
reported it
it was going to get to the attention of
the senior leadership of this country
right away or is this picture
that is a picture of david halverston
up in the central highlands actually not
down in vance area up in the central
highlands vietnam fording a stream with
a backpack on his he was doing a trip up
to the highlands uh he's out in the
field with a group of south vietnamese
soldiers who were right beyond him
crossing the stream and the picture was
taken by a
a
photographer for the ap named horst foss
who won two pulitzers in vietnam david
and horst had been friends in the
belgian congo
when they both covered that and they
were both on an operation with the with
the vietnamese when horse took that
picture as david said knee deep in the
big muddy later on uh before we leave
that
mr halperstein pulitzer prize winner a
book he wrote right around this time
david won a pulitzer david and malcolm
brown shared a pulitzer for their
reporting in vietnam uh and then david
went on to write a number of books the
most famous
first of which was on account of his
experiences in vietnam in 6263 called
the making of a quagmire and then a book
published in 1972 which was an
indictment of the american leadership
that led us to vietnam call the best and
the brightest and did you replace him as
a new york times reporter in vietnam
uh well i went back to vietnam no i
didn't really replace him there were a
couple of people in between but at the
time i i
david when david and i first knew each
other i was working for the upi then i
went to work for the time since david
left vietnam in the end of 63 december
of 63. i went to work for the new york
times in 64 and then the time sent me
back to vietnam in the middle of 65
august of
1965. at the time the american milit
when the u.s army and the marine corps
were coming to take over the war that
had had failed the advisory war had
failed as van had said it would
uh and they and the regime was in danger
of falling and they sent the us army and
the marine corps in i went back there to
be a reporter for the time the time sent
me there
a reporter named charlie moore who was
then the bureau chief who'd also gone
out there whom i'd known earlier when he
was chief correspondent for time charlie
asked me to come and report the war with
him cover the war with him i was first
sent down to indonesia
after i went to work for the times and
charlie wanted me to come back to
vietnam and cover the war with him and
so i did and then a
a reporter who's now chief political
course who chief washington
correspondent uh rw apple johnny apple
came out and joined us so were there
there were three of us in 1965 the year
of the build-up charlie moore johnny
apple and i why you said the new york
times was the most powerful newspaper
why
because the united states was the most
powerful country in the world
and the times was was in the position of
the times of london when
a quarter of the world was
pink with red if you will with the
scarlet tunics of a british soldier at
the high noon of the british empire uh
uh in 1963 uh
the
the american the united states of
america was at the high noon of its
power
and adolf ox who founded the new york
times uh he bought a bankrupt paper
had
in mind when he bought it
shortly afterwards developed the idea
that
he would
create an established and
if you will an establishment paper a
paper that would be respectable
that would print the truth
uh and
not not
not the sort of
uh scandal if you will that the american
press so often did print at the time
uh the so-called yellow journalism he
wasn't interested in that he wanted a
solid a respectable paper that would
would uh uh
become reliable that would be relied on
for for its for its news coverage and
the times grew and obviously and became
the most respected paper in this country
and then when this country was the most
powerful country in the world i think
the times became the most respected
paper in the world why not the
washington post for instance
the post had not at that point grown to
the stature it has now
the post was then
a beginning to to grow but it did had
did not have the stature it had that it
has now
the times was what dominated
the print field uh and it was read in
washington it wasn't read by a large
number of people in washington but it
was read by the people who counted in
washington it was read by by by uh uh
people who counted abroad that is the
times had a news service
so that if you reported something in the
new york times that the president was
going to read it
and the van knew that and he cultivated
halbuston for that reason what do you
think of cultivated the rest of us too
but he cultivated albertson predicted
what
you know you obviously have seen more of
this kind of journalism than just this
particular instance what do you think of
i just noticed a sentence or two here
that you wrote harkins and nolting never
ceased complaining about us hoping that
our editors would fire us and replace us
with more cooperative types
frustrating for a military
to have their subordinates leaking to
major publications and undercutting what
they're doing
frustrating for a military leader yeah
uh and frustrating for an ambassador who
was who shared the same illusions as the
commanding general oh of course they
wanted and they were you got to remember
that prior to vietnam
uh there hadn't been any disagreements
serious disagreements
between the news media
of the country
and the political and military
leadership of the country
we had pretty well marched and stepped
through the cold war
because
there hadn't been any occasion
in which reality
reality on the ground was conflicting
with what the political and military
leadership was saying
the problem the reporters had in vietnam
was that what we saw in the field and
what we were told by the advisors in the
field the men who counted like john van
and other advisers and by the captains
who worked for van was in direct
conflict with what we were being told by
the commanding general in saigon
and so this was a unique
at that time
a unique event uh in american politics
and journalism and these generals
weren't used to report excuse me
generals like harkins and ambassadors
like nolte
were not accustomed to american
reporters who who were saying that they
were consistently wrong
we weren't accustomed to generals who
were consistently wrong either had this
been a declared war
well could this have happened no yes the
same thing could have happened of course
but would john paul vanish survived in a
declared war with some maybe even
censorship implied we had censorship in
vietnam
throughout the war
uh uh legal censorship or just uh it was
it was effective censorship it was
tactical censorship they didn't read
your dispatches but there were ground
rules
if you could not report on operations
prior to them occurring we had military
censorship
you could not report on an operation
prior to its occurring
you could not at one point report the
precise number of casualties
uh you could say they were moderate
light or heavy but you couldn't give the
precise number of killed or wounded
there were a lot of rules uh that if you
did not follow your your accreditation
was removed and you couldn't get on
military aircraft
uh you couldn't attend military
briefings uh they enforced censorship
military censorship throughout the war
what they could not enforce
was the sen was was was the view of the
war
that we were conveying uh and and that's
what frustrated them you uh what they
couldn't enforce was was to sit down and
turn an account of a battle into a press
release
which didn't reflect the what general
hawkins was sending back
to washington his reports
did simply didn't reflect what was
happening in the field
and
he was furious
that our reporting
contradicted
what he was saying and of course his own
officers in the field
were contradicting what he was saying
and he wouldn't listen to them and they
would tell him general
uh uh
we have lost this
battle for x reasons he simply wouldn't
listen were there reporters that you
worked with in vietnam other
publications that
were reporting a different view of the
war than you were
most of the resident correspondents in
vietnam at that time
um
uh
were reporting basically the same
thing
excuse me their reporting had the same
flavor they were reporting the same
events are they all getting their
information from john paul vance no they
were getting it from other advisors as
well but but we were going out into the
field and we're seeing what was
happening we were reporting and the
advisors as they grew more frustrated
i'm talking about the men in the field
now from lieutenant colonel on down as
they grew more frustrated they turned
more and more to the reporters because
we were the only people who would listen
to them now you would get and then you
began to get reporters from outside like
bernie cal of cbs charlie moore who was
then chief correspondent for time they
came in and they they began to see that
that uh what the loca what the resident
correspondents were reporting was true
and they were reporting reflected as
well you did get people who would come
out like the late margarite higgins for
instance
who
had been very critical when she was in
korea
of the way the war was being fought but
when she got to vietnam she had she she
uh like so many uh
well like the
political leadership of the country she
assumed these generals knew what they
were talking about
and she wrote a series of articles i
remember in in august of 63 saying we
were a bunch of of of young cub
reporters who who didn't know what we
were talking about and we wanted to see
the united states lose the war that sort
of thing would hurt you
because you wanted to see the united
states win the war you were simply
trying to get the truth about it out yes
there were some that usually who would
come in and and who would say that we
were all wrong
that uh
we used to laugh about it uh uh because
it was it made no sense at all i think
there were people who they were people
in in her case who genuinely who were
acting on faith
because they had never dealt with
generals who really didn't know what
they were talking about before given
your experience and
this book and other books
uh could a vietnam ever happen again to
the united states no
well not in the foreseeable future i
think vietnam has changed this country
for the foreseeable future at least
uh are you an event like vietnam is
unique in the history of a country
vietnam was our first bad war
previously when you went off to war as
an american
you came you uh you came home having
proved your manhood and you were slapped
on the back and your cause was honored
even the confederate side
lost its war and i happen to think they
had a bad cause
but in their home communities they were
honored and they ran for office on their
war records
but
vietnam for whatever reason you you wish
to to say that the war was fought the
wrong way or that the cause was unjust
was a bad war
and it was the first it was the first
war in which americans could get could
and did get killed for nothing
now the europeans had learned that you
could go to war and get killed for
nothing that you could go to war and
your uh in which you could get involved
in the war in which your leadership was
was was driven by illusions rather than
reality we had never learned that as a
nation
that had never been driven home to us
war had always been a good experience in
the american historical conscious
consciousness and so
i think the impact of that on us
has been so profound because the
war was so divisive
that it remains with us today and you
the president of the united states
cannot so blightly send americans off to
war
as
he does not have the power to do it that
kennedy and johnson had because the
public doesn't give him the credibility
that it gave them those presidents we're
talking with neil sheen
this is the book published by random
house
about 860 some pages a bright shining
lie john paul van
an america in vietnam
included in this some 385
interviews
some 630 hours of audio tape
and lots of other background information
on mr shins
reporting from vietnam
from the year 1962 onward
[Music]
[Music]
you're watching c-span
coming up next we'll air the fourth in
our series of interviews with author
neil sheehan the author of a bright
shining lie john paul van and america in
vietnam
he covered the vietnam war for the new
york times and his new book is a
biography of one of the senior american
advisors in vietnam john paul vann and a
history of american and
our fourth interview with mr sheehan
looks at john paul van
[Music]
neil sheehan author of a bright shining
light john paul van and america in
vietnam
when you think of john paul van what do
you remember first
i guess i remember this
extraordinary lieutenant colonel
down in the mekong delta in 6263 when i
first met in this
banty rooster of a man with this
rasping virginia twang who was fearless
extremely bright explained the war to
you in a way nobody else could
who was always on the field
driving roads nobody else would drive
getting involved in in in firefights
this extremely colorful man who to whom
i was very much attracted as a young
reporter that's the van i i most
remember
the guy who summed up the kind of
qualities we admired so much in
ourselves then physical drive
the will to win
incisive thinking
that's the van i i remember
you knew him as early as 62 yes i met
john in 62 when i was a young reporter
and first went to vietnam
and thought i knew him i considered him
a friend because i did see a lot of him
in that first year and then i saw him
later on when i came back here and
briefly when he was in this country then
i saw him when i went back to vietnam
again in 65 66 and he was back in
vietnam
and i thought i knew john well
but after i began to research the book
after he died
after he was killed in vietnam at the
end of 10 years in
june of 72
and i decided to write a book about him
and about the war i discovered that he
was an exceedingly complicated person
and that we all thought we knew john van
and none of us knew him did he did he
ever lie to you
yes john john deceived me yes uh he
deceived all of us in that first year uh
in that
we thought he was
throwing away a career
to take on the commanding general and
warn about the fact that we were losing
the war in vietnam
it turned out that he was taking on he
did take on the commanding general and
he did have moral courage but it turned
out that
he had
uh a black spot on his record
which he knew would bar him from
promotion to general and he really
didn't have a career to throw away at
that point what was that black spot
he'd been charged with statutory rape
because of an affair with a 15 year old
girl
uh when he was at the commanding general
staff college
and he had beaten the charge in the
sense that the case had never come to
trial
but
in fact he beat a lie detector but uh it
turned out that but but the
investigation the record was still in
his file
and it would bar him from
being promoted in general he would have
gone as far as colonel but he would
never have gotten stars because a
general officer board
at least he was convinced of it and i
think he was correct a general officer
board is looking for reasons to reject
people
not to promote there are many more men
than there are stars to give many more
candidates than our stars to give and
they're looking for reasons to reject
you
and even though he had a brilliant
record
and was an extremely brave officer
he knew that he simply wouldn't they
wouldn't take a risk
that um
a general officer would have the sexual
compulsions that he had
he was a man of as i said of great
public professional honesty as i say in
the book
enormous professional honesty and
courage and these private
personal deceits which would bear light
which came out of his childhood
an illegitimate child
john yes john was an illegitimate was
illegitimate he was born in norfolk
virginia
uh
he was a very poor family
his mother
the problem wasn't that he was
illegitimate it was that his mother was
cruel to him
she she held his illegitimacy
up to him
she wouldn't allow his stepfather to
adopt him
when he was
he was finally adopted when he was 18
and later on many years later when he
was filling out a government security
clearance form this is motherboard
this is his mother yeah this is a
picture of his mother how old was she
here she was probably in her 30s then
she was she was
she was a woman who tended to attack
the men around her
attacked their masculinity if you will
uh
by by by cruelty
and she was she was very cruel to him
she hurt him deeply
and he
he had to overcome a great deal to
escape from that world of his childhood
and it it scarred him personally what
his mother did for a living
his mother
as i said in the book was a
she was she was a
a part-time
uh
she sold herself uh to to put it mildly
part of the time not always probably
yeah she hold herself and that hurt him
but the shame of it hurt him
but i think what hurt him even more was
the fact that she withheld love from him
he grew up as a in effect as a
motherless child
and it's very sad when that happens to a
person
i think what one's mother does might
cause one shame but if one is if if love
is withheld if one is rejected that
hurts even more who raised him
he was raised by his stepfather
and then a a frank van
who adopted him and who would have
adopted him early on and then he escaped
from norfolk
when he was in his late teens he was
desperate to get away from his family
situation and he encountered a minister
named garland hopkins a local
uh minister
uh at a
at a local methodist church
um who was a progressive man and who
sent him off to a uh
methodist boarding school
in the foothills of the of the blue
ridge mountains in in in southwestern
virginia a place called fearum at that
time freedom training school and junior
college it's now fearum college uh and
he broke out of that world through that
and then he went into the army during
army air corps during world war ii and
and broke out of that world and and
became
uh here's that's a picture of john
just as he's going off the theorem uh um
he that
sport jacket and pants
had been bought for him by a rich
oysterman in norfolk who was in effect
the patron of this methodist church and
who would
and who wrote who paid for his
scholarship at fear him as well and what
and and who would who backed the
minister
there who
in effect picked up the deficit
of the church for the minister uh and
had sent him off and that was his first
escape he escaped to fear him
that's the first time where he got three
square meals a day they were so
desperately impoverished he grew up of
course in the great depression in
norfolk in a poor white working-class
district
and they were so desperately
impoverished the vans that
most of the most the average the
standard meal at the van house cooked by
his stepfather would be fried potatoes
and biscuits
and his youngest brother
got rickets as a result of the vitamin
deficiency and his legs had to be broken
to straighten them ricketts bows the
legs
uh and um in fact you have a picture i
think that's right of his his youngest
brother who was a who's a wonderful man
uh this is his real brother yes his his
uh
well
half brother
technically half brother uh emotionally
his real brother they were they were
quite close
um he was his youngest brother
and um they were quite close and he
that youngest brother also broke out and
has had a very successful career and is
a wonderful man how much total education
did john paul van have he had a very
fine education actually
he uh
broke out of norfolk and got the theorem
and got two years of junior college
then went into the army air corps came
out
went to college
at rutgers spent a year there then
switched to the infantry finally got the
bs from rutgers in the mid 50s in
business administration the army then
sent into syracuse on a master's program
and he ended up with uh he was a
extremely bright man
and he ended up with
all but two court two courses short of a
thesis
uh for his phd in for a phd in public
administration as well as a master's in
business plus he went through uh all the
service schools short of the war college
he went through commander general staff
and the army has a schooling system of
its own and he went up through the army
schooling system so john was a highly
educated person
um
at least in
highly educated in in the sense of in a
technical way he was best
he had that peculiar ability
to understand human problems
and also to deal with them in a very
hard factual way he was a statistician
by training among other things as a
result of this this training in business
administration
uh and it gave him a a capacity to
take a human situation and put it into
quantitative terms
very very effectively he could lay
things out for you the facts etc even
statistically uh for for instance
um the the he would he would show you
why this how the south vietnam
vietnamese army wasn't fighting he'd lay
out the number of actions they were
involved in the number they claimed the
number of contacts they claimed to have
with the vietcong and then he'd point
out that
they weren't actually engaging the
vietcong in any of these here were the
number of casualties
john would do that sort of analysis it
was very clear that they were they were
simply faking things they would claim
they were going on patrols they would
report 500 patrols a month and they'd
have 13 contacts with the enemy or two
casualties and as john said at one point
he could he could he could have
generated more contacts on his own uh
but he had that ability to to take a
look at the situation and and and
draw these this this hard this hard data
from it uh
and
it was it was a particular turn of mine
he had but it also came out of his
education came a great source for you in
vietnam yes he was he was he really
educated a whole generation of reporters
there
because john's ideas john had the
capacity to analyze the war
and show us what was wrong with the way
first we were waging war in the kennedy
years that it was stupid
to be shelling and bombing civilian
hamlets that we were just killing women
and kids and we were turning the
population against us
uh
he showed us the extent to which the
arvind the regular south vietnamese army
was avoiding contact with the enemy and
would not fight
vietcong would not take them on he
showed us the extent to which we were
arming the guerrillas through these
outposts
again john would gather the data
precisely how many how much how many how
many american arms were going through
precisely how many outposts and and and
and we ended up as i said in the book we
ended up arming the viet cong in south
vietnam with american weapons because
the american generals were
pouring weapons into the south
vietnamese militia and the vietcong were
collecting them from these outposts and
so you were giving a communist gorilla
who had a bolt-action french rifle a
fast-firing semi-automatic m1 garand
which was a world war ii weapon but
which was a very good weapon in the mid
in the early 60s this is prior to the
fully automatic weapons the m16 etc the
m1 grant was a fine weapon and we were
we were arming there are arming our
enemy and john pointed those things out
to us he he gave us tools with which to
analyze the war that we wouldn't have
had without him flew his own airplane
uh
he later on ended up yes john john uh uh
ended up as a qua he he never was an
officially qualified helicopter pilot
but uh he got his pilot to teach him how
to fly he'd wanted to fly during world
war ii and and did get as far as flight
training and then got bounced for doing
loop the loop
moved all over vietnam in a plane off
helicopter yeah and helicopters or light
planes um
he did constantly on the move he was a
man who had to be on the move there's
massive amounts of material in your book
uh about uh the battles and how he
played a role but there's
there's one
two or three line sentence i want to
read you that just pops right out of the
page and i happen to read it first in
the new yorker and i want to ask you
before i ask you about this line
why did the new yorker devote so many
pages over four issues to your book
well i i think bob gottlieb thought he
liked it very much and he thought that
if he excerpted if he concentrated on
excerpting uh the
biography of van himself and the high
points of it that he would have a very
intense story that he could lay out for
the reader with a lot of narrative drive
an intense series a very good intense
series that would tell the story of the
war through this through through this
man's experience but which would focus
very narrowly on john vann and those
were the sections of the book he took
unusual for the new yorker to give all
that much space to one issue
look it it it has been for bob gottlieb
it wasn't for his predecessor sean
william shawn
often ran long series
um
that is four
would run four and five uh uh
excuse me would run a series of four or
five articles on the same subject but
bob gottlieb had initially intended to
to reduce that and basically he has he's
run shorter things but in the case of
the book he he had initially planned on
running three and then he discovered he
that he wouldn't fit that he simply he
had to go to four so he ended up running
a four-part series of 88 000 words in
all which is quite long for the current
new yorker yes okay by the way how many
words in the book
about 360 000
here's the here's the sentence and and
there's a lot behind this and i want you
to to tell us about it van like to
convey confide details of his sexual
exploits to ellsberg
the two stories here sexual exploits and
daniel ellsberg and the only reason i
want to ask you about the sexual
exploits is that you mentioned earlier
when you talk about this he led several
different lives paul john paul maher yes
tell us about it well john the private
side of him was this uh was this man
with this these powerful sexual
compulsions he was an incredible
womanizer
uh did you know that when you're in
vietnam no
he hid it from us his first year
and he also kept it under control his
first year he'd go off with
friends to
a saigon or down to a beach resort and
he kept it under control he would john
was a man who could play roles and he
was very conscious that if you fooled
around with women
in the place where you worked then the
vietnamese lost respect for you
and so he didn't do it he turned out to
be an incredible womanizer first of all
some of this he inherited
some of it was in his genes
his father was a womanizer it turned out
his real father
um
his bio if you will by a lot his natural
father
and but but then the insecurities
implanted in by his mother
i think fed this compulsion in him so
that uh
he was he was a driven man sexually
and
he
ellsberg and ellsberg and he of course
went on totally different directions on
the war
but it was daniel ellsworth doing in
vietnam but in the beginning dan
ellsberg went out there to help win the
war like everyone else he believed in it
uh and then ellsberg ended up turning
against the war but ellsberg was a very
adventurous guy and and he and van very
quickly became
best friends
ellsberg would go out in the field with
van on these on these trips
and uh john tended if he thought someone
would listen he liked to boast about the
sexual exploits of his and so he he
told ellsberg things right away that he
often didn't tell other people i
discovered after the new yorker series
was published that some of his friends
although they knew he was an incredible
womanizer didn't didn't didn't know
about
particular uh things that for instance
that statutory rape incident that
ruined his army career how did you find
out all this
first of all from his former wife mary
jane
she was genu well she was married to him
when the statutory rape incident
occurred and she helped get him off the
hook by by committing perjury for him uh
uh in the investigation in the military
investigation to it of course she felt
threatened as well it threatened her
family what would she do if her husband
was court-martialed and had to resign
from the army this is back in the 50s
the end of the 50s
at that time soldiers with dishonorable
discharges we're having a rough time
finding good jobs this in the
pre-vietnam period what would an officer
been dismissed from the army do this is
a felony with a very serious charge
and so she knew about it obviously she
had to and she was as i said
she was a married changed woman of great
courage and honesty and when she decided
to talk to me she told me everything she
knew
and that's when i first discovered how
complicated he was
that he had this private side to him
uh this of this man driven by these
compulsions uh and he had then then this
contradictory public sign
of rigid professional honesty of a firm
grasp on reality at least in the
beginning
he lost it after 10 when he couldn't
give up on the war and he began to
rationalize things in order to stay but
prior to that he had this very firm
grasp on reality and he fascinated me
for that reason i mean my fascination
with him deepened when i learned these
things because he had all these
contradictions
died in 1972 in a in a airplane crash in
vietnam yes a helicopter crash he was
killed at the time he was killed
divorced from his wife mary jane who
lived in denver right five kids
he lived yeah she lived right next to
denver and littleton right yes she had
divorced him and he was about to marry a
vietnamese woman by whom he had had a
daughter
and there was another woman in besides
this yes yes describe that whole thing i
mean well he he he carried on in vietnam
two
fairly permanent liaisons with two
vietnamese women
both of whom remained ignorant of each
other
until
about until one until he died and the
other one until about a year before he
died
uh
the
by one of these women he had a daughter
um and uh he was going to they were
going to be married he had planned to
marry her shortly before he was killed
taken out papers uh to do so
but he had also been maintaining this
permanent relationship with another
vietnamese woman uh i think john was
sufficiently complicated so he probably
enjoyed that captain's paradise if you
remember that old
movie it was an incredible thing he had
he had his staff trained for instance
to keep both women ignorant of each
other his helicopter pilot knew uh the
secretary knew you weren't supposed to
ever let the one know about the other
and he pulled it off for years
now this is a man who was of utmost
seriousness in his professional work
and
that part of him that the complications
in him made him more interesting to me
and it made him more representative to
me
because
we tend to think of ourselves
as a very simple country with very
simple motivations
and in fact we're a very complicated
people with all sorts of insecurities
and all sorts of fears
and drives which which which motivate us
and and the fact that this man was such
a complicated figure and the fact that
his personal and private life
was directly related to his public
actions
because you can't understand john unless
john van unless you understand his
private compulsions would you tell the
story about the
mistress who i believe her name was
julia julia uh annie annie and annie in
the book uh um go ahead
the the one where annie is a pseudonym
uh
uh and he he uh he called her by a
nickname and i changed i changed the
nickname to another nickname uh and it's
annie okay the but the point here was
the reason i wanted to tell the story
was the involvement that he had with the
woman's father first of all john van
what something around 41 and she was
like 17 or 18. yeah she was i think 17
when they met uh uh you
checked my memory with the book but i
think she's about 17. i don't see him
he'd written about my own book but i
think she was yes she was very young 17.
she had his daughter when i believe she
was 18. her father tried to uh she was a
a fine she's a fine woman she was a fine
woman she was a but she was a young a
romantically inclined young woman who
encountered this american who who uh
who uh uh was far more obviously far
more experienced she she had had no
experience and her father tried to
to stop him and he tried to
make her realize what she was getting
involved in a man who was a womanizer
etc
but her father was totally unsuccessful
her father waited until they came back
one night and he slapped van across the
face
and uh uh told him to leave his daughter
alone and it was fascinating that john
didn't attempt to defend himself how did
you find all that out she told me
this woman she told me about the
incident
there was another time when the father
when she was pregnant
yes she got pregnant then and she
refused to have
have an abortion
and a
van tried to get out of it by ignoring
the whole thing at that point
and her father
her father initially wanted her to try
to to have an abortion because he didn't
want to bring he did not want her to see
her get involved permanently with an
older american man and give up the
possibility of marrying a vietnamese
and having a normal family life but she
was determined to keep the baby and so
he confronted van in his office and he
told him that if he didn't arrange to
provide for
his daughter and for the child to come
in the manner in which she was to be she
was accustomed to living that he was
going to go and complain to the american
ambassador
and so then agreed uh to take on this
responsibility and support this young
woman and the child to come and he did
he had no well he felt he had no choice
he brought it on himself of course
did he ever marry her he was going to
and he called her his wife and his last
will in a will he wrote in the in the
helicopter which is in the book
he wrote he wrote a second will
one day when he thought he was going to
die
toward the end when he was rescuing some
advisors and on his way to to rescue
them they were in a compound the north
vietnamese tanks were bursting into
and that was the one day when he thought
the odds were not gonna what might apply
to him and he really thought that
morning he probably was gonna he was
gonna get it and but at the same time it
was part of his code to go and rescue
his people and he was gonna go get them
and so he wrote a holographic will on a
piece of note paper and he called her
his wife in that will he intended to
marry her but he was killed before he
could do i remember correctly even after
he told her he was going to marry her
and she had had this child that he still
maintained a liaison with this other oh
yes and i don't think he was going to
give up the other one either even after
he got married guess the reason why i
want to even ask you about all this is
how can you
you call him brilliant
how can a man be brilliant and have all
these liaisons going on and still keep
his mind on
the work at hand i think if you look
into
powerful figures in history
you often find that they have very
complicated personalities and very
complicated personal lives now one
reason i laid out john van's personal
life was not because i was trying to
titillate the reader
i tried to write about it as in as
restrained a fashion as i could
but there are there's no there are no
explicit sexual scenes in this book as
you know in fact i managed to write a
book about war without using the
four-letter word
but
i wrote about it because it this was a
man whose personal life and this is
probably true of a lot of historical
figures but we've lost their personal
lives the the the the data the detail
isn't there but this is a man whose
personal life was very tied to his
public actions and
he's and this is a man who affected the
way the war in vietnam turned out the
course of the war would have been
different had it not been for john vann
and john van would not have left the
army
and gone back to vietnam as a civilian
and then done the things he did in
vietnam had it not been for his personal
life in fact is he is he a general right
here in this picture that's right john
was the first civilian first genuine
civilian general in our history in fact
he's the only one i know john's the only
person i know the only figure i know
uh
excuse me let me back up john is the
first case i know of in our history
where a civilian official
and he was at the time an official in
aid
the agency for international development
actually held command and war
now he was by profession a soldier he'd
spent 20 years in the army and retired
but he was technically a civilian
on detail to the army
uh which is a
military excuse me a bureaucratic term
for transferring a person
and he held command uh he held the core
command under general creighton abrams
creating abram to put him in that
position uh on the advice of a friend of
vans who was abram's deputy
fred wyan and he wielded command
he's the first one i know of to do that
now the
the the personal man was very much tied
to the private man you can't understand
the public man without the private man
the things he would do the fearlessness
for instance was tied to his his his pr
the personal man again he i think he was
proving himself over and over again he's
extraordinary the things the the sense
of the the the the desire to be
a a a really fine officer
came out of the desire to get away from
his childhood
all of these things were tied together
you couldn't if you wanted to understand
the man and then you wanted to
understand his impact on the war
and as i as you you have in the book
that extraordinary battle of cantoom in
the end where john van held things
together where the the situation would
have collapsed the panic that broke out
in 75 would have broken out in 72 had it
not been for van he was the he was the
guy who said who who held it together
and it was his personal drives as much
as anything that that that led him to do
that
the book is a bright shining lie the
author is neil sheehan
published by random house john paul van
an america in vietnam
[Music]
[Music]
this afternoon here on c-span we're
looking back at american involvement in
the vietnam war
we've been talking with neil sheehan the
author of a bright shining lie
john paul van and america in vietnam
after this next and last interview with
mr sheehan we'll air a recorded
roundtable discussion with three retired
military officers who served in vietnam
then we'll open up our phone lines to
get your reaction to these discussions
the next and last interview with mr
sheehan is a profile of the author
[Music]
you know shane author of a bright
shining lie john paul van in american
vietnam
when did you first know that you want to
be a writer
when i was in the army oddly enough
i didn't know what i wanted to do in
college i was in the i joined the
literary magazine which was the harvard
advocate and i was an editor there and i
wrote book reviews but and i thought i
wanted to go into publishing
but then i switched to history and
graduated from union harvard and really
in 58 really didn't know what i wanted
to do went in the army and became an
army journalist to get out of a
miserable job as a pay clerk
in korea
and
went down to the division information
office
40 miles closer to seoul and fell into
journalism liked it
got transferred to tokyo to put out the
division newspaper there and started
working moonlighting for the united
press international and then they
offered me a job and i discovered i
decided this is what i wanted to do i
was born
i was born in a small industrial city in
western massachusetts called holyoke i
was actually i was born there but grew
up outside of it just outside of it my
grandfather
had a farm on the edge of it which he
left to my father and farm in the dairy
business which he left my father and my
father's two brothers and my father
my father handled the farming end of it
the cows the field the planting the corn
and that my father loved those things he
was a genuine he kept horses long after
he had a tractor simply because he loved
horses and so i grew up on a farm if you
will and uh and
worked in a farm when i was a young
young man and and and
had those
those advantages i think of a kid who
grows up out in the country it's
wonderful to grow up in the country
the book uh big book 860 some pages
24.95
random house
a bright shining lie
when did you know you had to write this
book
i
decided to write the book in 72
when i went after i went to john van's
funeral
i had spent my whole career
basically most of my career was reported
covering vietnam i'd first gone there in
62
and i had never been able to get away
from the war
of course of course it was the dominant
event of my generation
and as a reporter if you had gone there
early on you probably couldn't get away
from it but i had never succeeded in
getting away and
my last big thing had been obtaining the
pentagon papers for the times in 71 and
i wanted to leave behind something that
would be more permanent than another
magazine article and another newspaper
or another newspaper story and when john
died i realized that if i wrote a book
about this extraordinary man
i could tell the story of the war
through him because he was such a
compelling figure and he summed up in
the 10 years he'd been in vietnam the
american venture there and he summed up
the way we like to think of ourselves
the qualities that we admired in
ourselves in that period this enormous
drive the this this brilliant analytical
mind of this incredible energy sleeping
four hours and only needing four hours
of sleep at night
the fearlessness etc yeah the
extraordinary metabolism
uh all of these things that we we really
admired in ourselves as a people and and
he had he had devoted himself to vietnam
and he had died there and i felt that if
i if i wrote a story a biography of him
i could also write a history of the war
that's why
i started out and then of course i was
trapped in the enterprise
it was too late to go back
you left the new york times when i
left the new york times
in 1972 to go off to vietnam and do my
first research trip
uh i thought i could write the book in
three or four years and i'd go back to
work for the times i took a leave of
absence it turned out that i i
grossly underestimated the task that
running a biography of this complicated
man and writing history of this
complicated war was far more than than a
farm it was going to take me far longer
than than three or four years
and i also had interruptions i lost you
with an auto accident i had to earn a
living by lecturing
and but basically the task was to
research and write a book
about the war
which helped the country i hope come to
grips of the war that would be a book
that was exciting
that would have narrative force and
drive
that would uh um
that was
cast in the form in which truman capote
wrote cold blood
but of course he was writing about one
incident and i was writing about an
awful lot more than that how did you
physically write it in other words when
did you start putting words on paper
and where did you write i started
writing about 1976
and i wrote in a number of places
uh first i had a study in the basement
uh
uh in a basement in the house in my
neighborhood that i read it from an
elderly lady who was
renting out space
then i
had a little office
in maryland at one point
that i was sharing with a friend that
was psycho phys
she's a therapist in psychology
she and a group of psychiat psychiatric
therapists had an office neighbor they
had extra space and they gave me one
then i ultimately
went to the library of congress in 1980
and worked there
in a little space
they the library has
always has it's part of it their policy
given a place to to work and write to
professional writers and scholars
and they gave me a space to put my file
cabinets i had five file canvas at that
point filled with john vance papers and
they gave me a desk and i needed to work
at the library also because i needed
access to its collections for research
purposes library of congress is an
extraordinary place
with an extraordinary collection and and
you have extraordinary access within an
hour and a half you have a book if it's
in stock
excuse me if it's on the shelf and if
it's not they'll look for it for you
and so it was i worked most of the time
there i'd go down i'm a night person
and i believe in working a disciplined
way every day because that's the only
way you get anything done
and my wife also worked at the library
she also wrote did research live with my
wife susan sheehan who's staff writer
for the new yorker so we'd get down at
two we'd get out about two in the
afternoon work until 8 30 at the library
come home have dinner and then i'd work
in my study until about 4 in the morning
at home and then back to the library the
next day
it was
it was a grim business but
it's the way i got through it you
mentioned lecturing excuse the personal
question but how did you financially
survive over these 15 years it was
awfully grim
uh i repeatedly ran out of money i got
an initially a 45 000 advance from
random house that was burned up
i got fellowships
and they
gradually they ran out
um
and in 1979 i had run out of money
i was going to have to stop
and it was it was very upsetting because
i'd finally gotten a grip on the
structure
i'd worked my way through one manuscript
that hadn't hadn't succeeded and i
finally had a manuscript in which i had
the structure that you see in this book
i was really getting it down on paper in
a way that was working
and i'd done most of my research
obviously
and i encountered a friend of mine
in a supermarket
right after my wife had published an
article in new york or on the auto
accident that has sent me back a year
and he said how's the book coming and i
said i'm going to have to quit there's a
friend named peter braystrom who worked
who's the editor of the wilson quarterly
at the woodrow wilson international
center for scholars and he said why i
said because i run out of money peter
and i've run out of fellowships and i'm
just going to have to go back to work to
support the family and he's he suggested
i apply to the wilson center for a
fellowship and i did
and they gave me one
jim billington was then the head of it
the current librarian of congress and it
tied me over for a year
and then
we ran another year with no income but
we managed to get through it susan
brought in some income i could not have
written a book without susan
both her help and her support and also
in those years when i was not bringing
in income
and then in 1981 i renegotiated the
contract with random house i had two
thirds of a manuscript they could see
that they were going to get a book and
we renegotiated the advance and they
gave me into advance and i was able to
continue but again i ran out of money
because it took much longer
and in 1985 mr shawna the new yorker
advanced me forty thousand dollars
i was getting quite close to the end at
that point but i again i had run out of
money i was constant i constantly ran
out of money because this thing took
many more years than one could have
anticipated it was a very difficult
thing to do to both write an honest
complicated history of the war and an
honest biography
twinning the two together
without letting the one get out of
balance without putting more emphasis on
the man than he deserved or and without
spending more giving more space in the
history than it
could bear if you were going to twin it
with a biography and also catching
subtlety and writing it in a form which
would have this narrative drive
which i wanted because i felt i felt
very profoundly that vietnam is a pain
is such a painful experience that unless
you presented it to the reader in a way
that a reader could could
pick up a book and read a personal story
in a narrative form that would drive
forward
americans will not come to grips with it
in the abstract and we need to come to
grips with this war
we've got to somehow redeem the lives
that are remembered with the names on
that memorial
if we're going to draw any lessons from
this war and that was the thing that
kept me going those years at any point
did you worry that you might have become
obsessed with this project
well one
i was less obsessed than than i was
trapped in it
i was very worried of course
at the years going by they were very
grim years
i don't think i was obsessed in the
sense that i wanted to go on writing it
forever i wanted it to end
people said to me you're going to have
postpartum depression when it's over
nonsense i was saying i want this thing
to end
i felt less trapped than obsessed i knew
after by by 79 that i had a book that
would work the question was how soon i
could get it done and it was it kept the
deadlines kept going by and i kept
missing them i would set deadlines for
myself
and but but
i felt a great sense of being trapped i
wanted to desperately wanted to finish
this book because i knew it would work
once it was done it was a question of
getting it done did you ever find
yourself blocked when you were writing
not blocked but i found i would spend
days
battering away at a problem because
you're looking at a book which is long
360 000 words but it covers an enormous
span of years and events and it's very
telescope actually in its in its writing
and i would spend days excuse me i'd
spend a day
and not
and not finish what i started out to do
that day i i would not write those pages
i had wanted to write that day because i
hadn't solved the problem let's say of
telescoping a historical section or
telescoping a section on van's life
and uh i wouldn't be able to sleep that
night
uh i might not solve the organizational
problem of putting those pages together
until the end of the day let's say
and then i would i'd go out and take a
walk and come back and write down an
outline and then i'd be able to sleep
but some nights i couldn't sleep unless
i got i actually got work done of a
given day
i i had trouble sleeping that night and
so i desperately tried to solve a
problem
to get something
first of all i stayed organized
i tried i'm a night work i was a night
worker in those years because i have a
night metabolism but there were regular
hours and they were regular days i put
on a coat and tie when i went to the
library of congress
because i had gone to an office
previously and i
because it helped keep one organized i
kept very regular habits i led a
monastic life
because and i tried to get something
done every day
because then i could sleep at night and
i had a sense i was accomplishing
something everybody that knows you talks
about the automobile accident as a real
tough time for you uh what happened
uh an adult brained hillbilly kid who
liked to drive down the wrong side of
the road
hit me head-on in western maryland
and he literally liked to drive down the
wrong side of the road as he told my
wife when she interviewed him afterwards
when
uh back in 74
and it clobbered me for uh for for at
least a year uh because he broke seven
of my bones and
you
you don't even after your bones
initially heal you do not get back the
physical stamina to work at first i
could only work an hour a day and then
i'd get exhausted it took me a year
before i got back the stamina and
probably a year and a half before i got
back full stamina and i got some
souvenirs out of it a knee that was
operated on last fall it's it's healing
now
but uh
it was it was a traumatic event in terms
of of of of interrupting uh a work that
was in mid-course
um ironically perhaps by setting me back
maybe it may be possible to finish this
book it was a high price
perhaps it forced me perhaps the the the
interruption and lost time gave me more
perspective on vietnam than i would
otherwise have acquired
but it was a high price to pay do you
have a message that you want to deliver
in the course of selling your book a
political message at this point no i'm
not a political person
uh i i'm a reporter i deliberately i had
views on the war but i always try to
keep those views out of my copy unless i
was writing an essay
somebody said write an essay with your
personal opinions in it i wrote them
but in my news coverage i try to keep
them out now there are some personal
viewpoints in this in this book
obviously and i made judgments the book
is has got judgments in it but
essentially i tried to tell the story of
what happened in vietnam and why it
happened the message i have if there's a
message the desire let's say the desire
i have is that this book will help
people to come to grips with this war
that we will vietnam will have been a
war in vain
only if we don't draw wisdom from it
because it was our first war in vain in
the sense that it was that the people
died in it for nothing
in terms of the war itself we lost the
war
we went to war for the wrong reasons etc
we were constantly deluded in what we
did but i think if we draw wisdom from
it if we draw lessons from it
then
the war will have turned out to have
been a good experience for this country
a better experience but a good one and
so i tried i i discovered that the war
is much more complicated than i had
imagined when i s when i began to write
this book and research it and so i don't
have any political message for americans
no the desire is that people will come
to grips that the
book will help them to understand the
war and if they understand the war lots
of people will draw a different
political in the narrow sense of the
word different political lessons out of
it depending upon their political point
of view
and that's fine let them i tried to
record the war
is there a movie out of this book i
don't know there's been considerable
film interest in it uh whether there
will be a film made i don't know there's
been a lot of we've had a lot of
inquiries
uh and i hope there's a film made of it
eventually because again i think that
would help
people to come to grips with the war and
john fans a highly filmable guy and that
war is a highly filmable war and the
events and vans in van's life and the
events in the war are highly filmable i
mean this is some
as you know the extraordinary scenes in
there
let's take for instance the ambush when
he
he drives down the road in 10 viet cong
are waiting for him and he's in a pickup
truck and they shoot the whole truck up
and he drives his way through the ambush
by veering off the road first
accidentally and then deliberately
driving right down through these guys
and scattering them the battle of opbach
when the uh uh when this lone gorilla
battalion
defeats this south vietnamese army
armed with with air aircraft and
armor and and artillery et cetera the
vans rescuing the advisors the plucking
these guys right out of a compound with
north vietnamese tanks bursting in
it's all extraordinary filmable and i
hope there is a film but i would want to
film for the same reasons i wrote the
book
to make people in hopes that it would
help people understand what happened in
vietnam do i understand that when
the battle of opbach that you
constructed that battle in a narrative
by using both van's
words in his diary and his reports and
the north vietnamese captured documents
yes that was an extraordinary
situation where
we
the saigon side in an unusual ambush two
months after the battle captured the
vietcong after action report which was
very detailed this is what 62 63
and the battle occurred in january 63
and they captured the vietcong after
action report which was very detailed
because this was a major battle the
first
it was one of the few decisive battles
of the war
and it was the first decisive battle of
the early phase of the war it turned the
war for the vietcong it turned the war
for the communists it turned it in their
favor
they won it and it turned it in their
favor
and they were of course extremely
interested in this and wrote a long and
very detailed after action report about
what had occurred and why it had
occurred giving the the
not only the narrative of the battle
itself but the events that had led up to
it and what their situation what their
situation had been what prior to the
battle how weak they had been
uh how van the operations van had had
instigated had in fact weakened them and
that van had had because the battle had
been so important to him had compiled a
much more voluminous after-action report
much more much much much lengthier than
would normally be done he'd had each
adviser write a a
a personal account which he'd attached
to an after-action report which is a
very detailed thing so i took these two
documents plus my own memories i'd
covered the battle i'd reported it and
my own dispatches and i went back and i
interviewed
the people who'd participated
and some of them one of them in
particular an operations officer had
diaries he kept with code code names
vietnamese or no an american although i
interviewed the vietnamese intelligence
officer who'd been there two years i
interviewed a number of vietnamese on
the saigon site who'd been in but not
the north vietnamese
not no they're they were actually south
vietnamese uh communist guerrillas they
were viet cong they were southerners i
suspect almost all of those men are dead
because the viet cong was wiped out at
10. i would suspect that i i would like
to go back to vietnam someday when was
the last time you were there
73
and i would like to go back to vietnam
after the the book has been published
and
and i've finished my
tours etc and i'm and after this knee
that's been operated on heels better i'd
like to go back to vietnam and see
what's happening i'd like to look up
some of these people but i suspect most
of them are dead
but i i interviewed vietnamese on the
saigon side and i went to the americans
who've been involved in the in the
battle and i interviewed them and i then
put the action together and the two
basic documents
plus then the interviews enabled me to
put together an account that takes you
from the beginning right through this
very exciting battle this extraordinary
battle because the van's after action
report confirmed a lot of what the two
reports confirmed each other
uh as well as adding to each other and
then the interviews uh added more that's
why you have this extraordinary dialogue
for instance between vanna and an
observation plane and these advisors
with an armored personnel carrier
company
the two advisors remembered very vividly
what van had said to them uh and there
was corroboration of what he said to
them in
the operations officers no senate in the
after action report but of course they
remember they were young men they were
my age a little bit older and when
things happen to you that are very
exciting at a young age they're really
engraved on your memory and they had
remembered with great clarity uh
their their exchanges with van and that
in in that spotter plane and so i was
able to put put that battle together uh
um
if with a in a narrative into a
narrative which is the way i think you
have to tell battles if they're if
they're to be understood did daniel
ellsberg bring the pentagon papers to
you uh that's a really complicated story
and i don't want to get into it but but
daniel ellsberg copied the pentagon
papers and and
he uh he was prosecuted for it uh and
but that is another story that that i
don't want to really get into because
it's it's a complicated tale did you
ever tell the story no i've never told
the story the full story and and um
i that that that would have been a
reporter's memoir and i set out to write
a book about the war in vietnam i had
first thought of writing a reporter's
memoir but then i decided that
this was before i went to van's funeral
i decided a reporter's value was in what
he witnesses
and i had been a witness to this war
which was another reason i wanted to
write this book i thought i could bring
to the war and understanding that a
person who had not been a witness to the
world would not be able to bring to it
and i also knew people who who had been
involved i could talk to them and we
we'd shared experiences
like these young advisors at opbach so i
didn't i i've never uh gotten into that
but you did though lead the new york
times team yeah i i got the pentagon
papers for the new york times and i was
the lead writer on the team i obtained
the papers for the times and i was the
lead writer on the team
uh uh that it started out with me and
a um
one a
deputy foreign editor here in the
jefferson hotel going through them and
and um
deciding what to do and we uh then moved
the operation to new york and we ended
up with 50 people in the new york hilton
by the end what year was that 1971
1971. what impact did that have on you
after you got all the publicity and the
lead on the story like that that was so
important well i
first of all richard nixon said a grand
jury
the fbi was
questioning my neighbors and a fellow
named robert martian who was convicted
in the watergate business had a grand
jury going up in boston
and uh
under the direction of nixon etc and
that took up a lot of my time
but after that i was going to go back to
reporting uh but the the
pentagon papers gave me
further insights in the war that i never
would have had without them
they gave me uh insights that that added
to my experience
uh
got to remember now this is a war i'd
been started covering since in 1962.
i'd
been on the ground in vietnam three
years
but those those papers were the greatest
historical arc they were the records of
the war and they have remained the the
best official
record
that is what i would say the best
archive
on the war that we've ever that we've
ever obtained and they they gave me a
depth of understanding i never had
before and then when van was killed uh i
realized that that that perhaps had
prepared me for the task of writing the
book
but you and and daniel ellsberg and john
paul van were all in vietnam at the same
time yes we all knew each other
what
at the end john was at his funeral john
dan ellsberg and john vann went in
totally different directions by the end
of the war but they remain best friends
there was another
capacity van had
another part of the complicated
character that he could keep a
friendship with somebody on whom by the
end he was totally until although
with whom he totally differed uh uh on
the war
john was totally committed to
winning it at that point dan ellsberg
was totally committed to try to trying
to stop it uh because ellsberg was a was
a force in the anti-war movie it was
totally launched in at work crusade
there were a lot of people involved in
it but ellsberg was was totally
committed to it
but they remained friends but in those
earlier years yes everyone everyone went
to we had vietnam to win the war
are you glad this project's over
it's wonderful to finally have this book
done and to see it in print
and to then hope that the
my hopes will be fulfilled
and that they will help people to to to
understand why we went to vietnam and
what we did there
because i don't think up to now we have
really
taken a look at what what we did there
and why we did it it's very important to
understand why is there anything you
left out of the book
not really not that i left there are
lots of things you leave out of a book
like this in the sense that this book is
a distillation of a much greater a
body of research
i had five file cabinets plus all of
these interviews but i didn't leave
anything out important no this is very
selectively written this book it's long
but it's very selectively written what's
i i i got in when i wanted to get in
i said what i wanted to say do you feel
now that you personally have come to
grips with the war yourself i've come to
grips with
yes i think i've come to understand the
war myself and and i have worked it out
i
i'm satisfied with that
and if my 15 years when i put into
writing it another year putting at the
press
my 15 years won't have been wasted if if
if the book
is read with with the attention i hope
it's read because a book lasts a book
acquires a life of its own that's one of
the greatest satisfactions to see a book
and to see something that has a life of
its own now
it i feel a kind of separateness from it
in a way
it's it's it's got its own life now to
open it up and look at the maps and and
uh look at the words they're there and
books hang around on shelves um and i
hope uh i hope my grandkids will read
this book and it'll help them to
understand vietnam what do you want to
do next
i don't really know i want to
help promote the book because i
that's a necessity and then the only
specific thing i have in mind that i
would like to do is to go back to
vietnam
to see what's happened to the country
and to write about it
then what i will do i don't know i'm not
worried about it i might go back to
daily journalism i don't don't really
know i've stayed busy all my life and
the one thing that i've been taught is
is that if you want to work you'll find
plenty to do
and so i'm sure that i'll find something
to do and i if you learn as a newspaper
man that you go from story to story in
this case i went to a book to trap me
for for 15 years but it's finally done
now and i'll move on i'll do something
else any impact on your family
well the book was uh was a was a very
difficult time for the family all those
years
uh although actually we it made us
closer as a family i was around to help
raise my children whereas i might have
been on the road two kids two kids two
daughters i think i think the girls
are happy with what's happened the book
daddy's book is finally done
how old are the daughters my youngest is
19 and uh throughout most of her
wife
it was daddy's book and the uh a family
word was when daddy's book is done well
daddy's book is finally done and i think
they're happy
neil shannon author of a bright shining
lie john paul van an american vietnam
published by random house
[Music]
that concludes our series of interviews
with author neil sheehan but stay with
us here on c-span for a round-table
discussion with three retired military
officers who served in vietnam that's
coming up after a short break
so
[Music]
a behind the screen look at the inner
workings of the national public policy
process
that's just one feature of the weekly
c-span update the view
[Music]
you're watching c-span
coming up next we'll air the fourth in
our series of interviews with author
neil sheehan the author of a bright
shining lie john paul van and america in
vietnam
he covered the vietnam war for the new
york times and his new book is a
biography of one of the senior american
advisors in vietnam john paul vann and a
history of american and
our fourth interview with mr sheehan
looks at john paul van
[Music]
neil sheehan author of a bright shining
lie john paul van and america in vietnam
when you think of john paul van what do
you remember first
i guess i remember this
extraordinary lieutenant colonel
down in the mekong delta in 6263 when i
first met in this
banty rooster of a man with this
rasping virginia twang who was fearless
extremely bright explained the war to
you in a way nobody else could
who was always on the field
driving roads nobody else would drive
getting involved in in in in firefights
this extremely colorful man who to whom
i was very much attracted as a young
reporter that's the van i i most
remember
the guy who summed up the kind of
qualities we admired so much in
ourselves that
physical drive
the will to win
incisive thinking
that's the van i i remember
you knew him as early as 62 yes i met
john in 62 when i was a young reporter
and first went to vietnam
and thought i knew him
i considered him a friend because i did
see a lot of him in that first year and
then i saw him later on when i came back
here and briefly when he was in this
country then i saw him when i went back
to vietnam again in 65 66 and he was
back in vietnam and i thought i knew
john well
but after i began to research the book
after he died
after he was killed in vietnam at the
end of 10 years in
june of 72 and i decided to write a book
about him and about the war i discovered
that he was an exceedingly complicated
person and that we all thought we knew
john van and none of us knew him did he
did he ever lie to you
yes john don deceived me yes uh he
deceived all of us in that first year in
that
we thought he was
throwing away a career
to take on the commanding general and
warn about the fact that we were losing
the war in vietnam
it turned out that he was taking on he
did take on the commanding general and
he did have moral courage but it turned
out that
he had
uh a black spot
on his record
which he knew would bar him from
promotion to general and he really
didn't have a career to throw away at
that point what was that black spot
he'd been charged with statutory rape
because of an affair with a 15 year old
girl
when he was at the commanding general
staff college
and he had beaten the charge in the
sense that the case had never come to
trial
but
in fact he beat a lie detector
but
it turned out that but but the
investigation the record was still in
his file
and it would bar him from
being promoted the general he would have
gone as far as colonel but he would
never have gotten stars because a
general officer board
at least he was convinced of it and i
think he was correct a general officer
board is looking for reasons to reject
people
not to promote there are many more men
than there are stars to give many more
candidates than our stars to give and
they're looking for reasons to reject
you
and even though he had a brilliant
record
and was an extremely brave officer
he knew that he simply wouldn't they
wouldn't take a risk
that
a general officer would have the sexual
compulsions that he had
he was a man of as i said of great
public professional honesty as i say in
the book
enormous professional honesty and
courage and these private
personal deceits which would bear light
which came out of his childhood
an illegitimate child
john yes john was an illegitimate was
illegitimate he was born in norfolk
virginia
he was very poor family
his mother
the problem wasn't that he was
illegitimate it was that his mother was
cruel to him
she she held his illegitimacy
up to him
she wouldn't allow his stepfather to
adopt him
when he was
he was finally adopted when he was 18
and later on many years later when he
was filling out a government security
clearance form this is motherboard
this is his mother yeah this is a
picture of his mother how old was she
here she was probably in her 30s then
uh
she was she was um she was a woman who
tended to attack
the men around her
uh attacked their masculinity if you
will
uh
by by by cruelty
and she was she was very cruel to him
she hurt him deeply
and he
he had to overcome a great deal
to escape from that world of his
childhood
and it it scarred him personally what
does mother do for a living
his mother
as i said in the book was a
she was she was a a a part-time uh
she sold herself uh to put it mildly
part of the time not always probably
yeah she holds herself and that hurt him
but the shame of it hurt him
but i think what hurt him even more was
the fact that she withheld love from him
he grew up as a in effect as a
motherless child
and it's very sad when that happens to a
person
i think what one's mother does might
cause one shame but if one is if if love
is withheld if one is rejected that
hurts even more who raised him
he was raised by his stepfather
and then a
frank van
who adopted him and who would have
adopted him early on
and then he escaped from norfolk
when he was in his late teens he was
desperate to get away from his family
situation and he encountered a minister
named garland hopkins a local
uh
minister uh at a uh
at a local methodist church
who was a progressive man and who sent
him off to a
methodist boarding school
in the foothills of
the of the blue ridge mountains in in
southwestern virginia a place called
firm at that time freedom training
school and junior college it's now from
college uh and he broke out of that
world through that and then he went into
the army during army air court in world
war ii and and broke out of that world
and and became
here's that's a picture of john
just as he's going off the theorem
he that
sport jacket and pants
had been bought for him by a rich
oysterman in norfolk who was in effect
the patron of this methodist church and
who would
and who wrote who paid for his
scholarship at firm as well and what and
and who would who backed the minister
there who
in effect picked up the deficit
of the church for the minister
and had sent him off and that was his
first escape he escaped to fear him uh
that's the first time where he got three
square meals a day they were so
desperately impoverished he grew up of
course in the great depression in
norfolk in a poor white working-class
district
and they were so desperately
impoverished the vans that
most of most the average the standard
meal at the van house cooked by his
stepfather would be fried potatoes and
biscuits
and his youngest brother
got rickets as a result of the vitamin
deficiency and his legs had to be broken
to straighten them ricketts bows the
legs
uh and
in fact you have a picture i think
that's right of his his youngest brother
who was a who's a wonderful man
uh was his real brother yes
his uh um
um well
half brother
technically half brother uh emotionally
his real brother they were they were
quite close
um he was his youngest brother uh and um
they were quite close and he
that youngest brother also broke out and
has had a very successful career and is
a wonderful man how much total education
did john paul van have he had a very
fine education actually
he
broke out of norfolk and got the furious
and got two years of junior college
then went into the army air corps came
out
uh went to college uh at rutgers spent a
year there then switched to the infantry
finally got the bs from rutgers in the
mid 50s in business administration the
army then sent it to syracuse on a
master's program and he ended up with he
was a extremely bright man
and he ended up with uh all but two
two courses short of a thesis
uh for his phd in for a phd in public
administration as well as a master's in
business plus he went through
all the service schools short of the war
college he went through commander
general staff
and the army has a schooling system of
its own and he went up through the army
schooling system so john was a highly
educated person
at least in
highly educated in in the sense of
in a technical way he was best
he had that peculiar ability
to understand human problems
and also to deal with them in a very
hard factual way he was a statistician
by training among other things as a
result of this this training in business
administration
and it gave him a capacity to
take a human situation and put it into
quantitative terms
very very effectively he could lay
things out for you the facts et cetera
even statistically
for instance
the the he would he would show you why
this how the south vietnam
vietnamese army wasn't fighting
he'd lay out the number of actions they
were involved in
the number they claimed the number of
contacts they claimed to have with the
viet cong and then he'd point out that
they weren't actually engaging the viet
cong in any of these here were the
number of casualties
john would do that sort of analysis it
was very clear that they were they were
simply faking things they would claim
they were going on patrols they would
report 500 patrols a month and they'd
have 13 contacts with the enemy or two
casualties and as john said at one point
he could he could he could have
generated more contacts on his own uh
but he had that ability to to take a
look at the situation and and and
draw these this this hard this hard data
from it uh
and
it was it was a particular turn of mine
he had but it also came out of his
education came a great source for you in
vietnam yes he was he was he really
educated a whole generation of reporters
there
because john's ideas john had the
capacity to analyze the war
uh and show us what was wrong with the
way first we were waging war in the
kennedy years
that it was stupid
to be shelling and bombing civilian
hamlets that we were just killing women
and kids and we were turning the
population against us
he showed us the extent to which the
arvind the regular south vietnamese army
was avoiding contact with the enemy and
would not fight
uh the vietcong would not take them on
he showed us the extent to which we were
arming the guerrillas through these
outposts
again john would gather the data
precisely how many how much how many how
many american arms were going through
precisely how many outposts and and and
and we ended up as i said in the book we
ended up arming the viet cong in south
vietnam with american weapons because
the american generals were
pouring weapons into the south
vietnamese militia and the vietcong were
collecting them from these outposts and
so you were giving a communist gorilla
who had a bolt-action french rifle a
fast-firing semi-automatic m1 garand
which was a world war ii weapon but
which was a very good weapon in the mid
in the early 60s this is prior to the
fully automatic weapons the m16 etc the
m1 grant was a fine weapon and we were
we were arming there are arming our
enemy and john pointed those things out
to us he he gave us
tools with which to analyze the war that
we wouldn't have had without him flew
his own airplane
uh
he later on ended up yes john john uh uh
ended up as a qua he he never was an
officially qualified helicopter pilot
but uh he got his pilot to teach him how
to fly he'd wanted to fly during world
war two and and did get as far as flight
training and then got bounced for doing
loop the loop
moved all over vietnam in a plane
helicopter yeah at helicopters or light
planes
he did constantly on the move he was a
man who had to be on the move there's
massive amounts of material in your book
uh about uh the battles and how he
played a role but there's
there's one
two or three line sentence i want to
read you that just pops right out of the
page and i happen to read it first in
the new yorker and i want to ask you
before i ask you about this line
why did the new yorker devote so many
pages over four issues to your book
well i i think bob gottlieb thought he
liked it very much and he thought that
if he excerpted if he concentrated on
excerpting uh the
biography of van himself
and the high points of it that he would
have a very intense story that he could
lay out for the reader with a lot of
narrative drive
an intense series a very good intense
series that would tell the story of the
war through this through through this
man's experience but which would focus
very narrowly on john vann and those
were the sections of the book he took
unusual for the new yorker to give all
that much space to one issue i think
look it it it has been for bob gottlieb
it wasn't for his predecessor sean
william shawn
often ran long series
um
that is four
would run four and five uh uh uh
excuse me would run a series of four or
five articles on the same subject but
bob gottlieb had initially intended to
to reduce that and basically he has he's
run shorter things but in the case of
the book he he had initially planned on
running three and then he discovered he
that it wouldn't fit that he simply he
had to go to four so he ended up running
a four-part series of 88 000 words in
all which is quite long for the current
new yorker yes okay by the way how many
words in the book
about 360 000
here's the here's the sentence and and
there's a lot behind this and i want you
to tell us about it van like to convey
confide details of his sexual exploits
to ellsberg
the two stories here sexual exploits and
daniel ellsberg and the only reason i
want to ask you about the sexual
exploits is that you mentioned earlier
when you talk about this he led several
different lives paul john paul mayhem
yes tell us about it well john the
private side of him was this uh was this
man with this these powerful sexual
compulsions he was an incredible
womanizer
did you know that when you're in vietnam
no
he hid it from us his first year
and he also kept it under control his
first year
he'd go off with
friends to
saigon or down to a beach resort and he
kept it under control he would john was
a man who could play roles and he was
very conscious that if you fooled around
with women
in the place where you worked then the
vietnamese lost respect for you
and so he didn't do it he turned out to
be an incredible womanizer first of all
some of this he inherited
some of it was in his genes
his father was a womanizer it turned out
his real father
um
his bio if you will by a lot his natural
father
and but but then the insecurities
implanted in by his mother
i think fed this compulsion in him so
that
he was he was a driven man sexually
and
he
ellsberg and ellsberg and he of course
went on totally different directions on
the war
but what was daniel ellsworth doing in
vietnam in the beginning dan ellsberg
went out there to help win the war like
everyone else he believed in it
uh and then ellsberg ended up turning
against the war but ellsberg was a very
adventurous guy and and he and van very
quickly became
best friends
ellsberg would go out in the field with
fan on these on these trips
and uh john tended if he thought someone
would listen he liked to boast about the
sexual exploits of his and so he he
told ellsberg things right away that he
often didn't tell other people i
discovered after the new yorker series
was published that some of his friends
although they knew he was an incredible
womanizer didn't didn't didn't know
about
particular uh things that for instance
that statutory rape incident that
ruined his army career how did you find
out all this
first of all from his former wife mary
jane
she was how did you know well she was
married to him when the statutory rape
incident occurred and she helped get him
off the hook by
by committing perjury for him uh
uh in the investigation in the military
investigation to it of course she felt
threatened as well it threatened her
family what would she do if her husband
was court-martialed and had to resign
from the army this is back in the 50s
the end of the 50s
at that time soldiers with dishonorable
discharges were having a rough time
finding good jobs this in the
pre-vietnam period what would an officer
who'd been dismissed from the army this
was a felony it was a very serious
charge
and so she knew about it obviously she
had to and she was as i said
she was a married changed woman of great
courage and honesty and when she decided
to talk to me she told me everything she
knew
and that's when i first discovered how
complicated he was
that he had this private side to him
uh this of this man driven by these
compulsions uh and he had then then this
contradictory public side of rigid
professional honesty of a firm grasp on
reality at least in the beginning
he lost it after tet when he couldn't
give up on the war and he began to
rationalize things in order to stay but
prior to that he had this very firm
grasp on reality and he fascinated me
for that reason i mean my fascination
with him deepened
when i learned these things because he
had all these contradictions
died in 1972
in a airplane crash in vietnam yes a
helicopter crash he was killed at the
time he was killed divorced from his
wife mary jane who lived in denver right
five kids
he lived yeah she lived right next to
denver and littleton right yes she had
divorced him and he was about to marry a
vietnamese woman by whom he had had a
daughter
and there was another woman in besides
this yes yes describe that whole thing i
mean well he he he carried on in vietnam
two
uh
fairly permanent liaisons with two
vietnamese women
both of whom remained ignorant of each
other
until
about until one until he died and the
other one until about a year before he
died
uh
the
by one of these women he had a daughter
and
he was going to they were going to be
married he planned to marry her shortly
before he was killed he'd taken out
papers to do so
but he had also been maintaining this
permanent relationship with another
vietnamese woman
i think john was sufficiently
complicated so he probably enjoyed that
captain's paradise if you
remember that old movie
it was an incredible thing he had he had
his staff trained for instance
to keep both women ignorant of each
other his helicopter pilot knew uh the
secretary knew you weren't supposed to
ever let the one know about the other uh
and he pulled it off for years um now
this is a man who was of utmost
seriousness in his professional work
and
that part of him that the complications
in him made him more interesting to me
and it made him more representative to
me
because
we tend to think of ourselves
as a very simple country with very
simple motivations
and in fact we're a very complicated
people with all sorts of insecurities
uh
and all sorts of fears
and drives which which which which
motivate us and and the fact that this
man was such a complicated figure and
the fact that his personal and private
life
was directly related to his public
actions
because you can't understand john unlike
john van unless you understand his
private compulsions would you tell the
story about the
mistress who i believe her name was
julia julia uh it's danny and annie in
the book uh um go ahead
the the one where the annie is a
pseudonym uh
uh and he he uh he called her by a
nickname and i changed i changed the
nickname to another nickname uh and it's
annie okay the but the point here was
the reason i wanted to tell the story
was the involvement that he had with the
the woman's father first of all john van
what something around 41 and she was
like 17 or 18. yeah she was i think 17
when they met uh uh you
checked my memory with the book but i
think she's about 17. don't see him
ignorant about my own book but i think
she was yes she was very young 17.
she had his daughter when i believe she
was 18. her father tried to uh she was a
a fine she's a fine woman she was a fine
woman she was a she was a young a
romantically inclined young woman who
encountered this american who who uh
who uh
was far more obviously far more
experienced she had had no experience
and her father tried to
to stop him and he tried to
make her realize what she was getting
involved in a man who was a womanizer
etc
but her father was totally unsuccessful
her father waited till they came back
one night and he slapped van across the
face
and uh
told him to leave his daughter alone and
it was fascinating that john didn't
attempt to defend himself how did you
find all that out she told me
this woman she told me about the
incident but there was another time when
the father when she was pregnant
yes she got pregnant then and she
refused to have
have an abortion
and a
van tried to get out of it by ignoring
the whole thing at that point
and her father
her father initially wanted her to try
to to have an abortion because he didn't
want to bring he did not want her to see
her get involved permanently with an
older american man and give up the
possibility of marrying a vietnamese
and having a normal family life but she
was determined to keep the baby and so
he confronted van in his office and he
told him that if he didn't arrange to
provide for
his daughter and for the child to come
in the manner in which she was to be she
was accustomed to living that he was
going to go and complain to the american
ambassador
and so then agreed uh to take on this
responsibility and support this young
woman and the child to come and he did
he had no cho well he felt he had no
choice he brought it on himself of
course
did he ever marry her he was going to
and he called her his wife and his last
will in a will he wrote in the in the
helicopter which is in the book
he wrote he wrote a second will
uh one day when he thought he was going
to die
uh
toward the end when he was rescuing some
advisors and on his way to to rescue
them they were in a compound the north
vietnamese tanks were bursting into and
that was the one day when he thought the
odds were not gonna what might apply to
him and he really thought that morning
he probably was gonna he was gonna get
it
and but at the same time it was part of
his code to go and rescue his people and
he was gonna go get them and so he wrote
a holographic will on a piece of note
paper and he called her his wife in that
will he intended to marry her but he was
killed before he could do i remember
correctly even after he told her he was
going to marry her and she had had this
child that he still maintain a liaison
with this other oh yes and i don't think
he was going to give up the other one
either even after he got married guess
the reason why i want to even ask you
about all this is how can you
you call him brilliant
how can a man be brilliant and have all
these liaisons going on and still keep
his mind on
the work at hand i think if you look
into
powerful figures in history
you often find that they have very
complicated personalities and very
complicated personal lives now one
reason i laid out john van's personal
life was not because i was trying to
titillate the reader
i tried to write about it as in as
restrained a fashion as i could
but there are there's no there are no
explicit sexual scenes in this book as
you know in fact i managed to write a
book about war without using the
four-letter word
but uh i wrote about it because it this
was a man whose personal life and this
is probably true of a lot of historical
figures but we've lost their personal
lives the the the the the data the
detail isn't there but this is a man
whose personal life was very tied to his
public actions and
he's and this is a man who affected the
way the war in vietnam turned out the
course of the war would have been
different had it not been for john vann
and john van would not have left the
army
and gone back to vietnam as a civilian
and then done the things he did in
vietnam had it not been for his personal
life in fact is he is he a general right
here in this picture that's right john
was the first civilian first genuine
civilian general in our history in fact
he's the only one i know john's the only
person i know the only figure i know
uh
excuse me let me back up john is the
first case i know of in our history
where a civilian official
and he was at the time an official in
aid
the agency for international development
actually held command and war
uh now he was by profession a soldier he
spent 20 years in the army and retired
but he was technically a civilian
on detail to the army
which is a
military excuse me bureaucratic term for
transferring a person
and he held command uh he held the corps
command under general creighton abrams
great creating abram to put him in that
position
on the advice of a friend of vance who
was abram's deputy
fred wyan and he wielded command
he's the first one i know of to do that
now the
the personal man was very much tied to
the private man you can't understand the
public man without the private man
the things he would do the fearlessness
for instance was tied to his his his the
personal man
again he i think he was proving himself
over and over again he's extraordinary
the things the the sense of the the the
the desire to be
uh a a a really fine officer
came out of the the desire to get away
from his childhood
all of these things were tied together
you couldn't if you wanted to understand
the man and then you wanted to
understand his impact on the war
and as i as you you have in the book
that extraordinary battle of con tomb in
the end where john van held things
together where the the situation would
have collapsed the panic that broke out
in 75 would have broken out in 72 had it
not been for van he was the he was the
guy who said who who held it together
and it was his personal drives as much
as anything that that led him to do that
the book is a bright shining lie the
author is neil sheehan
published by random house john paul van
and america in vietnam
hmm
[Music]
this afternoon here on c-span we're
looking back at american involvement in
the vietnam war
we've been talking with neil sheehan the
author of a bright shining lie
john paul van and america in vietnam
after this next and last interview with
mr sheehan we'll air a recorded
roundtable discussion with three retired
military officers who served in vietnam
then we'll open up our phone lines to
get your reaction to these discussions
the next and last interview with mr
sheehan is a profile of the author
[Music]
this afternoon here on c-span we're
looking back at american involvement in
the vietnam war
we've been talking with neil sheehan the
author of a bright shining lie john paul
van and america in vietnam
after this next and last interview with
mr sheehan we'll air a recorded
roundtable discussion with three retired
military officers who served in vietnam
then we'll open up our phone lines to
get your reaction to these discussions
the next and last interview with mr
sheehan is a profile of the author
[Music]
you know sheen author of a bright
shining lie john paul van in american
vietnam
when did you first know that you want to
be a writer
when i was in the army oddly enough um
i didn't know what i wanted to do in
college i was in the i joined the
literary magazine which was the harvard
advocate and i was an editor there and i
wrote book reviews but and i thought i
wanted to go into publishing but then i
switched to history and graduated from
harvard and really in 58 really didn't
know what i wanted to do went in the
army and became an army journalist to
get out of a miserable job as a pay
clerk
in korea
and went down to the division
information office
40 miles closer to seoul and fell into
journalism liked it
got transferred to tokyo to put out the
division newspaper there and started
working moonlighting for the united
press international and then they
offered me a job and i discovered i
decided this is what i wanted to do were
you born
i was born in a small industrial city in
western massachusetts called holyoke i
was actually i was born there but grew
up outside of it just outside of it my
grandfather
had a farm on the edge of it which he
left to my father and farm in the dairy
business which he left my father and my
father's two brothers and my father
my father handled the farming end of it
the cows the field the planting the corn
and that my father loved those things he
was a genuine he kept horses long after
he had a tractor simply because he loved
horses and so i grew up on a farm if you
will and uh and uh worked in the farm
when i was a young young man and and and
and uh
had those
those advantages i think of a kid who
grows up out in the country it's it's
wonderful to grow up out in the country
the book uh big book 867 pages
24.95
random house
a bright shining lie
when did you know you had to write this
book
i
decided to write the book in 72
when i went after i went to john van's
funeral
i had spent my whole career
basically most of my career was reported
covering vietnam i'd first gone there in
62
and i had never been able to get away
from the war
of course of course it was the dominant
event of my generation
and uh as a reporter if you had gone
there early on you probably couldn't get
away from it but i had never succeeded
in getting away and
my last big thing had been obtaining the
pentagon papers for the times in 71 and
i wanted to leave behind something that
would be more permanent than another
magazine article and another newspaper
another newspaper story and when john
died i realized that if i wrote a book
about this extraordinary man
i could tell the story of the war
through him because he was such a
compelling figure and he summed up in
the 10 years he'd been in vietnam the
american venture there and he summed up
the way we like to think of ourselves
the qualities that we admired in
ourselves in that period this enormous
drive this this brilliant analytical
mind of this incredible energy sleeping
four hours and only needing four hours
of sleep at night
the fearlessness etc he had an
extraordinary metabolism uh
all of these things that we we really
admired in ourselves as a people and and
he had he had devoted himself to vietnam
and he had died there and i felt that if
i if i wrote a story a biography of him
i could also write a history of the war
that's why
i started out and then of course i was
trapped in the enterprise
it was too late to go
back you left the new york times when i
left the new york times
in 1972 to go off to vietnam and do my
first research trip
uh i thought i could write the book in
three or four years and i'd go back to
work for the times i took a leave of
absence it turned out that i i
grossly underestimated the task that
writing a biography of this complicated
man and writing history of this
complicated war was far more than than a
farm it was going to take me far longer
than than three or four years
and i also had interruptions i lost you
with an auto accident i had to earn a
living by lecturing
and but basically the task was to
research and write a book
about the war
which helped the country i hope come to
grips of the war that would be a book
that was exciting
that would have narrative force and
drive
that would um that was
cast in the form in which truman capote
wrote cold blood
but of course he was writing about one
incident and i was writing about an
awful lot more than that how did you
physically write it in other words when
did you start putting words on paper and
where did you write i started writing
about 1976
and i wrote in a number of places
first i had a study in the basement
in a basement in the house in my
neighborhood that i read it from an
elderly lady who was
renting out space
then i um
had a little office uh in maryland at
one point
that i was sharing with a friend who was
psycho phys
she's a therapist in psychology
um she and a group of psychiat
psychiatric therapists had an office
neighbor they had extra space and they
gave me one
then i ultimately
went to the library of congress in 1980
and worked there
in a little space
they the library has
always has
it's part of it their policy
given a place to to work and write to
professional writers and scholars
and they gave me a space to put my file
cabinets i had five file candidates at
that point filled with john vance papers
they gave me a desk and i needed to work
at the library also because i needed
access to its collections for research
purposes flight roof congress is an
extraordinary place
with an extraordinary collection and
and you have extraordinary access i mean
within an hour and a half you have a
book if it's in stock
excuse me if it's on the shelf and if
it's not they'll look for it for you
and so it was i worked most of the time
there i'd go down i'm a night person
and i believe in working in a
disciplined way every day because that's
the only way you get anything done
and my wife also worked at the library
she also wrote did research that libra
my wife susan sheehan who's the staff
writer for the new yorker so we'd get
down at two we'd get out about two in
the afternoon work until late 30 at the
library come home have dinner and then
i'd work in my study until about four in
the morning at home and then back to the
library the next day
um
it was uh it was a grim business but
it's the way i got through it you
mentioned lecturing excuse the personal
question but how did you financially
survive over these 15 years it was
awfully grim
i repeatedly ran out of money i got an
initially a 45 000 advance from random
house
that was burned up
i got fellowships
and they
gradually they ran out
and in 1979 i had run out of money
i was going to have to stop
and it was
it was very upsetting because i had
finally gotten a grip on the structure
i'd worked my way through one manuscript
that hadn't hadn't succeeded and i
finally had a manuscript in which i had
the structure that you see in this book
i was really getting it down on paper in
a way that was working
and i'd done most of my research
obviously
and i encountered a friend of mine in a
supermarket
right after my wife had published an
article in the new yorker on the auto
accident that had sent me back a year
and he said how's the book coming and i
said i'm going to have to quit there's a
friend named peter braystrom who worked
who's the editor of the wilson quarterly
at the woodrow wilson international
center for scholars and he said why i
said because i run out of money peter
and i've run out of fellowships and i'm
just going to have to go back to work to
support the family and he suggested i
apply to the wilson center for a
fellowship and i did
and they gave me one
jim billington was then the head of it
the current librarian of congress and it
tied me over for a year
and then
we ran another year with no income but
we managed to get through it susan
brought in some income i could not have
written a book without susan uh both her
help and her support and also in those
years when i was not bringing in income
and then in 1981 i renegotiated the
contract with random house i had two
thirds of a manuscript they could see
that they were going to get a book and
we renegotiated the advance and they
gave me a new advance and i was able to
continue but again i ran out of money
because it took much longer
and in 1985 mr shawn of the new yorker
advanced me forty thousand dollars uh
i was getting quite close to the end at
that point but i again i had run out of
money i was constant i constantly ran
out of money because this thing took
many more years than one could have
anticipated it was a very difficult
thing to do to both write an honest
complicated history of the war and an
honest biography
twinning the two together
without letting the one get out of
balance without putting more emphasis on
the man than he deserved or and without
spending more giving more space in the
history than it
could bear if you were going to twin it
with a biography and also catching
subtlety and writing in a form which
would have this narrative drive
which i wanted because i felt i felt
very profoundly that vietnam is a pain
is such a painful experience that unless
you presented it to the reader in a way
that a reader could could
pick up a book and read a personal story
in a narrative form that would drive
forward
americans will not come to grips with it
in the abstract and we need to come to
grips with this war
we've got to somehow redeem the lives
that are remembered with the names on
that memorial
if we're going to draw any lessons from
this war and that was the thing that
kept me going those years at any point
did you worry that you might have become
obsessed with this project
well when
i was less obsessed than than i was
trapped in it
i was very worried of course
at the years going by they were very
grim years
i don't think i was obsessed in the
sense that i wanted to go on writing it
forever i wanted it to end people said
to me you're going to have postpartum
depression when it's over
nonsense i say you know i want this
thing to end
i felt less trapped than obsessed i knew
after by 79 that i had a book that would
work the question was how soon i could
get it done
and it was it kept the deadlines kept
going by and i kept missing them i would
set deadlines for myself
and uh but but uh i felt a great sense
of being trapped i wanted to desperately
wanted to finish this book
uh because i knew it would work once it
was done it was a question of getting it
done did you ever find yourself blocked
when you were writing
not black but i found i would spend days
battering away at a problem because
you're looking at a book which is long
360 000 words but it covers an enormous
span of years and events and it's very
telescope actually in its in its writing
and i would spend days excuse me i'd
spend a day
and not
and not finish what i had started out to
do that day i i would not write those
pages i had wanted to write that day
because i hadn't solved the problem
let's say of telescoping a historical
section or telescoping a section on
van's life
and uh i wouldn't be able to sleep that
night
i might not solve the organizational
problem of putting those pages together
until the end of the day let's say
and then i would i'd go out and take a
walk and come back and write down an
outline and then i'd be able to sleep
but some nights i couldn't sleep unless
i got i actually got work done of a
given day
i i had trouble sleeping that night and
so i desperately tried to solve a
problem
to get something
first of all i stayed organized
i tried i'm a night work i was a night
worker in those years because i have a
night metabolism but there were regular
hours and they were regular days i put
on a coat and tie when i went to the
library of congress
because i had gone to an office
previously and i
because it helped keep one organized i
kept very regular habits i led a
monastic life
because and i tried to get something
done every day
because then i could sleep at night and
i had a sense i was accomplishing
something everybody that knows you talks
about the automobile accident as a real
tough time for you uh what happened
uh an adult brained hillbilly kid who
liked to drive down the wrong side of
the road uh hit me head-on in western
maryland
and he literally liked to drive down the
wrong side of the road as he told my
wife when she interviewed him afterwards
when
uh back in 74
and it clobbered me for uh
for at least a year
uh because he broke seven of my bones
and
you
you don't even after your bones
initially heal
you do not get back the physical stamina
to work at first i could only work an
hour a day and then i'd get exhausted it
took me a year before i i got back the
stamina and probably a year and a half
before i got back full stamina and i got
some souvenirs out of it a knee that was
operated on last fall it's it's healing
now
but uh
it was it was a traumatic event in terms
of of of of interrupting a a work that
was in mid-course
ironically perhaps by setting me back
maybe it may be possible to finish this
book it was a high price
perhaps it forced me perhaps the the the
interruption and the lost time gave me
more perspective on vietnam than i would
otherwise have acquired
but it was a high price to pay do you
have a message that you want to deliver
in the course of selling your book a
political message at this point no i'm
not a political person
uh i i'm a reporter i deliberately
i had views on the war but i always try
to keep those views out of my copy
unless i was writing an essay
somebody said write an essay with your
personal opinions in it i wrote them
but in my news coverage i try to keep
them out now there are some personal
viewpoints in this in this book
obviously and i made judgments uh the
book is has got judgments in it but
essentially i tried to tell the story of
what happened in vietnam and why it
happened the message i have if there's a
message the desire let's say the desire
i have is that this book will help
people to come to grips with this war
that we will vietnam will have been a
war in vain
only if we don't draw wisdom from it
because it was our first war in vain in
the sense that it was that the people
died in it for nothing
in terms of the war itself we lost the
war
we went to war for the wrong reasons etc
we were constantly deluded in what we
did but i think if we draw
wisdom from it if we draw lessons from
it
then
the war will have turned out to have
been a good experience for this country
a better experience but a good one and
so i tried i i discovered that the war
is much more complicated than i had
imagined when i when i began to write
this book and research it and so i don't
have any political message for americans
no the desire is that people will come
to grips that the book will help them to
understand the war and if they
understand the war lots of people will
draw a different political in the narrow
sense of the word different political
lessons out of it depending upon their
political point of view
and that's fine let them i tried to
record the war
is there a movie out of this book i
don't know there's been considerable
film interest in it uh whether there
will be a film made i don't know there's
been a lot of we've had a lot of
inquiries
uh and i hope there's a film made of it
eventually because again i think that
would help
people to come to grips with the war and
john fans a highly filmable guy and the
war is a highly filmable war and the
events and vans in van's life and the
events in the war are highly filmable i
mean this is some
as you know the extraordinary scenes in
there
let's take for instance the ambush when
he
he drives down the road in 10 viet cong
are waiting for him and he's in a pickup
truck and they shoot the whole truck up
and he drives his way through the ambush
by veering off the road first
accidentally and then deliberately
driving right down through these guys
and scattering them the battle of opbak
when the uh uh when this lone gorilla
battalion uh uh defeats this uh south
vietnamese army uh
uh
armed with with air aircraft and armor
and and artillery etc the vans rescuing
the advisors the end plucking these guys
right out of a compound with north
vietnamese tanks bursting in
it's all extraordinary filmable and i
hope there is a film but i would want to
film for the same reasons i wrote the
book
to make people in hopes that it would
help people to understand what happened
in vietnam do i understand that when in
the battle of opbach that you
constructed that battle in a narrative
by using both vans words in his diary
and his reports and the north vietnamese
captured documents yes that was an
extraordinary situation where
we
the saigon side in an unusual ambush two
months after the battle captured the
viet cong after action report which was
very detailed this is what 62 63 63
and the battle occurred in january 63
and they captured the viet cong after
action report which was very detailed
because this was a major battle it's the
first
it was one of the few decisive battles
of the war
and it was the first decisive battle of
the early phase of the war it turned the
war for the vietcong it turned the war
for the communists it turned it in their
favor
they won it and it turned it in their
favor
and they were of course extremely
interested in this and wrote a long and
very detailed after-action report about
what had occurred and why that occurred
giving the the
not only the narrative of the battle
itself but the events that had led up to
it and what their situation what their
situation had been what prior to the
battle how weak they had been
how van the operations van had had
instigated had in fact weakened them and
then van had had because the battle had
been so important to him had compiled a
much more voluminous after-action report
much more
much much much lengthier than would
normally be done he'd had each adviser
write a a
a personal account which he'd attached
to an after-action report which is a
very detailed thing so i took these two
documents plus my own memories i'd
covered the battle i'd reported it and
my own dispatches and i went back and i
interviewed
the people who'd participated
and some of them one of them in
particular an operations officer had
diaries he'd kept with code code names
vietnamese or no an american although i
interviewed the vietnamese intelligence
officer who'd been there two years i
interviewed a number of vietnamese on
the saigon site who'd been in but not
the north vietnamese
not no they're they were actually south
vietnamese uh communist guerrillas they
were viet cong they were southerners i
suspect almost all of those men are dead
because the vietcong was wiped out at
10. i would suspect that i i would like
to go back to vietnam someday when was
the last time you were there
73
and i would like to go back to vietnam
after the the book has been published
and i've finished my tours etc and i'm
and after this knee that's been operated
on heels better i'd like to go back to
vietnam and see what's happening i'd
like to look up some of these people but
i suspect most of them are dead uh but i
interviewed vietnamese on the saigon
side and i went to the americans who'd
been involved in the in the battle and i
interviewed them and i then put the
action together and the two basic
documents
plus then the interviews enabled me to
put together an account that takes you
from the beginning right through this
very exciting battle this extraordinary
battle because the van's after action
report confirmed a lot of what the two
reports confirmed each other
as well as adding to each other and then
the interviews uh added more that's why
you have this extraordinary dialogue for
instance between vana and an observation
plane and these advisors with an armored
personnel carrier company
the two advisors remembered very vividly
what van had said to them uh and there
was corroboration of what he said to
them in
the operations officer's notes and in
the after-action report but of course
they remember they were young men they
were my age a little bit older and when
things happen to you that are very
exciting at a young age they're really
engraved on your memory and they had
remembered with great clarity uh uh uh
their their exchanges with van and that
in in that spotter plane and so i was
able to put put that battle together uh
um
if with a in a narrative into a
narrative which is the way i think you
have to tell battles if they're if
they're to be understood did daniel
ellsberg bring the pentagon papers to
you uh that's a really complicated story
and i don't want to get into it but but
uh daniel ellsberg copied the pentagon
papers and and uh um
um he uh he was prosecuted for it uh and
but that is another story that that i
don't want to really get into because
it's it's a complicated tale did you
ever tell the story no i've never told
the story the full story and and um
i that that that would have been a
reporter's memoir and i set out to write
a book about the war in vietnam i had
first thought of writing a reporter's
memoir but then i decided that
this was before i went to van's funeral
i decided a reporter's value was in what
he witnesses
and i had been a witness to this war
which was another reason i wanted to
write this book i thought i could bring
to the war and understanding that a
person who had not been a witness to the
world would not be able to bring to it
and i also knew people who who had been
involved in it could talk to them and we
we'd shared experiences
like these young advisors at opbach so i
didn't i i've never uh gotten into that
but you did though lead the new york
times team yeah i i got the pentagon
papers for the new york times and i was
the lead writer on the team i obtained
the papers for the times and i was the
lead writer on the team
uh uh that it started out with me and uh
and uh um
one uh uh deputy foreign editor here in
the jefferson hotel going through them
and and um
deciding what to do and we uh then moved
the operation to new york and we ended
up with 50 people in the new york hilton
by the end what year was that 1971
1971. what impact did that have on you
after you got all the publicity and the
lead on the story like that that was so
important well i
first of all richard nixon said a grand
jury uh the fbi was
questioning why neighbors and a fellow
named robert martian who was convicted
in the watergate business had a grand
jury going up in boston
and uh
under the direction of nixon etc and
that took up a lot of my time
but after that i was going to go back to
reporting but the the the pentagon
papers gave me
further insights in the war that i never
would have had without them
they gave me uh insights that that added
to my experience
got to remember now this is a war i'd
been started covering since in 1962.
i've
been on the ground in vietnam three
years
but those those papers were the greatest
historical arc they were the records of
the war and they have remained the the
best official
record
that is what i would say the best
archive
on the war that we've ever that we've
ever obtained and they they gave me a
depth of understanding i never had
before and then when van was killed uh i
realized that that that perhaps had
prepared me for the task of writing the
book
but you and and daniel ellsberg and john
paul van were all in vietnam at the same
time yes we all knew each other
what
at the end john was at his funeral john
dan ellsberg and john vann went in
totally different directions by the end
of the war but they remain best friends
there was another
capacity van had
another part of the complicated
character that he could keep a
friendship with somebody on whom by the
end he was totally until although
with whom he totally differed uh on the
war
john was totally committed to
winning it at that point dan ellsberg
was totally committed to try to trying
to stop it uh because ellsberg was a was
a force in the anti-war movement was
totally he had launched an anti-war
crusade there were a lot of people
involved in it but ellsberg was was
totally committed to it uh but they
remained friends but in those earlier
years yes everyone everyone went to we
had vietnam to win the war
are you glad this project's over
it's wonderful to finally have this book
done and to see it in print
and to then hope that
my hopes will be fulfilled
and that it will help people to to to
understand why we went to vietnam and
what we did there
because i don't think up to now we have
really
taken a look at what what we did there
and why we did it it's very important to
understand why is there anything you
left out of the book
not really not that i left there are
lots of things you leave out of a book
like this in the sense that this book is
a distillation of a much greater
uh uh
body of research
uh i had five file cabinets plus all of
these interviews but i didn't leave
anything out important no this is very
selectively written this book it's long
but it's very selectively written what's
i i i got in when i wanted to get in
i said what i wanted to say do you feel
now that you personally have come to
grips with the war yourself i come to
grips with these yes i think i've come
to understand the war myself and and i
have worked it out i i've i'm satisfied
with that um and if my 15 years when i
put into writing it another year putting
in the press
my 15 years won't have been wasted if if
if the book
is read with with the attention i hope
it's read because a book lasts a book
acquires a life of its own that's one of
the greatest satisfactions to see a book
and to see something that has a life of
its own now uh it i feel a kind of
separateness from it in a way
it's it's it's got its own life now to
open it up and look at the maps and and
uh look at the words they're there and
books hang around on shelves
and i hope uh i hope my grandkids will
read this book and it'll help them to
understand vietnam what do you want to
do next
i don't really know i want to
help promote the book because i uh
that's a necessity and then the only
specific thing i have in mind that i
would like to do is to go back to
vietnam
to see what's happened to the country
and to write about it
then what i will do i don't know i'm not
worried about it i might go back to
daily journalism i don't don't really
know i've stayed busy all my life and
the one thing that i've been taught is
is that if you want to work you'll find
plenty to do
and so i'm sure that i'll find something
to do and i if you learn as a newspaper
man that you go from story to story in
this case i went to a book to trap me
for for 15 years but it's finally done
now and i'll move on i'll do something
else any impact on your family
well the book was a was a was a very
difficult time for the family all those
years
although actually we it made us closer
as a family i was around to help raise
my children whereas i might have been on
the road two kids two kids two daughters
i think i think the girls
are happy with what's happened the book
daddy's book is finally done
how old are
our youngest is 19 and uh throughout
most of her
life
uh it was daddy's book and the uh a
family word was when daddy's book is
done well daddy's book is finally done
and i think they're happy neil shannon
author of a bright shining light john
paul van an american vietnam published
by random house
[Music]
that concludes our series of interviews
with author neil sheehan but stay with
us here on c-span for a roundtable
discussion with three retired military
officers who served in vietnam that's
coming up after a short break
[Music]
a behind the screen look at the inner
workings of the national public policy
process
that's just one feature of the weekly
c-span update the
[Music]
coming up next we'll continue our look
back at the vietnam war
our guests on a recorded roundtable
discussion are three retired military
officers who served in vietnam
they are retired admiral elmo zumwalt jr
retired army colonel harry summers and
retired army colonel herbert chandler
they talk about american involvement in
vietnam and about their reaction to neil
sheehan's book a bright shining lie john
paul van and america in vietnam
[Music]
[Applause]
colonel harry summers u.s army retired
you wrote in a review
of the
book by neil sheehan that it will
undoubtedly become one of the classics
works on the war why did you say that
well for several reasons one of course
it's extremely well written he writes
beautifully
and very convincingly so i think that
that will increase the readership
secondly he uh he takes a uh he hits one
of the main issues of the war it seems
to me one that's going to endure for
quite a long time and an issue that
still has yet to be resolved that is
the the united states in is dealing with
its allies and particularly the south
vietnam
in that respect i think that uh it has a
lesson that will endure in a very in a
very important lesson for us one and
unfortunately we haven't quite learned
and the third reason is that unlike many
of the people who've written on vietnam
he writes
much of his book from personal
experience that is
uh mr sheehan spent three and a half
years there and he speaks with some
authority that is an awful lot of the
academic accounts in particular the
vietnam war were atrocious written by
people who didn't get within three or
four thousand miles of the war
so you one may agree or disagree with
what yoshi has to say but you have to
acknowledge that he was there he was
there in iadrong he was there in the
mekong delta he saw things firsthand so
i those are really the three reasons i
believe it's going to endure admiral
elmo zumwalt uh u.s navy retired what
was your what's your reaction to what
you've seen on the book
i think he
properly
focuses
us on the fact that you cannot
win a war for somebody else that that
war winning morale and spirit has to
come from within a nation it's one of
the reasons why i
in a
modestly junior position oppose getting
involved in vietnam
colonel herb chandler us army retired
what's your reaction to the book well
basically i think neil sheehan has said
what needs to be said about
not being able to win a war for someone
else the problem in vietnam was partly
military but not totally military and
the united states approached it as a
military problem solely and went about
it as a military victory was the only
thing whereas building a viable society
and government in south vietnam was
perhaps our primary consideration we
didn't really address that any great
extent we're going to talk about this
for an hour before we start and i want
to show you a clip from the interviews
that we did i want to ask herb chandler
when were you in vietnam what did you do
there
1965 i went over with the first infantry
division i was a battalion executive
officer fought in a couple of big
battles in the third core zone north of
saigon then i spent seven months as a
adviser to the ministry of revolutionary
development developing the pacification
concept came back and served on the army
staff
on the vietnam desk and deputy chief of
staff operations i was in the assistant
secretary of defense for international
security affairs
during the ted offensive worked on the
paris peace talks for a while then went
back to vietnam commanded a rifle
battalion in the 101st airborne division
doing pacification work up in icor in
1970. admiral zumwalt how about you're i
know you were chief of naval operations
but in the vietnam theater what did you
do there well i was before i went to
vietnam an advisor to paul nitza who
was in opposition to our ever-expanding
effort in vietnam and i worked with him
on the papers
seeking to
advise mcnamara that we ought not to get
involved later 1968 to 1970 i commanded
the u.s naval forces the brown water
navy in vietnam
and then
for the following four years as a member
of the joint chiefs of staff
worried about it from the washington end
colonel uh harry summers how about you
well i went to vietnam in 1966 like
colonel chandler served in first entry
division as the battalion operations
officer of an entry battalion served
there for six months was wounded twice
and after the second time i went back to
core headquarters and served core
headquarters and operations officer
i went back to vietnam in 1974 as a
negotiator with the north vietnamese on
the powmia issue and as such went back
and forth to hanoi
almost every week and was there at the
very end that is i took part in a final
evacuation on 29 30 april and was a
second to the last army guy out of
vietnam was a
captain my name is stu harrington behind
me who had the distinction of being the
last army person out of vietnam of
course the marines were still there but
sort of turned off the lights as we went
i want to show you uh during this hour a
number of things that neoshin said and
get your reaction to it first up he
talks about the intellectual and moral
trooper
that he found at that time let's listen
to that and get your reaction to his
comment here here's neil shane
one of the reasons we we went to vietnam
in all of our self-confidence
and all of our ignorance if you will
was that
the pro the enormous success this
country had in world war ii the great
miracle
of world war ii the great moral crusade
that it was
and the economic success that followed
world war ii
led to a kind of moral torpor
uh an intellectual torpor
uh
americans cease to think imaginatively
the american generals in vietnam thought
they'd prevail simply because they were
american generals
they'd cease to realize that you could
lose a war
the american civilian leadership
assumed
that because its generals had four stars
and said they knew what they were
talking about that they really didn't
know what they were talking about
our leadership
what had happened to us was that we had
was was it was a process that has
happened to european countries that but
that had never occurred
it happened to that excuse me that had
never happened to the united states
before
is that we had gone through that
historical process of becoming a great
power
and as a result of it we had we had our
we had we had become an arrogant our
leadership become arrogant and
self-satisfied and and and unthinking
admiral zamot was he talking about you
i don't think he was talking about
any of the senior generals that i knew
at my stage of the war general abrams
was then the theater commander i know
firsthand general abrams worried a great
deal
both about the way in which the war
would wind down
and about insisting that that
civilian authority had reported
accurately to it his concerns
we all felt that we had
the war under control by that time
as long as u.s forces were there but we
all worried about whether or not there
was enough infrastructure and morale and
leadership
within
the vietnamese armed services to carry
that if we had to
move out quickly as the political
situation in this country made it clear
we were going to have to do
herb chandler what do you think about
what he said about the judge i don't uh
i don't agree with him very much at all
i think the reason lyndon johnson
committed american forces to vietnam was
because he felt that we had a commitment
to vietnam he also felt that we had
entered into commitments with many other
countries around the world and nato
the philippines and his treaties and
that if we fail to fulfill our
commitment toward vietnam that this
would cause the american commitment the
american leadership of the free world to
be called into question throughout the
rest of the world and this was his basic
reason for attempting to use american
forces in vietnam he never contemplated
a military victory there but he felt
that we had to do at least the minimum
necessary to meet our commitment around
the world and other in order to validate
our other commitments harry summers well
i think he used the wrong word i think
torpor was probably the wrong word i
think the word he was searching for is
hubris i think there was some hubris as
we went in it's amazing to me i felt the
same way when i went to korea as a young
corporal in 1950 that surely the war was
going to end because then i went in with
the first wave that when north koreans
saw the united american forces coming
they surely run i mean what a choice
they have of course they did right over
the top of us so that one of the
interesting things about vietnam is out
of three wars world war ii
vietnam and korea in the first two we
lost the first battle we certainly lost
the first battle of batan and corridor
and in north africa the first battles in
north africa and in korea i was happy to
be there as i said as a young corporal
we got beat badly in the opening months
of the war
and it concentrated our mind wonderfully
we knew that if we didn't get our act
together we could lose it but in vietnam
after the american troops were committed
to battle the idrom setting the stage
by and large whenever american forces
went into battle they were successful so
there was never this sort of
re-examination of what we were doing but
i think an important point that admiral
zumwalt made the majority of sheehan's
book and certainly the formative part of
sheen's book that formed his attitudes
were long before the u.s forces were
committed that is
you're almost halfway or more through
the book before the first u.s soldier
combat soldier that is an advisor arises
in vietnam so i think the attitudes he's
talking about primarily is during the
harkins period during the early period
62 63 64 and not so much on the later
periods of the war one slight historical
correction harry the u.s navy had the
honor of losing the first battle in
world war ii or however that's right
exactly so
admiral zimwalt if you go back to what
you were thinking back in you were there
69 70 68 70 68 70. what did you think of
the war
then that you weren't able to tell
anybody about
well uh
i i believe first that we had to move
vigorously to vietnamize because of our
political situation back home and i put
forward what i think was the first
service veterinarian program when i got
there but at the same time
i was counseling my superiors and and
urging general abrams to counsel his and
i believe he did
that
that very venomization if it came about
too rapidly
would
leave us in a deplorable situation
in korea we tend to forget that there
was the same colonial inheritance the
same
lack of a viable national entity but
because u.s forces stayed for a long
time there gradually emerged the proper
infrastructure had we politically been
able to keep our forces there for
five years eight years i think we could
have had a two vietnam solution
colonel shannon what you were there in
65 uh what were you what was your rank
then i was a major
did you have any opinion of the generals
that were in vietnam at that point and
who was there then you remember
my division commander was general uh
seaman
and uh general westmoreland was the mac
b commander and uh it seemed at that
time in 1965 i had the same impression
harry did when we came into van gaal on
our ships and we moved up to benoit and
there were mountains of ammunition in
one part of the campus and the other
part of the campus there were mountains
of coke cases piled up and trucks
running about and i felt a poor viet
cong out in the jungle looking at this
my god he must throw his hands up and
say we're through you know they've got
more coke than we've got ammunition here
and
our first two big battles we fought
north of
lai kay we my battalion was hit by a vc
regiment well-trained regular troops and
we wiped them out we had airstrikes i
lost
20 killed in the first battle in my
battalion we killed four or 500 of them
we really wiped them out and it seemed
that we were making a fantastic amount
of progress at that time although
you kept wondering where did all these
vietcong come from how did you feel
about being there the first time around
well i was a regular soldier and
i loved it i was a battalion exec
and we were having these big battles and
winning these big battles and doing my
job and it was
very exhilarating i was a
platoon leader in korea my first
assignment after west point and that was
exhilarating too you know combat uh if
you survive it is very exhilarating and
we were doing very well indeed against
these uh against the vietcong we had the
firepower and they didn't they were very
brave and they
threw themselves against us and we wiped
them out and it seemed like we were
making a great deal of progress you all
are doing interesting things in the
audience i know a little bit more before
we continue our discussion admiral
zumwalt you have a syndicated column yes
right you also have a company called
zumwalt and consultants incorporated
what kind of consulting
corporate strategy and foreign policy
and national security advice to
corporations
based where in washington dc
i stay away from government consulting
you were chief of naval operations 70 to
74 the youngest
man in history to ever have that job
that's what i'm told and at 68 to 70 you
were commander u.s naval forces in
vietnam
graduate of the u.s naval academy in
annapolis post-graduate work at the
naval war college in newport and
national war college in washington
originally from san francisco right
harry summers uh you were when you
retired a colonel in the u.s army
now you among other things i have to
find it here on the desk you've started
a new magazine called vietnam and who's
this
peg too what audience mostly
the veteran of course but
one of the surprising things in a
magazine is has just skyrocketed is the
younger generation has a great interest
in vietnam and what we've tried to do
with the magazine is make it factual
concentrate on the war itself stay away
from the polemics and make it just an
even-handed account of what happened in
vietnam and
we're into our fourth issue now and it's
doing very well how often does it come
out it's quarterly now but we hope to go
by monthly uh after the first year and
who's uh who owns it
empire press they put out a book called
military history several other civil war
history
okay and you're also writing a
syndicated column for the los angeles
times syndicate
uh and they're contributing editor to us
news and world report graduate
university of maryland a master's in
military art and science army command
staff college originally from dayton
ohio
and the colonel herb chandler retired
currently a professor at the national
defense university has is that here here
in washington yes has been doing that
for the past five years previously that
was vice president for the american
league for exports and security
assistance for four years worked for the
congressional research service served in
the army for 23 years colonel in the
infantry as a phd from harvard graduate
of west point originally from asheville
north carolina i've just started a new
organization as well it's called the
great eagles incorporated it's a private
organization what we're attempting to do
is to model ourselves on the
international executive service corps
we're taking retired military personnel
who who volunteer uh for military
training missions overseas to supplement
our security assistance program and
that's gotten off to a flying start let
me ask you a question you may not have
the answer to who is is there a group of
people that would normally be interested
in this book who are not represented at
this table in other words have we missed
a certain segment of the army or navy
out there critics of the war critics of
neo-shin that's not here well jane fonda
is missing
anybody else that you can think of i
mean civilian educators
vietnam is a fascinating subject in
schools today there's another generation
and i went up to stony brook for example
at
state university in new york and for an
evening class there must have been 2 000
students and i can't imagine 2 000
students turn out for anything but and
they're extremely they're extremely
critical they don't buy any of the sort
of the preconception
preconceptions the preconceived notions
that were current in the 60s and 70s the
the right or the left they want straight
answers and they're very interested in
what's going on and i find that very
exhilarating herb is your group is not
represented yeah there's another
audience as well and i think it's the
younger military officers who did not
participate in vietnam and who indeed
have never
really studied very much about it the
army the all the services i think have
sort of put that behind us and said that
was a terrible mistake no more vietnam's
i really haven't derived a great many
lessons from it and have turned our
attention back to
nato and the war on the central front
and i think
these people
the young military who did not
participate have a great interest in
what happened over there and what went
wrong and why it went wrong i would
suggest that there's another group that
is not represented
and that is
that liberal persuasion that has taken
as the primary lesson from vietnam that
we must never
use our military force in
ways that i would consider intelligence
uh intelligent and
that that legacy of vietnam uh is an
important one to begin to deal with in
our national discussions i think let's
go back to neil sheen again here's a
comment from the author of the book
we've been talking so much about called
a bright shining lie neil sheen this is
in your bookstores let's listen to mr
sheen again talk about the generals and
we'll come back and continue our
discussion
we were
young reporters were going out into the
field seeing what was happening talking
to advisers like van van hapen to be the
most
brilliant of the advisors
and the most outspoken
but the others were were also speaking
to us and uh we we thought that the
these fatuously optimistic uh remarks by
general hawkins were were simply an
attempt to fob us off it turned out that
he believed these illusions
and that uh and it was striking that
then after
uh
the kennedy commit the excuse me the
advisory phase of the war that president
kennedy started failed and we then they
had to send the american army and the
marine corps of vietnam prevent the
saigon regime from collapsing
uh westmoreland began to acquire the
same set of illusions
uh despite the
the uh uh the
despite his own experience at watching
harkins
westmoreland was then fueled by the same
illusions and anyone who challenged the
these was was crushed first you see van
attempting to challenge it and his
briefing for the joint chiefs is
cancelled by maxwell taylor who did not
want to hear bad news
he was convinced he was winning the war
harry summers
reaction
yeah i think he's right except that i
don't think he understands the full
dimension of the problem uh
what happened to us unfortunately we
began to get a politicization of our
senior military leadership
and the villain in villain is not the
right word because he's certainly not a
villain
but but the one who personified that
more than anyone else is maxwell taylor
that is he he resigned rather than
discussed retired rather than discussed
over the strategy of massive retaliation
the book on the thing became an advisor
to president kennedy was brought back
into the administration as military
adviser to kennedy pushing very hard for
counterinsurgency as sort of as a wave
of the future
and then was finally made chairman of
the joint chiefs by president kennedy
and it was his entourage people that
were part of his uh that he part of his
coterie that is harkins was one
certainly westmoreland was another a
buzzwheeler was a third
they shared a common view and i think
they thought in their own mind that it
was for the good of the country
that
that they really had to
to not say negative things that they had
to keep a positive face on everything
and anyone who who came out with
anything negative tended to be put down
i mean president kennedy himself fired
the army chief of staff
uh
general decker when he argued that he
wanted warfare so that the message went
out get in line
so i think it was much deeper than than
perhaps she understands and
as i said in a recent piece i i think
now that era has passed but it was a
very dangerous time before you comment
i want some somebody to react to john
paul van impe he is the the thread
through this book any of you have an
experience with him did you know him in
the mekong yes he was there as a
civilian advisor uh in 1968 when i took
over as a
commander of the u.s naval forces and i
had the opportunity to talk to him on
several occasions i found his advice
brilliant
and his understanding of the dynamics of
the war
were most useful to me in laying out our
naval strategy for the brown water navy
so you liked it i did
at the same time i would like to make
the point that i think
uh history has not accurately uh
portrayed the extent to which
mcnamara's
uh
system analysis approach to the war
which left no room for the variables
and his constant
bullish recommendations to the president
forced the then senior military to fall
in line or get fired as general decker
was
and maxwell taylor and others when they
went out there were constantly
operating with the knowledge that bad
news would not be acceptable to civilian
authority herb chandler i met john paul
van when i was with the revolutionary
development division of mcv and we were
developing a concept for the
use of military forces in pacification
using them to build the infrastructure
in south vietnam
and
i was to brief the ambassador on this
program one day and the day before john
paul van called and said that aid did
not concur and would not go along with
the briefing i briefed the ambassador
anyhow and the ambassador looked up and
said well john i don't see how anybody
can be opposed to that approved and i
think the reason
he was opposed to it was because we
didn't give him a big enough part to
play in it and i was not
that favorably impressed with
but to get back to what neil sheehan
said
i think it's wrong to blame the generals
this might have been true in the early
period when i was there 65 on the
generals were doing very well as harry
said we were winning every battle we
were
blasting the vietcong unfortunately that
was not the whole problem counter
insurgency in vietnam was not a military
problem it was a political military
problem how do you build a viable
effective government in south vietnam
that was not the military problem that
was not a military problem aid the state
department other agencies of the u.s
government opted out and turned it over
to the military to do an impossible task
political science really gives us no
formula on how to build a viable
democratic society in a former colonial
power with limited resources in the
midst of a
civil war that's a difficult job
certainly no agency of the united states
government is responsible for that and
so it was turned over to the military to
win a military victory within their
capabilities and they did so
yeah these military victories could
never be
and never were intended to be translated
into political gains for the south
vietnamese government there was no plan
for that what do you all think at this
stage of the work that general
westmoreland did over there
i think general westmoreland was well
intended i think he was an honorable and
decent man i think that
to some degree that
as colonel shannon said so well
is a failure to understand peculiar
american failing not only military
civilians as well that war is
fundamentally a political act not a
military act so that again the idea that
we could win militarily and this
we hear this again in central america is
insane i mean klaus would said that 150
years ago it's insane to think that any
such thing as a military victory is
possible there's only a political
victory to which the military can
contribute its part admiral zumwalt your
opinion of general osmond
i was not there during
westie's period in command i agree with
the judgment that he is a fine and
honorable person
general abrams who succeeded him and for
whom i worked was meticulously honest in
reporting the bad as well as the good
both verbally and in writing and
i'm confident that president johnson had
accurate reporting during a general
abrams period there mr
chandler yeah i'm sure he had accurate
reporting of the military situation and
what was going on and lyndon johnson
said he wanted [ __ ] skins on the wall
and by that i suppose he meant some
progress in building a viable south
vietnamese government general
westmoreland and this no what do you
think
westmoreland uh was a good military
leader within the bounds of his
capabilities and what he had he won
military victory after military victory
it was not necessarily his job to be
able to coordinate and translate those
military victories into political gains
for the south vietnamese
government and that was the problem and
no one was in charge of that really and
the south vietnamese government corrupt
as it was was untouched by this colonel
somerset yeah when general westmoreland
took over his commander the vietcong
were about to win the war
when he left his commander the vietcong
by their own admission today were spent
force so if you measured in purely
military terms he was enormously
successful which makes the point made
earlier war is not a military act it's a
political act and so in political terms
when he left of course things were in
turmoil the one place that it counted
that public opinion back at home had
been ruined had
had turned against the war and which was
irretrievable so in political terms it
was a disaster in military terms it was
a success what all do you think what do
you all think of us spending so much
time on a journalist's interpretation of
the war
versus say a military man's
interpretation are we spending too much
time on this i don't think so no the
military have written military histories
of the war uh a lot of them and it tells
how the battles were fought and so on
but the
mission of the military the mission of
the united states the counterinsurgency
the building of a viable political
system in south vietnam this was the
problem that the united states just
really failed to address and is not now
organized to address in any other part
of the world
well
i think that this book deserves praise
because
not only is it a reporter's observation
but it was a reporter on the scene as
colonel summers has pointed out
i think it's important to realize that
it's not history it's reporting what one
man saw and and largely a man who was
educated by a single brilliant
individual with all of his pluses and
minuses and john ban had minuses as well
as pluses so that
historians need to use this and properly
discount balancing with other accounts
before the true accurate history of
vietnam will be portrayed the ocean told
us that he
started the project of writing this book
some 15 years ago and the thing that
really triggered it for him and where he
started was at the funeral
of john paul van here in washington
let's listen just a little bit to what
he had to say about that
and i went to his funeral at arlington
because he was he was a friend
and it was like and when i walked into
the chapel
it was like going to a very strange
class reunion
uh i got there only about 10 minutes
before it started and the chapel was
already full
and uh
ev and this man had paul had drawn
together all
everyone or almost everyone who was of
significance uh in that war
uh uh
that is a great many of them i mean here
was william westmoreland was the chief
pallbearer of this former renegade
lieutenant colonel who retired from the
army in 1963.
daniel ellsberg was over on the other
side sitting next to the family
uh edward kennedy came in a few minutes
before the
the the service began and i thought of
the one kent the kennedy who had turned
against the war the second kennedy the
one kennedy who had started us into
vietnam john harry summers any reaction
yeah i i again you can see
in the book it comes without clearly the
depth of neosheen's caring and that's
one of the things i think that makes it
a powerful book also very peculiarly she
and his writing in a permanent
perspective of a soldier i mean he right
before he went to vietnam he just spent
three years as an enlisted in the
american army in fact i missed being his
company commander by a year he was in
the seventh entry division in korea
edited the division newspaper went from
there to the
to the war in vietnam so that you can
sense in the book a soldier's
perspective in a sense of holding
the military to its own ideals and i
think part of his disillusionment was
when he found the military was not
living up to its ideals i i think he was
very much an idealist and i think that
comes through very strong in the book
one of the main tenets of the american
character idealism
do you all remember your own
relationship with the press over there
herb shannon did you have any contact
with the press oh yes in the early days
in 1965 when we were being very
successful we were hounded by a bunch of
guys who really didn't know what
was happening and every time we had a
battle and were doing very well somebody
would stick a microphone in my face and
say was this an ambush how american
forces were always being ambushed and
that's all they knew it seems to me they
were looking for a sensational story of
americans being ambushed we weren't
being ambushed at all we were winning
battles very well and this uh basically
was my impression that they were
uninformed and uh and were looking for
some sensational aspect of it that was
over 20 years ago do you have any sense
of who had the power in the press
back here in the united states who was
influencing
the politician from my point of view i
didn't know i was a major in the field
and
there's a great picture of dan rather
helping carry some of our bodies out of
the jungle after one battle he had in
december of 65 that he used for
publicity and a lot of these guys were
there and were helpful but
they weren't looking for uh the facts
they weren't looking for a deep story of
what was going on they wanted something
of what was happening that day was this
an ambush if it wasn't an ambush they
lost interest how'd you feel about the
press then and now man well at that time
i felt that they were bothering and they
didn't understand and i didn't need to
didn't need them around basically
now
i think they were very valuable once
they learned what was happening i don't
think the press
ever reported anything that was not
happening in vietnam i think after a
while they began to question as did the
american public
whether we were being successful or not
whether our military knew what was going
on and not only our military our
civilian leadership whether we were
indeed
having a viable concept in vietnam and
mozilla did you have a sense when you're
in the mekong delta who had the power in
the press
uh
yes our sense was that
it was
controlled way over on the liberal side
to the level of 90 or 95 percent we used
to say in vietnam that
the
soviet media
were told what kind of lies to print
whereas the u.s media got to decide for
itself
now in truth
that is an exaggeration
just as the military tended to put a
favorable gloss on the news though the
media tended to highlight and emphasize
the unfavorable and therefore an
intelligent reader had to read both
and come down in the middle in order to
get accurate uh insights
how about publications did at the time
in the early days neil shane was writing
for upi and he
wrote for the new york times and he was
involved in the pentagon papers and all
that
and i think i read herb shanna where you
were on the other side of that pentagon
paper you wrote some of them i wrote
part of them in the uh november and
december of 1968 as the administration
was about to change i did the part on
the tet offensive to kind of wrap it up
did you have a sense when you were there
that the new york times was being read
by everybody and did you ever talk to a
new york times reporter quietly or off
the record or feed your own particular
thinking to a new york times reporter
i talked to a large number of reporters
the the only one who really stands out
as a fellow who did his homework
brilliantly was kai's beach chicago
daily news right
but there were other good reporters
there
uh
i think that uh
there were many who were honestly trying
to come out with balanced reporting
but there were also the headline seekers
who distorted in order to get the
headline
did you divide your uh feelings about
the press between the television people
and the print people were was there a
difference yes i thought that the
television tended to
exacerbate the bad news
you never saw them or very very seldom
saw them
covering a favorable story it was always
the unfavorable and then the the verbal
reporting that went with the pictures
was sometimes even worse than the
pictures themselves
harry summers i'm just kind of fortunate
i suppose one of the reporters with us
quite a bit was al chang
and al had been the uh my my battalion
commander's platoon sergeant during the
korean war so they had a close
relationship
when i was wounded the second time
everyone in our command group was either
killed or wounded except for two
reporters from upi who picked up rifles
and there were our security i'm not so
sure they'd want that known but they
weren't so but of course i was a captain
dealing the captain's level at that time
so
you know my impression was quite
favorable of the press in retrospect i
think that
as i went back in 1960s
1974-75 of course it was another
another ball game i ran into a couple
people i thought were rather
contemptuous but
but by and large i thought the press in
country did a fairly good job uh you're
speaking about television the people we
ran into were mostly television
cameramen and as everyone knows tv
cameramen are somewhere to the right of
genghis khan
it's a stand-up commentator but the
cameraman are always
always hard-line hawks but
so i got a very favorable impression of
them but
i think that as in the first four
correspondent i did a piece on this on
william hart russell his dispatches from
the crimea everyone agreed were quite
good and he told the truth but william
delaney the editor of the times in
london had his as a crusade to bring
down the government and did using those
dispatchers so i think the editors
particularly television editors who cut
the film to fit the time and the the
editors on the newspapers and magazines
took these dispatches from the field and
used them to their own end so i think
you have to differentiate between a
working reporter in the field and the
people back at the other end who were
guiding the news let me go back to
something i asked you earlier if we were
to slip another chair at this table and
from all of your experience
people you know that you now talk about
what kind of an individual would come to
this table that would be very unhappy
with what we've been saying or what
you've been saying or what neil sheen is
saying and are they out there and are
they military men who think that general
harkins was terrific
uh or that uh civilians would think that
robert mcnamara couldn't have done
better all these kind i mean are there
still people that you deal with that
argue a whole different point of view
than what we have here today
i think the person who would be most
critical are the people
who
who
avoided the war as the people who seem
to be bothered most by the vietnam war
are the people who didn't serve and it
kept constant and this coil thing was i
think was in-stream
illustrative the people outdoing
themselves apologizing for why they
didn't serve in vietnam and i think
those of us who served thought
you know we should we're not interested
you didn't serve you live with it you
made your decision so be it so i think
there's a group of people out there who
still need to justify their actions in
the 60s and 70s
and who would who would
who would uh
grasp some of the things that neoshin
had to say and really distort them to
their own view that is that the war was
unwinnable that some of the reviews are
starting to say that that this was an
entirely negative book and only
gives a negative perspective on the war
and i don't think anyone who read it can
come out with that kind of a judgment
but do people read what they want to
read herb shannon do you have any
examples of people who are in the
military who totally disagree with you
on those situations well a lot of people
in the military disagree that the
military didn't do a good job in vietnam
or that the military lost the war
because they felt they did a job that
they were sent to do i think another
group sitting at this table though that
might disagree with the book and
question it are the young american
draftees who went over there and fought
well for their country and some of them
died and some of them
came back and or the better for that
service someone for the worse that
service and now they read that this was
all a wasted effort that no one really
knew what was happening over there the
government was confused that we weren't
helping the south vietnamese it was all
a terrible mistake and they expended
their life their time their treasure
for nothing and i think they're the ones
that have some questions to ask and
someone i would like to see represented
here a spokesman for
that group of vietnam veterans who have
paid
a heavy price for being there
the cancer victims the ones whose
children have birth defects the ones who
carry wounds that are debilitating
whom this country has not yet adequately
recompensed as we did the veterans of
world war one and two in korea
we've got a lot to do in this government
before we've fully paid our debt to
those and somebody ought to be here
speaking forcefully for them the
audience should know if they don't
already by now that you lost a son and
want to tell just briefly how he died
just a short time ago yes after a five
and a half year battle with two
different forms of lymphoma which both
he and i
sincerely believe were the result of
exposure to agent orange
something that i used to defoliate
riverbanks to reduce casualties
and he has one of his two children who
has a sensory integration dysfunction a
birth defect as do
scores of children of vietnam veterans
let's look at another clip of the
interviews with neil sheehan again we're
continuing talking a little bit about
the press let's hear what he has to say
about this and get your reaction
at the beginning i suspect the press
helped us
to go to war in vietnam
uh
the
the press was in general the
the news media of this country in my
opinion
tend to be
quite conventional
they reflect conventional ideas
they are not
the
cabal of liberal plotters that the right
wing would have us believe at least that
does that thesis doesn't stand up to
reality in my experience in the
beginning
uh
you you have um
first of all
let's take my myself and the small group
of reporters in saigon
we were objecting to the way they were
the war was being fought because the
advisers in the field the military
advices in the field were telling us
that it was being lost
but our objective was to help the
country win the war we thought it our
duty to report the truth so that we
could win if you take the press back
here
they were by and large
accepting what the kennedy
administration was saying and then later
on what president johnson was saying
colonel chandler
your reaction i think the press by and
large in the early stages did indeed uh
support the president's policy as they
normally do i think neil skinner's
probably quite right in that
aspect i'm not sure that they did a lot
of in-depth analysis of what was
happening in vietnam what the situation
was who ho chi minh was what the issues
were the issue was international
communism as lyndon johnson framed it
and the press accepted that so yes they
supported us in our going in i don't
know if they informed the american
people very well as to what the stakes
were and what the mission was what the
objective there was why the united
states should get involved there is the
press a liberal cabal mr shan says it's
not i don't think it is no not in my
experience uh and as you say the editors
back here as harry said the editors back
here have a lot to say no the uh
the reporters out in the field in my
experience were looking for a
sensational story but they once the
fighting started they were with us and
they understood the fighting man and
they uh were supportive of the fighting
man
and rosemont did you find that the news
media reflect conventional ideas
there was a significant body of
reporters who
tried to reflect the
insights that they got from the people
in the field
there was another
uh significant subset who never left
saigon and who reported rumors and
gossip and horror stories
the media
are like any other profession there are
very good ones and very bad ones and
then there are those who were in the
middle
you interested you made a comment
earlier about kai's beach is he still
alive
yes i believe he is i was with him just
less than a year ago in new york
i remember people saying uh
back in the late 60s early 70s that he
was the best reporter in vietnam and he
wrote for the chicago daily news what
made him a good reporter well kais
seemed to me to have the ability to go
beyond the immediate factual event which
he always reported accurately to come to
the conclusions
concerning trends developments that sort
of thing
he had a lot of experience at war
colonel summers you're now a member of
the press uh
magazine u.s news and will report a
column what about some of the things
nielsen said press helped us to go to
war
news media reflect conventional ideas
and that the is the presses are not a
liberal cabal
i think the first point if you go back
and read that in fact i was just talking
to an anti-war group up at amherst
several months ago and so if you go back
and read the new york times washington
post of the early 1960s they were
overwhelmingly in favor of what we were
doing in vietnam
it was the idealistic side of the
american character that tended to propel
us into being involved in vietnam that
tends to be forgotten now
i think the reporters that i ran into
were pretty honest people that is that
they were trying to do a good job of
course they were trying to get a byline
and that's how they make their living
that's how they get ahead and one of the
things the military
is not too sensitive is how a reporter
makes his living
bias on the part of the press i think
that the biggest problem with the press
is is they tend to go with the pack that
is as george orwell said before world
war ii
that that once an idea becomes common
everyone goes with the idea and to go
against the accepted wisdom is just
almost impossible for one thing your
editor won't let it get printed because
he doesn't want to take an opposing
point of view so that ideas tend to get
underreported for example in chin's own
case now one of the bright shining lies
of the vietnam war that he unfortunately
i think unintentionally gives his some
credence to is that somehow the other
side was the repository of
of the genuine social revolution and my
god the events of the last 10 years have
proven that if there was ever a
reactionary force in vietnam it had to
be the north vietnamese and the
communist side who were who was uh
as has been said were
were uh were nazis with a human face
they were really the force for evil as
has been proven
proven by subsequent events that is it
was obvious that the corruption of the
south vietnamese was corruption of the
pocketbook it was and that's easy to
report but corruption of power and
corruption of the soul which was the
problem with the other side was very
difficult to report so you so you see
the boat people continue to this day uh
the viet cong are now both people the
north vietnamese are now voting for both
people
those kind of phenomena are very
difficult to report especially in a
closed society where they don't give you
the kind of access that you get in an
open society so that that tends to get
underreported right
in my best of all possible worlds i wish
there was some way for the media
to police themselves after the fact in
the same way that
the military do
in looking into a disaster
i believe that it's unfortunate that
there have been no retrospective
analyses
by the media themselves
of the extent to which their reporting
was grossly an error in certain cases
for example the fiction that it was
really legitimate
national liberation movement we now know
from the vietcong leaders themselves who
escaped that they were ruthlessly
crushed once hanoi took over it was an
invasion which is what the military
always said it was
that kind of a
post-event analysis is somehow missing
with regard to the media whereas the
congress does it for the executive
branch and the executive branch does it
for itself
um this may not be unfair i did we
didn't ask you before you got here to do
this could you recommend other than this
book and i'm not sure you're
recommending this book but could you
recommend other
books i know you've all written some
books uh on one subject or another uh
you can mention your own you like we're
somebody who's just starting to really
think about this and the history of it
all can go and get a balanced
presentation
uh
start with you colonel i
again
vietnam is so much time and space
dependent so is the literature on the
wartime space dependent uh
colonel chandler's book on lyndon
johnson for example is an excellent book
and stanley carnell with some may
disagree with stanley carnell's overview
of the war vietnam history is a good
book
my book on strategy looks at the
strategic considerations that were made
general uh bruce palmer's book 25-year
war looks at the joint chiefs of staff
and their actions in the war admiral
zumwalt's book on his experiences in
vietnam looks at that facet of it so
there's a great many books on the war
and i think that
in a great many good books on the war
and i must say that i think my own
personal view is that the best books in
the war are by the participants and by
the journalists the worst books
unfortunately are by the academics but
admiral zelma your recommendation uh
there's a very fine book on the naval
aspects of the award done by lieutenant
commander cutler the name which i
believe is the brown water navy
that is the best thing i've seen it even
beats my own book on watch
your book is titled on watch right
colonel chandler my book of course
covers the decision making process in
washington and how we got involved in
the conflicts between the civilian uh
decision makers and the military there's
another little book uh jeffrey race
wrote a book on called an lock i believe
it is which talks about an american
advisor and his frustrations and how the
vietnamese viewed him and how he really
didn't understand
despite our best and good-hearted
efforts what was really going on in the
hearts and minds of the people over
there
one of the questions asked of neil shane
in our series was what comes to mind
when the word vietnam is mentioned let's
listen
the
wasted gallantry
the sacrifice
in vain
provided of course we don't draw some
wisdom from it but but the tragedy
of it all is what comes to mind uh
the inevitability of it because it was a
war toward which we were
headed as a nation there was a great
inevitability about it uh but all of
those things come to mind to my mind the
the the the the the names on the wall
down there at the memorial
uh the
the the sadness always comes to mind at
the same time uh you you have that
it's it's even sadder because of all
because of all that that gallantry that
went into it all that self-confidence
and that was wasted
what uh what does the word bring to your
mind
it brings to mind a whole spectrum of
emotions ranging all the way from
my treasured
recollections of the prisoners of war
jim stockdale
jerry denton everett alvarez william
lawrence
to the treasonous performance of jane
fonda
do you when you say treasonous
performance of jane fun does that still
bother you
yes very much so i don't think she has
ever fully fathomed the depths of what
she did to our men fighting on the front
and most especially to those being
tortured in hanoi while she claimed that
that was not the case
colonel summers what is uh the word
vietnam i think i would agree with the
with the neo-shin's comment the tragedy
of it that is i was fortunate enough to
serve in vietnam in 66 67 and i truly
feel we had the best army the united
states ever put in the field those
soldiers were magnificent they did
everything you asked them to do and more
and
they were so willing so brave so
dedicated and to think that because of a
failure of strategy at the top that all
of their sacrifices proved to be in vain
it's just
it's just it's what propelled me to
write my book that is to try to get
some feel for what happened so that we
don't make that kind of mistake again
herb shannon how about you now well same
thing uh basically i think of the south
vietnamese people my friends who wanted
to be left alone basically to live their
lives in freedom who didn't want to be
communists who did not have a government
that supported them or helped them
the young officers in the south
vietnamese army that i worked with who
were just as good of nationalists
as the north vietnamese as ho chi min
who are now under that system who who
were lost who were not supported
we have
about 10 minutes left uh and and maybe
this is the wrong moment for this but
let's try it anyway uh when you think of
vietnam
what
what story do you like to tell about
your experience in country and your
your command over there what do you
what's that first story you remember or
the one that you like to tell people
when they like sit around talk about the
experience
mine
has to do with the creation of a
floating
anchored base in the middle of the
kulong river in the southernmost tip of
the delta
an anchored pontoon series
which we turned into an impregnable
fortress
and
which the senior military adviser of the
fourth corps
reported to general abrams was a
disaster waiting to happen
but which his fine deputy general rossen
endorsed and we were able as a result of
that activity to pacify a significant
portion of the delta
alzheimer's what do you remember i guess
one and one i use to start off my book
with is a rather classic one of going to
hanoi five days before the fall of saga
and of course being in the mood you can
imagine not being very
very sad about what was happening and
saying to my north vietnamese
counterpart north vietnamese colonel in
somewhat of a fit of peak you know you
never beat us on the battlefield
and he thought about in a minute and he
said well that may be so
but it's also irrelevant and i thought
the shortest course on strategy that i'd
ever had because it's exactly right that
is our military successes were
meaningless because of our political
failures
colonel chandler what do you remember
well as i
mentioned i commanded a battalion 101st
airborne division in the area called the
street without joy in fondine district
and we had
trained the people we had cleared the
minds from the area and we were putting
these refugees back into their villages
and helping them build a village and
training them to defend themselves and
as our american forces withdrew at that
time i remember uh the vietnamese
district chief came to me and said can i
borrow your helicopter and i said what
poor and he said well vietcong tried to
infiltrate these three new villages that
we settled out there and i've got three
bodies and three prisoners i have to
bring out and that that time i knew that
we had really succeeded in pacifying
that area they were taking care of their
own security that they had we had won in
that particular area at that particular
time
could john paul van exist again in any
kind of an environment do you think in a
future conflict we might have
i think in every war there there are
legendary figures i think of t lawrence
in arabia during
the first world war for example but
i i would hope that the circumstances
that led to
john
paul van becoming a legend and never a
crew again
carl
i think you know people are not familiar
with the internal workings of the
military but i think there are many john
paul evans many of them today that is
the bolsheviks bolshevik in a sense of
someone who rails against the system and
fights within the system
tend to do very well at least in the
army my experience after 38 years in the
army is that you can stand up and you
can you can argue with the boss and you
can tell me what you think and
and he may not like it but he'll listen
and i think that's one of our great
strengths so that we have to encourage
the john paul vents in the sense of a
man who looks at the conventional wisdom
and says it's not right we've got to do
something could neil shan or any other
author pick a number of other people
like john paul van that existed in
vietnam do you think and written about
them well they weren't certainly as well
known but there were people arguing
against the conventional wisdom there
were people standing up and telling
general abrams or general what's more
for that matter that things weren't
going right they ought to listen
i work for the one of the finest
generals that i've ever worked for in my
life in vietnam you know william de pew
a very controversial gentleman here he's
in the book too yeah and and and neil
sheehan of course is looking at him in a
different dimension i thought he was one
of the finest people i'd ever worked for
in in my army career but he was the kind
of guy you could stand up and say no
damn this isn't right we ought not to be
doing it he might not agree with you but
he listened one of the things that i
wish could happen is that we could begin
to get some accurate
uh reporting of some of the legendary
vietnamese figures on our side so that
this caricature of the cowardly
vietnamese would be dispelled i think of
general trung who commanded the first
division and was the full equivalent of
any american division commander we've
ever had or of admiral chan who did a
magnificent and philosophical job of
building the vietnamese navy
herb chandra about john paul van today
could he exist in a future conflict oh
yeah i think so i think john paul van
was someone that sought controversy as a
way of changing things i know many
people in the american military and i
might even be counted uh as one of them
who tried to change the system from
within from their positions in
the secretary of defense's office in the
white house who had the same kind of
concept and tried to turn this around
but uh there was really no system within
the american government for turning it
around for changing it to a pacification
effort to building up the south
vietnamese government so there were many
people and they were
listened to they were heard they weren't
listened to
part of what neil sheen does in the book
is talk about some vietnamese
officers who
weren't and this is early 63 and 6263
who weren't
reliable and who were taking all their
orders from
president of the country and all that uh
do you all do you have one that you were
a vietnamese military uh person would
you like to tell us about that was there
when you were there well my counterparts
on the four-party joint military team at
the very end 74-75 who were standing in
the communists arguing with them toe to
toe and in the very end as as everything
was collapsing they sent their families
out of country
and they this is over the last two or
three days wars as the north vietnamese
tanks were closing in on saigon but they
themselves stayed because they were they
were
they were officers in the south
vietnamese military and they wouldn't
run
and and they stayed in and and went to
concentration camps i guess they're now
just coming out of it uh
it's interesting that that in four core
the the fourth quote which never really
was touched in the final days
the the core commander and his deputy
both committed suicide
on the first of may 1975 rather than
surrender to the communists so there
were many fine south vietnamese officers
and and neoshame would admit that if you
know and i've talked with neonatal he
admits that there were fine soldiers in
south vietnamese military half a you
know a quarter of a million south
vietnamese died in defense of the
country
but unfortunately at the top
there was rottenness and corruption i've
used the analogy and i think it's very
apt is the fall of france in 1940 for
almost exactly the same reasons as a
corrupt civilian government corrupt
leadership at the top good soldiers but
to know to no avail colonel shannon do
you have somebody oh sure general trung
i don't know if the same one you
mentioned who was the i-corps commander
in 1970 who turned
a retreat around he just announced
anybody heading south gets shot they all
turned around and they fought very well
general tang who was the minister of
revolutionary development when i was
there in 66 uh was an outstanding figure
but he didn't have the political
connection so he was too honest and uh
these guys really didn't get anywhere uh
there were majors and uh captains down
the line my district chief some of my
regional force commanders who had
gallantry crosses down to their knees
and have been out there for years but
we're getting no support from a distant
indifferent government
for a long time now we've been
discussing this book which is a bright
shining light by neil sheehan it's in
your bookstores and uh we spent two and
a half hours with mr shin
and the last hour with our three special
guests some of whom you've all seen
before somewhere on television or read
their books
colonel herb chandler is retired from
the u.s army spent
some time over in vietnam back in 65 and
from 68 to 69 was an assistant for
southeast asian affairs for the
assistant secretary of defense worked in
the pentagon
worked on the pentagon papers and is
originally from asheville north carolina
and uh is here currently as a professor
at the national defense university
admiral elmo zumwalt jr now a syndicated
columnist and president of his own firm
admiral zumwalt and associates
authored two books on watch and my
father my son served in the navy for 32
years was chief of naval operations the
graduate of the u.s naval academy is
originally from san francisco and
finally colonel harry g summers jr
writes a syndicated column for the los
angeles times contributing editor to u.s
news and world report is now involved in
the start of a new magazine called
vietnam as a book called on strategy a
critical analysis of the vietnam war and
the vietnam war almanac served in the
army for 38 years a graduate of the
university of maryland as a masters in
military art and science army command
and staff college originally from dayton
ohio thank you all
for joining us and to our audience have
a good day
[Music]
stay with us here on c-span for a live
viewer call-in program we'll open up our
phone lines to get your reaction to
these discussions about american
involvement in the vietnam war that's
coming up after we take a short break
[Music]
[Laughter]
united states foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
neil sheehan author of bright shining
lie
about two months ago you were here we
spent two and a half hours talking about
your new book
john paul van america in vietnam
what's been the reaction to the public
since we last talked
it's been wonderful for me uh i
when you when you're a reporter you
never believe anything's going to happen
until it happens and the reception has
been just
marvelous for me i pinch myself all the
time the most moving reactions have been
from vietnam veterans uh
letters and an occasional phone call i
get in which people say you you put me
back there and that's what it was like
but now for the first time i know why it
was why it happened i know what it was
all about and that's what i wanted to do
when i wrote the book and i'm i'm deeply
moved by those reactions on your screen
you'll see what the book looks like and
we spent a long time talking about the
contents of the book and we're going to
go to the phones fairly soon because of
people are already calling and anxious
to talk to you where have you been
i've been all over uh most recently san
diego uh san francisco seattle and
denver and then atlanta and miami and
then up to new york for the book award
what kind of things have you been doing
to talk about the book i've been on
television radio and a good a good bit
of of news a good many newspaper
interviews uh people have been wonderful
to me and i'm i'm deeply grateful to
them any hostile reaction anywhere once
in a while you get people calling in on
call-in shows you get people calling in
occasionally and they're really angry
because of course there's still there's
a lot of anger out there over the war
and you don't know quite whether they're
angry at you or they're just angry and
they and they they they talk about the
media doing them in or linda johnson
doing them in or and you see letters
occasionally i saw one recently not
about my book but about saying nixon had
done us in it's amazing the amount of
anger out there over the war what's the
question that's most often asked
why how could this have happened i mean
how did our government get us in
this deeply and stay there that many
years that's the question i get most
often asked
you won a big award i you know it was
all over the papers the national book
award how did that work
that was quite extraordinary because you
go to it you first of all you have a
reading the night before in which all
the finalists read and then you go to a
dinner
and they give they have two two
categories fiction and non-fiction and
first they read the fiction of
certificates and then they give each
of five finalists a certificate and then
the jury announces its award and
non-fiction was second so we waited
until the end and it was it was enormous
tension it was like going into battle in
a way and then they announced the the
award and i was just of course
absolutely thrilled uh
deeply moved to
to to have been awarded the national
book award by the jury and deeply
grateful to them who who gives the award
a jury does uh of of uh
people who are picked each year by the
national book awards uh uh and and they
they're they're writers most of them and
they they make the decision and you see
you had to read we had to read part of
the book yes the night before at the
saint peter's church in citicorp
building in new york uh they uh asked
each of the authors and eight out of ten
came of both the fiction and non-fiction
to read a portion from their book and i
read a section on
the argument between general
westmoreland and general krulak
who was a marine general over whether we
ought to be fighting a war of attrition
or not and then what happens to the
marines up on the dmz i really i really
the beginning of that and to me because
to me that's one of the most moving
sections of the book who are you up
against
there was uh uh there were there was
four other books uh one was a uh by a by
very fine writer named brenda maddox uh
it was a biography of james joyce's
wife nora
and then there was a a book on
reconstruction by eric foner and uh and
then a biography of freud by peter gay
so
so there was quite a quite a spread
what's it meant i mean the reason why i
keep asking you a lot of these questions
about that particular award is that you
got so much publicity out of that
but what does it mean i mean have you
gotten offers to write another book or
go do a movie or
when you get this award isn't it isn't
it in itself enough to satisfy you well
the award in itself is is is a wonderful
thing because uh it's it's it's from
your peers uh it it it's given to you by
other writers and and richard rhodes for
instance who won the award previously
was one of the judges and scott berg
wrote a fine book on maxwell perkins the
the famous editor uh was as was another
of the judges and it's it's uh and a
professor garrity at columbian historian
was another and it's it's very moving
when you get something like that from
your peers but of course there has i've
gotten letters from everyone and it did
get the book some more publicity and
about movies i don't know but there's
been a lot of movie interest i hope
somebody will make a good movie out of
the book how's it selling
it's doing well thanks thank goodness
it's it's been on the times bestseller
list and it's been on the local
bestseller list that isn't you i run
into it seattle it's been on the
bestseller list here in washington and
it's it seems to be doing quite well all
of our east coast lines are already
lighted and we have three other lines on
the west coast for those who live on the
west coast that you can use it's 202 737
three uh i mean seven eight seven two
seven two seven and uh we also have an
international number that you'll see on
the screen here in just a moment uh for
those of you who live around the world
outside of the united states it's
three 202-737-6734 begin dialing now and
we're gonna go to the phones here in
just a couple of minutes say two minutes
or so till we take our first call from
neil sheen is going to spend a whole
hour and a half this is after you asked
to uh have mr sheen back after you
saw those interviews and wanted a chance
to talk directly with him and ask him
questions and give us your opinion
in the book what chapter do you find
that people are most interested in
the people talk to me most about about
it depends on the individual the thing
that seems to fascinate people most is
the character of john van the fact that
the man has in him these great qualities
these qualities of greatness which he
had
of and also these great flaws
the the mixture of the two in the man
seems to fascinate people and that's
what i get the most comments about
people ask me about the man when did you
discover the flaws for instance uh how
did the flaws how did the flaws in your
mind
is he still a sympathetic figure to you
and of course he is he remains a
sympathetic figure to me do you consider
him a hero yes i consider john a hero in
the greek sense of of the man of great
virtues and great flaws but that's the
the character of john and the way it it
melded together with the history of the
war it's what seems to to interest
people most any reaction more reaction
from his family about the book they've
been very good about this whole thing
his family have been very good uh they
uh are people of the vans are people of
great moral courage and great honesty
and they've been very supportive about
the whole thing let's go to the phones
for neal sheehan a bright shining lie is
the name of this book you know a lot
about it especially if you saw the
series in the interviews and it's a
chance for you to talk directly with mr
sham we go to urbana illinois for our
first first call go ahead please ryan
it's been about a year and a half since
i got it when tom wicker was on another
new york times and i can ask for
questions that came up at that time how
many people voted
how many newspapers went for republican
democrat i saw just before the election
just after the election i'm sorry to say
that there were uh
44 percent who did not cast for either
bush or dukakis and fifth of the 56
percent you may be interested to know
that two to one i'd get the exact
figures it was uh for bush now what i
want to ask mr sheen about is uh the
impact of the lack of foreign language
capacity among the american advisors and
not only those in vietnam
but i'm a 64 year old man and i went to
college after the second world war and
studied a foreign language where it
happened to be french and i was struck i
am struck in reading your wonderful book
by the incapacity of so many of our
advisors and
not only there but at home
to deal with the cultural impact of the
french experience the cultural and
military impact of the french experience
in vietnam in the uh
you know in our earlier engagement there
to what extent do you think that some
larger lessons might be learned
about americans learning about the uh
about the culture of the land of the
countries they are
going into
well i don't want to discuss for the
moment the morality of going in i just
wanted to discuss the truly practical
implications of your discussion sorry to
say i mean i mean uh purely practical
implications of
the inability of americans apparently to
relate culturally okay thank you urbana
well i think that in that period of time
in the 1960s when we went to war in
vietnam in 62
americans didn't think they needed to
know history we thought that history
didn't apply to us i think obviously
again the question of whether you
intervene aside that's that's another
matter but uh
the one of the lessons of vietnam is you
ought to know
what what where you are intervening you
better look before you leap and
obviously one of the lessons is that we
didn't know the vietnamese we went in to
support
and we didn't know our vietnamese enemy
and it would have helped an awful lot
if we had studied the if we had known
something about the history of those
people and their culture and i think it
would help for the future we didn't
think at the time we needed it
metairie louisiana go ahead please
yes sir thank you i was concerned about
something that you said about vietnam
that are insane that now that i've read
your book i understand what happened
while i was over there
being a vietnam veteran and having read
some of your writings
i can only say to them that
please do not take you as the only
source of what happened over there
because i i do not agree with your
outlook i don't even think that you
understand
what the war was all about
specifically that pet was a complete
victory for us and i don't think you
understand that the turning point of the
war was not in vietnam but was here in
this country and that you are a part of
it and in my opinion sir
you hold some responsibility
for the death
of millions of innocent people
i know you have the last word it isn't
how are yours
do you have a question uh
or do you want me to simply make a
statement i don't
first of all i think one has to look at
you mentioned the tet offensive i don't
think anyone has all the answers on
vietnam and i certainly wouldn't pretend
to have them i've done my best in this
book to tell what really happened there
and why it happened you mentioned the
tet offensive as being a victory for the
united states
what happened at tet was that the
vietcong gorillas were destroyed
and so it was a military it was a
military defeat for the vietcong but
unfortunately nothing changed on the
saigon side the saigon government
remained as corrupt and as incompetent
as ever and the north vietnamese army
was there ready to move in and take over
and the surprise blow of tet broke the
will of the american public to continue
the war and that's actually what
happened at ted now it's very difficult
to accept the fact that tet dealt a
death blow to the war that is it broke
the will of the public and and of the
johnson administration to continue but
that's what happened and i think as if
you're going to write history you have
to write it the way it happened and
that's what i tried to do
follow-up
metary
yes if i could respond to that
i think that this is one of the few
things that you have said that is
accurate
broke the backbone of the american
people the point that you didn't say was
the reason why
on network television and i understand
that they have to show exciting scenes
but they betrayed ted as a defeat for us
they betrayed it as mayhem and the enemy
taking over our embassy all of which was
not just
disinformation
it was out and out
lies
many reporters wrote about things that
were just totally false i'm seeing
reports where they say such and such a
base was rocketed when in fact they were
not even there it would have been a
terror it was a terrorist attack in some
instances and from saigon
they write about rocket fire because
they speculate just like you did about
very much
i i realize we have different
differences of opinions and that's what
makes our country great all right sir
thank you i'm afraid you just can't
accept what happened in vietnam that's
the problem uh you you don't want to
accept what happened the fact is that
the vietcong moved 15 battalions into
saigon totally unexpectedly in the book
i relate how the american ambassador was
woken up by his own marine guards at
three o'clock in the morning mr bunker
he told me this and they they told him
that he didn't even have time to put on
his clothes just pull on his bathrobe
they were going to take him away in an
armored personnel carrier general
westmoreland had just announced to the
american public that victory was eminent
and the vietcong did penetrate the
embassy compound the vietnamese
communist attack all over south vietnam
it was a complete surprise and of course
it had the predictable effect in the
united states of causing a political and
psychological collapse now this wasn't
the fault of television this actually
happened and if you can't accept it
that's that's something that you will
have to come to grips with yourself i
simply try to tell what happened
mesa arizona go ahead please
hi mr sheehan i am
very much enjoyed your book and it
illuminated again the lines of
protest and accolade i had for the
vietnam war
but
illuminated only
on in the sense of the other side that's
still unexposed of our first amendment
involvement the corrupting involvement
of our first amendment
in that whole fiasco
um
your book again
reminds me that
our sectarian
involvement
corruptly with the zm
government originally
and a quiescent congress
led us into that morass
and it's still
amply unremarked
that that involvement ever occurred
now we're into the constitution's body
itself
with the separation of powers doctrine
lately
only bandied about
with the intelligentsia after the
election
when in fact it was the most crucial
aspect to that election
what's your question sir
well i'm i'm saying that
i i'd ask for mr sheehan's uh
he does
illuminate again in his book our
sectarian involvement
with south vietnam
yet the first amendment is unremarked
and i think it should be broadly
discussed because that was
the downfall initially of our
involvement there why do you say the
first amendment was the downfall
well because we were in effect
extrapolating from the first amendment
corruptly
by taking
a sectarian side in south vietnam we
were therein establishing a religion
okay i understand i think the gentleman
is referring to the fact that the
america the united states when it
intervened in south vietnam relied very
much on the catholic community there the
first president the president whom we
put in power in 1960 and 1954 was a
catholic mandarin name negotiating
now i think
the united states actually relied on the
vietnamese catholics because they were
anti-communist it had less to do with
the fact that they were catholics than
they were anti-communists now they
happen to be anti-communists because
they were a minority within vietnam and
because
this goes back into french colonial
history but i don't think it was an
attempt to sort of to set up a separate
religion i think it was an attempt to
find a group who opposed the vietnamese
communists newport richie florida for
neil sheehan go ahead please hello brian
hi mr shannon
i bought your book after your last
interview on cnn and i'm
delighted that i got your book since
that time i bought four copies for my
four children all of them were too young
to understand what really happened at
the time we were involved in vietnam but
they understand now having read your
book i thank you for it
i wanted to say something to you about
the title a bright shining lie
these were words if i understand
correctly that john paul van himself
used is that right that's right yes yes
i find it ironic that this man whom i
consider tragic and a victim as much as
all the rest of us those who gave our
lives and those who protested the war
are in this instance and i do not agree
at all
with that terminology i think that mr
van in the final analysis lied to
himself because the lies which were told
regarding our involvement in vietnam
were neither bright nor shining in my
opinion they were dark
and they were tarnished would you please
address yourself to that
i used the the words of bright shining
light because they were john van's words
and of course in the end uh he had lost
his grip on reality by the by the end of
the war but i i felt that they were apt
because john had a had a kind of apt way
of putting things and what the title is
meant to reflect is all of the ironies
and the delusions and the misguided good
intentions uh that went into that war
and of course some of them were dark
they weren't all bright and shining and
but that's and that's part of what the
title means and i think that's what he
meant too when he used the words bright
bright shining he he was referring he
was referring to to darkness as well as
light
springfield pennsylvania go ahead please
oh thank you
i
heard mr band while serving over there
in the vietnam
and uh i think
when i did hear him i thought that
perhaps he was losing it also
and this was in 1971.
uh mr sheehan i wish you would address a
statement i believe it's on page 153 of
your book
uh that the the germans were in fact
more barbers than the japanese
i believe something like 40 percent
of american prisoners of war
died under the japanese
while something under 5 percent
died under the germans
and
uh you blamed
the two million deaths
in vietnam
under the japanese
on the french and uh
their vietnamese underlings
uh i
simply cannot accept that
i think that's a distorted statement
okay
well to begin let me answer the first
part of your question last part of your
question first
the french colonial administration the
vichy french those who collaborated with
the nazis in europe
also collaborated with the japanese in
indochina until march 1945 when they
were disarmed by the japanese because
the japanese thought they were going to
turn against them and side with the free
french they administered indochina for
the japanese and there's no doubt
whatsoever that the french authorities
were involved in those forced rice
collections that led to the the
widespread famine in north vietnam and
parts of central vietnam in 44 and 45
there's just no doubt about that
to back up i use that term you were i
was i was speaking in general of of of
the germans being the greater
well you mentioned in the book on page
53 there i was speaking uh there of
american racism towards asians in
general and the fact that during world
war ii we perceived the japanese as the
most dangerous enemy when in fact the
germans were because they had the
technological capacity and when i spoke
of barbarism
obviously the japanese were
terribly barbarous toward our prisoners
and the germans did treat our prisoners
better than the japanese treated them
that was because of the germans were
europeans and they saw us as europeans i
think you have to look at german
barbarism in terms of the of of using an
industrial uh uh system to kill millions
of people which is what the germans did
in creating those in those death
factories at auswitch and in the other
concentration camps that's what i was
talking about to me that's the ultimate
barbarity portland oregon go ahead
please
uh i just i bought your book after the
last interviews i'm a vietnam veteran
too
uh i kind of wanted to comment kind of
true to the brother from louisiana
uh we could really kind of have to quit
fighting the war which a lot of us are
still doing and figuring out why we lost
rather than dealing with what's going on
now
uh
primarily i think your comments are
blaming the messenger i mean the
constant the media did us in it's just
not true if you go back and read michael
harris book dispatches which is written
i think in 68
you'll see a book which comments on the
heroism of the the warrior and the
ultimate fertility of the war i mean i
think uh he had a beautiful phrase uh
we weren't for the war against the war
we were in the war that was a position
and uh i think it makes a lot easier for
him to deal with uh the kinds of
bitterness and anger that a lot of us of
course have now
other than that to comment in your book
and to ask you to ask your question i'm
about halfway through it
um between that and taylor branson's
book on martin luther king and i got my
reading set up right now two fine books
that came out
uh i hope they do make a movie of it i'd
heard of john paul van when i was over
there
uh
he was he became a legend
uh i have basically two questions
one
how did he hold up that kind says i
haven't finished the book that kind of
dedication to that war
knowing all he knew from very early in
the war
uh yet he spent 10 years of his wife
there
uh second
we keep referring to tech which was just
tried correctly by by both you and the
caller uh basically a military victory
which changed the war
from a guerrilla war to a war against
the north vietnamese army straight war
but something else happened during that
period which wasn't uh reported for a
year and a half i was hit on the first
day of that two days before i could go
out so i came home
and kept kind of
it took a lot out of me because i came
back
to the hospital a few days came back and
got out of the service and and and saw
this very negative feeling you know
coming over two years in a
in a war and expecting to feel proud of
it and run into the negative attitudes i
remember was a real effect then a year
and a half later i'm in college and we
got the report on my line
you know i haven't heard in any of your
interviews i watched all the europeans
saying what effect really do you think
the reports of my life had
all right portland thanks well to answer
i'll answer the the first part of your
question then go on to the second on
john van john van was a natural leader
of men and war i mean when he he was in
vietnam because he that was something he
did best he was he was one of the most
brilliant army officers of his time and
and he in war everything is important
everything has meaning everything has
urgency now in those early years john
saw the realities of vietnam very very
clearly what happened was he couldn't
let go of the war and after ted 68 he
had so much of himself invested in it
that he couldn't he couldn't give it up
and then he began to rationalize what
was going on in vietnam to say that well
we didn't have to worry as much about
the corruption in the saigon regime we
didn't have to worry about it as much
about the incompetence he began to
rationalize these things and came up
with a number of the ideas in fact which
were incorporated in nixon's
vietnamization strategy and which was
another delusion and van began to then
lose his grip on things but prior to
that i think what kept him there was the
fact that that it satisfied him
professionally and it satisfied him
emotionally
and and and so and also of course he had
that that a complicated personal side
which he was also able to satisfy in
vietnam in a way he couldn't anywhere
else
the second part of your question about
ten and the veteran i think and and me
lie i think
all of this ties together uh
not only do you have this the scapegoat
theory that the media did us in in
vietnam or linda johnson chickened out
you've got a whole lot of other
scapegoat theories but one of the things
i think that's been most unfair to the
american fighting man in vietnam is the
fact that he came home and he was blamed
for the ugliness of the war the the i
think that one shouldn't blame the
fighting man which would blame those
those in charge those who victimized the
american fighting man and milai was a
case of of of of the american soldier
being brutalized some american soldiers
being brutalized over a period of time
by the by by the way the war was being
fought by the generals and then we you
had a sadist in cali who who who enjoyed
obviously killing people and you had a
massacre that was made but the massacre
was made inevitable by the way the war
was fought by the generals
again i don't think the soldiers should
be blamed
again aside from individual blame for
cali
and those who are guilty in that
particular massacre but the massacre has
to be seen in terms of the whole war
next call clearwater florida go ahead
please
mr sheehan i'm reading your book and i
want to thank you for your years of
research and
labor to bring this
book to the american people
my wish is that every american adult
would read it
my question is to mr lamb
is it possible mr lam to purchase the
transcript of the five interviews that
you had with mr sheehan that i heard one
sunday
i would love to obtain those if possible
to send them to my son who is in the
military because i don't think right now
he'd have time to read this book and i
would so like him to read it
let me suggest to you that you give us a
call in our office
at 202-737-3220
and ask for uh matt moore who is
involved in our archives and and uh
we'll see what uh if there's enough
interest in this frankly we do not have
a transcript of those series uh but we
do have arrangements where people can
buy tapes and we'll have to discuss it
with you if it's all right tomorrow i'll
certainly call may i confirm that number
with you again sure 202
737-3220 correct
okay thank you very much for the call
let's go to uh bellevue nebraska next go
ahead please yes mr shan uh a question
uh
i'm only halfway through your book but
what prompted
buying the book was i just finished
belatedly david halwerstram's the best
and the brightest and that really uh
got my interest up i am a vietnam
veteran and a 20-year career officer who
recently retired
but do you think that
with the current situation with the nsc
is it almost a separate power entity
within the government and sometimes uh
almost not responsible to congress
uh to what the iran contra affairs
and our military uh
excursions with granada libya central
america lebanon
is there any reason to believe that we
couldn't with our
all communist or bad approach to uh
foreign affairs or so it appears in many
regards in the reagan administration
could we get in the same situation again
could we eight or 10 or 20 years after
vietnam
and for instance central america go in
and have the same outlook on a very
noble cause but not
everything but falling into the same
type of trap with the military say of
course we can do it we can do it we can
do it okay billy thank you well i think
that if we don't learn the lessons of
vietnam some other kind of disaster can
be false and vietnam was a disaster that
we brought
that we brought on ourselves uh and and
that we inflicted a tragedy we inflicted
on ourselves and on the peoples of
indochina i think the war has changed us
at least for the foreseeable future in
that the president no longer has the
ability to commit the armed forces of
the united states with the freedom that
kennedy and johnson had now of course
you can make short-term commitments as
reagan has he did in beirut uh this the
grenada thing was really a very limited
thing you're talking about one
of very small uh uh
opponents on on on an island it was a
very limited thing but in terms of a
major commitment of the american armed
forces i think there's a recoiling
against that
that's that has resulted from vietnam
and i think it would be quite difficult
for any president
at least unless the issue is clear to
the public to commit the army the navy
and the marine corps
and the air force uh as johnson and
kennedy could do with great freedom
reno nevada you're next
hi mr lam i was very interested in
hearing your report from england and uh
it was interesting to hear one of this
gentleman uh guests mention the fact
that um
it's uh that the possibility of one
world and uh also the fact that we are
the we the let's say the western world
are the only people and not the eastern
bloc or russia helping out the uh the
poor countries of this world the third
world
so what i
want to talk about today is where we're
going with what happened in vietnam the
way i see it it was a justifiable war it
was better than there were 50 000 um men
killed instead of five million men going
to war and being murdered by the chinese
crossing the border because at that time
china wanted to take over and they were
willing to go to war with us except for
the nuclear war so we fought the war
instead of letting the south vietnamese
so um because i've heard so many things
since this war of people like mr lam
i've mentioned mr horowitz comments and
how the uh communists in this country
were working to see that they would help
the expansion of communism in the world
i think one world is dangerous one world
would mean who's going to make the rules
russia who is going to where the
freedoms of the people you can't have
one kind of leadership we should remain
separate nations and we should stop
interfering with other countries okay
thank you
well i think ma'am if you take a look at
what happened in vietnam you'll see it's
a lot more complicated than you think
there's an incident in the book in fact
in which john van's assistant is
captured by the viet cong gorillas and
he's on his way to a prison camp on his
way to seven years of terrible captivity
in in in prison camps in the in the
rainforests of south vietnam and one of
his escorts is a 16 year old gorilla
a young farm boy and he asks doug ramsey
who was vance assistant who was captured
ramsay spoke vietnamese he asks him why
are you americans in this country making
war on us and ramsey explains to him
that we're there we were there because
we were stopping the chinese from
expanding into southeast asia and this
young vietnamese gorilla says to him
you're crazy the chinese are our
traditional enemies we're not going to
let the chinese take over this country
just because we share the same form of
government they do that's the same type
of government and and uh ramsay began to
argue with the young man and two older
guerrillas jump in and they say to
ramsey you're wrong and the boy's right
and of course what happened after the
war was that vietnam and china went to
war with each other
two communist countries the unthinkable
went to war with each other and what you
have to remember is after our defeat in
1975. i think what vietnam shows us is
is that the world is an awfully
complicated place and you cannot look at
it in black and white
white plains new york you're next
yes uh mr sheehan i was particularly
interested in in your last comment which
kind of dovetails with my
observation in in that
in your book you don't really cover the
decisions of the eisenhower
administration
not go along with the geneva accords
and leaving it to the kennedy
administration to
to
figure out whether we were going to
contain communism or not
i think that the the real
contrast in vietnam lies with korea
and that truman went in with united
nations
and if you consider a 20-year span
or 40-year span
we sort of won in that we contained
communism in north korea
had we done likewise in vietnam i mean
had we
acceded to the geneva accords and went
along with
the then
attitude of ho chi minh
maybe we wouldn't have had all this
difficulty in vietnam mr chan i i do
deal in the in the book with the fact
that the eisenhower administration uh
as as far as the geneva accords were
concerned uh sought to turn what the the
provisional military demarcation line up
there on the dmz the sympathy prowl into
a into a permanent frontier and to
create a separate south vietnam so i do
deal with it uh that is they put in
power in in saigon the catholic mandarin
the golden museum but you can't really
compare vietnam and korea they're two
different two different situations in
south korea you had a nationalist
government in sigmund re which had
credibility with its own population the
the koreans were willing to accept these
people as a genuinely korean government
the problem in vietnam so that we could
solidify things you could apply military
action defeat the chinese and the north
koreans and then you'd have something in
south yet in south korea which would
endure the problem in vietnam was that
you had in saigon a government which had
which was composed mainly of people who
had sided with the french during the
first war compromised themselves
politically the government was terribly
corrupt and inept and it wasn't anything
you could ever build on it was sand that
was the real problem and so the two
situations really aren't comparable
putnam county new york go ahead please
thank you brian
uh mr sheehan i want to thank you for a
very thought-provoking book
my question is essentially this
had the war
been executed
according to john van's
earliest ideas in 62 and 63
was would have the
effort still have been worth it
was the fault in the execution
or in the entire effort itself
i'm not quite sure after reading
your book
where you actually come down on that
question
what i try to do in the book is to lay
it out as it happened and let people
come down their own way and i'm glad you
asked me the question because that was
deliberate on my part i didn't want to
preach or draw
those kinds of conclusions i think if
you look at it in retrospect uh
there are two things and two things that
emerge from to me from the story and and
probably would emerge from the book if
one reflected on it one the entire
effort was probably doomed uh from the
beginning because we were dealing with
with a
a structure in south vietnam which which
couldn't survive by itself the saigon
government now van in those in that
early period and i think you'd have to
conclude his his ideas when he came back
in 65 66 john saw very sharply very
clearly then that the saigon regime was
corrupt and incompetent couldn't stand
by itself and his idea was to not fight
this big american war of attrition
because that would be applying military
force in a void his idea was to take
over the country take over south vietnam
completely reform the saigon regime
and
create a government that would have some
support in its own country that could
stand by itself when we left now of
course the war was fought in the worst
way possible the only thing that the
american generals did was to defeat
themselves to apply all of this military
force in a void
had had vans ideas been followed i
suspect we would still be in south
vietnam i'm not that is we would have
prevailed in the extent that we would
have probably crushed the guerrilla
rebellion in south vietnam i'm not sure
that in the end you can thoroughly
remake a society in the way he had
thought one could he would he had come
up with the most realistic solution any
american could come up with in that time
frame there's no doubt about it but
whether it would have worked over the
long run i'm really not sure i suspect
it probably wouldn't have worked and we
would have ended up in south vietnam
occupying the country it would have
ended up with a with a permanent
economic drain on our resources and a
running moral sore and that we would
have been dominating a people who who
will not accept foreign domination and
the vietnamese are like that that's why
their communism it was like a yugoslav
communism there's like tito as a very
national as nationalistic as as it was
communist ukiah california go ahead
please
hi uh
i haven't read your book yet
uh it's on order uh but i have a rather
general question
why doesn't somebody in the democratic
or republican party
stand up and say that america
is feeding the evil guys we're
supporting the evil guys all over the
world we with the the dictators the
anti-people
people
uh i get i get a tremendous enragement
about what i feel the united states is
doing all over the world doing bad
things to the people everywhere by
supporting the bad guys and why isn't
there somebody who will speak up in
either the democrats or the republican
party and say this caller can you give
us an example or two who you consider to
be bad
[Music]
let's
guys
um
[Applause]
my mind goes blank and
i i i read widely i read extensively and
i feel worse
and i get my
and i just have a lot of feelings
okay let me ask mr sheen if he has
do you agree or do you have a view on
this i don't think we always support i
don't think we always support the bad
guys all over the world i i think that
would be an oversimplification of what
the united states does in the world the
united states behaves like a big power
it behaves
with often with great expediency now if
you take a look at the chinese or the
soviets you'll see the same kind of
behavior very often uh
the the united states some sometimes
supports people like uh i suppose you
could pick out people in central america
like samosa who who uh certainly are are
are not very good people but at the same
time there are other instances where we
do support the right people it i don't
think you should one should blanketly
condemn
american foreign policy that to me is is
an oversimplification the great tragedy
of vietnam one of the great tragedies of
it was that it was all really
unnecessary uh had the united states not
started out at the beginning supporting
the french attempt to reconquer
indochina had we understood that
vietnamese communism was also
a nationalistic force the whole thing
probably would have been the whole thing
could have been avoided and it's a
terrible tragedy that it wasn't avoided
so but i don't draw from that the
inference that we're always supporting
the bad guys i think that's terribly
over that that's an oversimplification
where we do support the bad guys
undoubtedly we ought to be supporting
the right people but that's a matter of
sorting it out case by case 45 minutes
with neil shandago atlanta georgia next
go ahead please
hello
mr
i have one question
uh
i am a naturalized
american i am french
and i wanted to know
when the funds finally pulled out
why did we pull in
thank you
because we thought that first of all we
could
gather and and maintain a nationalist
government in south vietnam in the
person of the of an anti-communist the
anti-communist one of the anti-communist
leaders then we brought in a man named
negotiating siam we thought that because
we were americans we could really do
anything
we could do anything we wanted and we
assumed that all communist governments
were the same that they were run by in
i'm oversimplifying it but not
oversimplifying it too much we assumed
at the time that all communist
governments were run by a switchboard uh
out of the kremlin in moscow that that
that the communist world was also not as
not a complicated place and we thought
that we could organize the
anti-communist nationalist forces in
vietnam and create a viable government
out of them now it turned out that there
really wasn't an anti-communist
nationalist solution that you could that
a foreign power like the united states
should come in and put together out of
uh out of in effect out of the air
because when you come in as a foreigner
you really don't know what you're doing
you're dealing with a local situation
and we really didn't know what we were
doing if you read the book you'll see
that there was a great there was great
ignorance on our part
our intentions were to to create a
nationalist government in south vietnam
which would stand against the communist
government in the north atlanta georgia
go ahead please i'm sorry herndon
virginia we just had atlanta go ahead
please how are you doing well i have a
quick question uh
i agree 100 with what you said about how
we have a tendency to oversimplify our
views but one thing which really bothers
me in the media and in education in
general is that
we are correctly
concerned with how complicated things
are with vietnam and yet we're taught
that world war one was started by some
relatively unknown individual who gets
assassinated uh
we taught how world war ii is is you
know this totally unexpected surprise
attacks from these bad guy japanese
uh we're taught you know how incredibly
bad hitler was and yet welcomed stalin
as an ally
a man who probably killed three times
the people uh i'm maybe you'd comment on
just
why is it that everything else seems so
simplified in our culture and in our
education except for vietnam
well i think americans tend to
oversimplify things and that that isn't
to agree that that that uh stalin was
worse than hitler or vice versa i mean
stalin was a monster and
and hitler was a monster uh i think we
we tend to oversimplify things be it but
we have in the past because we tended to
to we like to think of ourselves for
example as a simple people with simple
and right-minded motivations who always
act from those right-minded motivations
when in fact i think we're a very
complicated nation i think it's part of
the american inability the american
difficulty in coming to grips with
history and and probably it's it may
have to do with some
in some ways with the way history is
taught in this country i really can't
say but i think that prior to vietnam in
any case americans had a very simplistic
view of the world and we tended to
romanticize what happened in world war
ii so some of your comments may reflect
that sedona arizona for neil sheehan go
ahead please
yeah i haven't read the book but i've
been listening to the program
and i'm a vietnam veteran as well as a
korean veteran of 25 years in service
and i'd like to make a couple of
comments i've been in vietnam of the
danang
and i think we
i
we couldn't win the war
in the beginning and we could never win
the war because we were fighting
essentially a guerrilla war
and
the united states military is not set up
to fight a guerrilla war has never been
set up fake awards we don't have the
equipment and the knowledge and when you
combine that that we were fighting with
a nationalistic pride in the country and
the fact that we weren't equipped
for a guerrilla war
we we were doomed to defeat when we
started but people in this country think
that like the author has said we are the
greatest power in the world
and the truth is uh we may have a lot of
power
but we cannot do everything and i think
katara had the right idea when he made a
comment at one time to the effect that
we can't be
the policeman of the world
and as long as we think we can
we got big problems ahead of us all
right thank you
well i think you can you can overdo this
as as as you say i mean we we obviously
i happen to believe this is is is the
the last best hope of man on earth this
country this is the best country that
does exist i think we do what vietnam
has given us a sense of is that we also
have limits and prior to going into
vietnam we didn't think we had any
limits we thought we could do anything
simply because we wanted to do it and
and that it was always that it would
always be right and good also because we
americans wanted to do it and vietnam
has disabused us of that idea and and i
i think this abuses of it very very
painfully and that's why it's so
difficult to come to grips with the
experience but it's a very necessary one
for to learn from vietnam we're neil
sheehan we go to yonkers new york and mr
sheen there's a group of us here and one
of my friends here said that they
thought you were born in a communist
country is that so
because i tell you why because we have
hanoi jane and we have marxist ted
kennedy and now we have sell out sheen
thank you
well i'm sorry but i don't see myself in
that light and if you do that's your
problem
what's next
i don't really know uh i've been busy
with the publication of the book now and
uh what i'll do next i don't know i'm
sure i'll stay busy uh i i've always
stayed busy and and uh i'll i i probably
won't write another book on vietnam
there's no encore to this book are you
tired one last question before i grab
this are you tired of talking about this
subject no no no vietnam doesn't i one i
don't think a subject is important as
vietnam is one that one ever should get
or one ever will get tired of talking
about i certainly would never get tired
of talking about it nor a man as
fascinating as john van i mean to me the
two are vietnam was the most important
event of the whole whole
post-world war ii period there's no
doubt in my mind about it it's changed
this country it was an enormously
traumatic event and i don't get tired of
talking about it
port walton beats florida for neil shin
yes i've enjoyed your comments and i
enjoyed this program the first time i've
talked in about three years now
but this is a particularly uh subject a
subject very close to my heart
first of all i would like to ask you
what do you think about the policies
that set up the rules of engagement
that so severely handicapped and
restricted
any military operations
and secondly
why has mr mcnamara
received the blame
that he should have as the architect for
the disaster that we face
thank you well if you read the book
you'll see that uh our military
operations in vietnam were not
restricted within vietnam itself within
particularly within south vietnam
obviously the the we couldn't cross the
borders into cambodia until late and we
couldn't cross the borders except uh in
you couldn't send american troops in
uniform across the borders into laos you
could bomb there and there were
restrictions on the bombing of north
vietnam although they don't really they
didn't really affect it in the end
because the only target in north vietnam
that would have would have had any
effect was the population and i don't
think americans would have wanted to
kill millions of women and children the
problem was the way the war was fought
the the army generals had this idea that
they could
it was called a war of attrition they
had the idea that they could kill off
the vietnamese communists faster than
they could replace themselves the
vietcong and the north vietnamese and
all this succeeded in doing it was it
was it was a zany idea uh when you look
at it because it didn't make any sense
all it it did in the end was to cause
the deaths of a lot of them thousands
tens of thousands of american soldiers
and undercut the political will at home
to to carry on the war so that when 1068
occurred the surprise communist
defensive it caused a psychological and
political collapse here and that really
is the problem uh in the way the
the war was prosecuted uh militarily
robert mcnamara
ah yes mr mcnamara well
mr mcnamara's caught an awful lot of
blame uh and i don't think he's
obviously he hasn't escaped from this
whole uh
he's he's uh he bears an awful lot of of
of scars from this war i tried in the
book to deal with him fairly
you see him in inside the government by
the end realizing that we are going to
lose the war in vietnam trying to tell
president johnson in 67 that he is going
to lose and then mcnamara is fired and
moved over to the world bank as
president of the world bank the thing he
couldn't do in later years uh for for
obviously personal reasons he couldn't
come to grips with it i suspect
emotionally was he never could come out
and publicly say what he what he had
said in secret in private within
government uh that's something mr
mcnamara was unable to do in all those
later years of the war
corvallis oregon you're next
uh mr sheehan i spent a couple of years
out there teaching in the universities
and
i agree almost entirely with everything
i've heard you say i've not read your
book but i'm going to
and
looking at it from where i was i never
met any vietnamese who said they would
support the government of south vietnam
i
think that we could only have made the
war bigger i don't think we could have
won it
uh the chinese didn't want in the war we
went to fight the chinese the chinese
didn't show up
and i think much to our embarrassment
maybe but we're probably fortunate
uh i do agree with you that i think we
are likely to make the same mistake
again
uh perhaps in nicaragua or some other
like place
i think generally our foreign policy in
the third world
needs much to be leaves much to be
desired
and i don't know if i have any further
comment other than i shall read your
book
and i think you're doing us a great
service
because the vietnamese would have died
to the last man before they would ever
have allowed us to stay there
you agree
that that was essentially the problem in
vietnam i mean you you you have a
situation where the vietnamese won't
tolerate the vietnamese are people who
will not tolerate foreign domination
they're like the irish and then the most
recent case the soviets discovered the
afghans they won't tolerate foreigners
uh the vietnamese uh whom we supported
as i said earlier were the vietnamese
who had sided with the french by and
large they were vietnamese who had sided
with the french during the first war now
not that there weren't a good many
really good men on the saigon side and a
quarter of a million vietnamese died
of fighting uh for the saigon side but
you're right in general
the the society this
south vietnamese society and the
government lacked a will to survive and
it lacked popular support and that's i
think what you were running into with
the university students now whether
we're going to uh do this make this kind
of mistake again i don't know i would
hope we wouldn't i would hope we would
learn from vietnam and not make the same
kind of mistake on that scale uh that
that we would
if if we draw lessons from it i think
one has to look at vietnam as as as
let's let's contrast it to world war ii
in world war ii our soldiers brought
home
victory and glory and thank god that
they did because our cause then was the
cause of humanity in vietnam we were
defeated
but i think that vietnam can be at the
defeat
uh can be as
valuable
in in its time as victory
if one learns from defeat
and that if we do learn from what
happened in vietnam then the lives of
those men who died there will not have
been in vain i think we have to find
some way to redeem the lives of those
men whose names are remembered on the
wall uh and uh
and and and to to redeem to the extent
one can one can never truly redeem it
obviously the the the millions who die
uh who died in indochina and the
devastation of those those lands redeem
it to the extent one can by by drawing
wisdom from it wilmington north carolina
go ahead please um yes but the caller um
who is so emotional from california
imagine talking about
uh how the united states foreign policy
is corrupt
though he could not list
where we're corrupt and what areas
but do you remember that call yes sir
um
that's very interested in that call
especially the due to his emotional
aspect
but there is quite a number
of
foreign policy
programs initiated by this country that
that are corrupt in that since you ask
him the nameless view you can name
more than you can count on your fingers
very easily
well we did die around in 54
and why
for the oil
what we did the guatemala
it was 53 it wasn't in iraq then 54 we
did guatemala and for the united fruit
company
obviously
but we did the chili in 783 what henry
kissinger did this chilean 73
he ended up with a nobel prize for what
he did in vietnam
but what did he get for what he did with
itnt and anaconda
and ralston purina and guess who
guatemala in 1980 16 000 people were
dead
just like that indians peasants they
called them sixteen thousand dead wasn't
released in the united states nowhere in
the press
but they had a u.n geneva conference in
human rights which determined that
guatemala had genocide going on
in 79
and 80.
it was front page news throughout europe
it's not the rest of the world
all right sir
any coming on the list i i
really can't comment on most of those
situations because i haven't studied
them in detail and i'm the kind of
person who if i haven't studied
something in detail i don't want to
address it so i'd have to just pass it
uh the only thing i can say is that i
tried to look at vietnam in detail and
see what happened there and and and in
hopes that as i said earlier we draw
some lessons from it
overland park kansas go ahead please
yeah i want to address a question
earlier caller had concerning
how much we've analyzed the vietnam war
and i think it's just like a basketball
game or something you tend to analyze
the losses and point fingers a lot more
than you do the wins
and
i think from that standpoint if we
looked a little harder at
world war ii
saw that by moving the
pacific fleet from san diego to pearl
harbor and the
macarthur's headquarters from the
hawaiian islands to the philippines uh
we've been in a
a little less of a threatening stance to
the japanese
if we'd have lost or drawn a stalemate
in europe in world war ii why there's
been a little more finger pointing at
the idea of uh
an invasion of france and
and uh you know the the meeting which
basically roosevelt gave eastern europe
to the russians in exchange for them
continuing to put pressure on the
eastern front
and that's that's my viewpoint on why we
uh analyze
um the loss and the tie korea
uh more than we have the wins and i just
wonder if your guest would have any
comment on that thank you
well i i would say to you that first of
all i in world war ii was a war of
survival and it was an incredible
success story for this country it was uh
and it but it was also in it was in in
the line of our prior wars in american
experience wars have always been good
experiences
they have been
morally cohesive things they pulled
people together morally and and they
have been experiences in which you went
off
you fought you defended your cause of
your country and you came home and you
were praised for it even the
confederates who lost in the civil war
were honored in their own communities
the problem with vietnam was it was the
that however you look at the war in
vietnam you say that it was a war fought
in the wrong way or let's say you say
that it was a war in which our cause was
not just it was a bad war it was a
terribly painful experience
as divisive more divisive than any war
since the civil war and it's it's
terribly difficult for americans to come
to grips with there's an awful lot of
anger out there and i think what you
heard from that caller was that kind of
anger i mean there's just an awful lot
of anger out there and it's very
difficult for people therefore to to un
to to congregate with what with the
reality of it they tend to blame it on
others
blame it on lyndon johnson blame it on
restrictions on the military blame it on
the news media
the president of cbs didn't order the
marines into vietnam in the first place
whoever he was at the time he didn't
station the marines at caisson
television certainly had an impact
in driving home what was happening in
vietnam but television didn't decide how
to fight the war it was the generals who
decided how to fight the war so you
these these scapegoat myths don't stand
up to historic examination the media
didn't lose the war in vietnam lyndon
johnson didn't lose the war in vietnam
it's a very complicated thing but i
think the reason it's difficult for
americans to come to grips with it is
because it's just so painful i think
we're only now beginning after these
years to come to grips with it and what
i wanted to do with the reason i was
willing to stay with this book through
the grimmest of my long years with it
was the hope that i would help my
country
to come to grips with that war and to
finally set it to rest by facing the
truth of what happened there los angeles
yes mr sheehan i too am a vietnam
veteran by the way you left out one of
the scapegoats and we're it
but
i would like to ask you a question
regarding the role of the press it seems
to me that america had never really
dealt with war aside from the civil war
had never really dealt with war on a
daily basis had never had to look at it
had never had to do everything but smell
it and recognize it for what it is
lately however it seems that what has
come of that is that there's been a
tremendous restriction placed on the
press in terms of its ability to not
compromise the action itself but to be
able to report the action in an accurate
fashion i would like your comments on
how you feel america has since
placed restrictions on the press or
whether you feel they have
as regards their ability to report
what war is thank you very much
i i think that first of all i'd like to
make one comment on on the fact that you
you said i left out one scapegoat the
veteran i didn't leave out the the fact
that the veterans have been scapegoated
over there i didn't mention it earlier
in the program i think it's wrong that
the fighting men were blamed for what
happened in vietnam it's not the
fighting man's fault the american
fighting man fought with great gallantry
in vietnam i recount an incident in the
book the first battle between the north
vietnamese army and and the u.s army
which i happened to cover at a place
called the adron and the american
fighting man their fought for example
with great gallantry i think that what
you're thinking of when you talk about
restrictions on the media perhaps is the
unwillingness to allow reporters into
grenada that was the most recent example
of it
that i think came out of vietnam and out
of the anger uh that that set in as a
result of of vietnam and the bad
relationship that has developed between
the news media and some in the military
as a result of it it's it's twofold you
people forget that in vietnam reporters
did have military censorship
we did you could not write about future
operations at one point in 65 and 66
when i was there you couldn't give the
exact number of casualties american
casualties you could say they were light
they were medium or they were heavy
there were a number of but they were
milk they were questions of military
security the argument was over whether
the press was saying we were winning or
losing
now that's something you can't hide and
preserve a credible news media when
people talk about censoring the news
media if we'd only had censorship we
could have won they forget that if let's
say the news media had gone to vietnam
the television and radio and had only
reported good news
when ted 68 occurred and the vietcong
moved 15 battalions into saigon caught
the american command totally by surprise
moved into the compound
the american embassy compound let's say
the american news media said all of this
is fine don't worry about it everything
is grand i think people would have
ceased to believe what they were reading
in their own newspapers and they would
have ceased to believe what they were
watching on television the news media of
this country would have lost their
credibility we would have ended up with
proved on his vesti and soviet
television and people would have
listened to gotten their news from
somewhere else because the work the
truth would have come back somehow you
have to deal with the truth and it's
only like lately one sees in fact
in soviet media that now the soviets are
beginning to believe what they read in
their own newspapers because as a result
of glasnost the soviet media are finally
printing the truth and so they don't
have to get it from
voice of america but i think this is a
complicated thing and people don't think
of it in those terms hingham
massachusetts you're next
i'm miss chen
uh i'm a vietnam veteran and uh
i was over there between 69 and 70.
uh
when
i was a mad team leader
and they had me
the first guy i met was after going
through was john paul vann
who had me in his office and me and some
other officers
it was really gung ho at that time
and then about
oh
when i was in the delta
about four and a half five months later
they helped me they brought me in from
the field to
at this cocktail party for colby
and van at the time
and you know he was talking to me and
stuff and he was
heavily drinking whatever
and uh it seemed like a really depressed
guy at the time
i haven't read your book but when did he
change his views
on it
john began to change his views on the
war after ted 68 and he began to
rationalize things at that point i'm
surprised that you would find him
drinking because he rarely drank much at
all uh the the uh he was not a man given
to alcohol
the he he drank almost hardly at all the
the uh what happened was
after 1068 he couldn't let go of the war
and because it satisfied him so much and
he began to rationalize what was
happening there prior to that he had a
very firm grip on the fact that the war
of attrition the american generals were
fighting wasn't going to work that it
would just help to undercut political
support for the war at home the fact
that you had to have a decent saigon
government not the corrupt regime we had
in order to prevail in vietnam but after
1068 he began to rationalize and say
well the vietcong are gone
we've only got the north vietnamese army
to deal with somehow we can we can we
can we can crush what's left of the
vietcong and we can prevail against the
north vietnamese and he began to say
well it doesn't matter that the saigon
regime is corrupt anymore it doesn't
matter as much it doesn't matter that
their incompetence we can somehow
overcome all of that
he started to rationalize the whole
situation there and he came up with a
number of their ideas in fact that were
put into nixon's vietnamization strategy
which was another delusion that you
could transfer the burden of the war to
the south vietnamese and progressively
withdraw the american forces in order to
gain
political tolerance for the war at home
and what happened finally of course was
that when the american forces were
withdrawn the north vietnamese attacked
in 1972 and the whole situation started
to come apart the south vietnamese
panicked by that time van was a general
commanding the second corps up in the
highlands he was our first civilian
general in history he left the delta and
gone to the mountains of the central
highlands and the central coast and he
stopped the north vietnamese offensive
there in a battle
which i recount in the book at a town
called khan tomb he stopped the panic he
took it over himself uh but he didn't
see that in having to take it over
himself the saigon system didn't regime
didn't have any will to survive of its
own and so he won the battle and then he
was killed a week later he died in a
helicopter crash thinking when he died
that he'd won his war but of course he
hadn't
baltimore maryland go ahead please
mr sheen
there is such an awful unrest in the
world do you feel tonight in the callers
and i was just wondering
mr reagan and mrs thatcher
seem to be making so many changes
but the changes seem to be orchestrated
by a larger group and i can remember
after world war ii
i was reading a book
and i think it said that a group of very
wealthy and influential men were forming
them
and they were going to make this one
world do you believe this is happening
when so much is happening in the world
and no one seems to be able to
understand
i'm not given the conspiracy theories of
history ma'am i i happen to think that
history is made by individual countries
and by individual leaders of those
countries
with obviously made trends and forces
involved but but trends and forces that
are affected by individuals you
mentioned mrs thatcher she has changed
in major ways britain uh some people say
for the better some people say for the
worst but this is the effect of an
individual i'm not given to these
conspiracy theories of history no i
don't think that everything's uh been
been been planned in some big room by a
bunch of wealthy men boys see idaho
you're next
yes uh mr sheenan
the question that i have uh is more or
less really a comment i guess because it
seems to me that in your book which is a
fine piece of work by the way i was glad
to see it
is that uh for the people of america
this war is over in your book a lot of
the programs that i've seen this war is
over for the veterans and the thing that
that i have to deal with every day and
that i know more you know they're all
over the place is that this war is not
over
the the only problem is
that
the enemy has changed it used to be the
vietcong in the delta for the veterans
the the enemy now is the american
political system as far as the anger and
frustration that's been caused in like
disabled vets who can't receive aid or
treatment that are
they're termed anti-social
when in reality it's nothing more than
anger and frustration for being really
messed over and denied benefits when
they get back
my primary concern with this is like i'm
from a family where my father was in
vietnam then later i served
my father is now dying of ancient orange
cancer and the veterans administration
says oh no there's no such thing so he
can't receive eight
my father's well above 60 now
i was in an airplane accident my back
was tore out and the veterans
administration and all this stuff they
deny the benefits creates more anger
more frustration not just for the
veterans but for the families for
everybody around the families uh it
really
makes me me angry when i when i hear all
these people going over vietnam and it's
the attitude that the war is over and
it's not okay sir thank you yeah i
didn't say the war was over i i said
that the world was still very much with
us uh in that the pain is with us and
we're only now beginning i think to come
to grips with it i can't comment on the
individual cases that you you specified
your own and your father's because i
don't know the facts of them i do think
it is was terrible that the vietnam
veteran was made a scapegoat for what
happened in vietnam what what in fact
the the american fighting man in vietnam
was a victim of his own military
and political leadership senior military
and senior political leadership a superb
army went to vietnam and it was
destroyed there by its own senior
leadership it was the best army we have
ever fielded from the training camps to
this country to the battlegrounds of
vietnam i mean i saw those men go into
battle i was extremely proud to be there
as reported to see them uh i recount in
in the book an example in the first
battle with the north vietnamese
at a place called the iadrong in the
mountains of south vietnam one company
came in the first day a hundred men
strong the next morning they got hit by
a viet by a north vietnamese battalion
on their side of the perimeter and only
40 men walked away unharmed but no north
vietnamese got through that line those
men were absolutely superb and i think
it's terrible that that they have been
made scapegoats for what happened there
i i think that that the american veteran
from vietnam ought to be treated with
with extreme consideration and and ought
to be helped in any way that this
country can help him for neil sheehan we
go to dayton ohio
yes just to comment on a comment you
made you said the generals fought the
war the generals didn't fight the war
the american people in congress fought
the war
goldwater if you remember said get in
there and get it over with or get out
11 years before the war was over the
people called him a war monger
congress cut off the money without
giving us any way to get out of there
with any respect whatsoever
because the uh the way the politics was
running at the time i just like for you
to comment on that
well i think that barry goldwater's
solutions to vietnam were simplistic and
i don't think they would have worked he
recently said for example that he would
have he would have won the war in
vietnam by by bombing north vietnam into
a swamp
uh in 1965 that would have broken their
will and stopped the communists from
taking over south vietnam
there are two things involved here first
of all if you bombed north vietnamese
north vietnam into a swamp you would be
attacking the population of north
vietnam
you would be killing millions of women
and children now that choice was
available to president johnson and he
chose not to take it i'm not sure the
american public and the flyers
themselves talking about the pilots the
airmen would have wanted to do that do
we want to kill millions of women and
children
secondly it would not have won the war
in vietnam in 1965 because the vietcong
gorillas were winning in south vietnam
and if we had bombed north vietnam into
a swamp it wouldn't have stopped the
vietcong in south vietnam they would
have gone on to victory the only thing
that temporarily stopped them was
sending in the u.s army and the marine
corps into south vietnam itself so these
solutions so-called solutions which were
which were propounded uh
in retrospect and at the time the
simplistic ones really just don't stand
up to historic examination if you read
the book i think you'll see that
birmingham alabama for neoshan
yes i wanted to ask a couple questions
about the tet offensive
it seemed that when you were talking
earlier that that was a
loss for the u.s of course i guess
emotionally or psychologically it
probably was but it was a military
disaster for the north vietnamese
i've never seen any records where they
gained any significant uh ground hold or
permanent
advantage from that and the second thing
was it always seems like vietnam is the
one loss and everyone talks about we
lost the war whereas the facts
militarily we did not lose the war
we essentially effectively pulled out in
73 and saigon and the rest of vietnam
really didn't fall until 75
after a gradual deterioration of cutting
off aid to them and supplies i want to
get your comments on that first of all
we didn't cut off aid in supplies the
south vietnamese had plenty of fighting
equipment the problem in 1975 was that
they wouldn't fight they ran
they fought one last stand at a place
called swan lok north of saigon but
prior to that they ran because the whole
system collapsed the panic broke out
that same panic broke out in 1972 as a
recount in the book and had john van not
been there the country would have been
split into in 1972 van took over in the
in the highlands he was a man of great
force and great character who by that
time had become part of the south
vietnamese system as much as he was in
the american system he was kind of an
american lawrence of arabia he took over
and won a major battle of the town
called kantum and stem the panic
but that panic broke out in 72 and 75
three years later and undid south
vietnam it wasn't the fact that the
united states
cut off aid
secondly if if you take a look at at
that earlier period of time you will see
again that it's it's not a question of
us of of these simple solutions they
just weren't simple solutions in vietnam
los angeles california go ahead please
yes mr sheen i just finished reading
your book i'm a vietnam vet i was with
the 25th division at kuchi in 1966.
and one thing i wanted to say is the
reaction i had as i was reading the book
was one of
rising anger
as i read what you were the case you
were building against westmoreland and
the way he
he used american soldiers and just
through
threw us away
and and this may not even be a question
to direct you i guess what i don't
understand is how 20 years after the war
or a little less than that
even vietnam veterans still invite
westmoreland to be grand marshal of
their parades and treat the man as a
hero and i wonder if you could just
comment a little bit about what the
attrition theory was if we keep losing
americans you know we we might stop them
well the attrition theory was that that
the army generals had a head of all was
that you could kill off the vietnamese
communists faster than they could
replace themselves and you would bleed
them to death as westmoreland said and
then break their will
well the theory didn't make any sense
because first of all their military
manpower pool was huge and and uh
once you committed american soldiers to
battle on the ground against them what
would happen was that you would run up
very large american casualties
early on in the war john vance saw that
this wouldn't succeed all it would do
would be to run up american casualties
at home and undercut the american
political will to fight the war a marine
general named victor krulak brilliant
marine general in 1965 when we were
going to war there the big american war
was starting also took a look at this
whole attrition theory worked out the
mathematics of it and said this isn't
going to this isn't going to work we're
just going to undercut ourselves we're
going to we're going to get americans
killed off you can't
he calculated it would take
175 000 deaths on the south vietnamese
and american side to reduce the military
manpower pool on the vietnamese
communist side by 20 percent the whole
thing was ridiculous when he worked out
the figures but you couldn't get the
army generals to listen and mcnamara and
johnson at that point had faith in the
army generals well what krulak wanted to
do was the same thing van wanted to do
he wanted to follow a pacification
strategy and reform the saigon regime
see the vietnamese have had a history of
defeating powerful invaders every time a
new dynasty came to power in china it
would inevitably invade vietnam and the
way the vietnamese and including the
mongols vietnamese who invaded three
times and when the vietnamese defeated
in in two of the invasions were major
ones and the vietnamese defeated them
they defeated them by wearing them down
and what the vietnamese communists did
to us was they would create these man
traps of bunkers uh complexes out in the
rain forest and our generals following
this attrition theory would send our
infantry out there again and again to
take these ridges in the middle of
nowhere on the theory that we were going
to wear down the enemy and all we did
was wear down ourselves because of
course when you get out of a helicopter
in a rain forest you're on the same
basis as that fellow who's also a
well-armed infantryman and and a lot of
them and the vietnamese were living out
there for months at a time the american
soldier who landed in the middle of
nowhere he hadn't been there before he
didn't he didn't know anything about
what he was facing and and our people
didn't win all the battles in vietnam as
that's another myth we won all the
battles but we still lost the war we
didn't win all the battles and even if
we had it would have been irrelevant
five minutes for neil shannon we go to
columbia south carolina um yes sir mr
shannon um i'd like first to compliment
you on your book i found it uh uh just
an excellent piece of work and um
have you read a book by uh andrew
krepniewicz
it's called the army in vietnam
he has much the same ideas due to that
that the army leadership
essentially got everything they wanted
and didn't learn anything from the war
do you see any change in
the especially in the army any change in
their ideas or views about how to win
wars
after the war now
well i think that if you take a look at
the military leadership in general
post-vietnam you see people who are
being a lot more cautious
you have
well let's take an example in the army
the first of the vietnam generation to
become
chief of staff was a general named
shia
edward
meyer
his nickname he i met him when he was a
lieutenant colonel first as executive
officer and then a battalion commander
in vietnam he served two tours there
general meyer as he said inherited a
hollow army because vietnam the the
american army was destroyed by the war
in vietnam
and and he had to start rebuilding it
he was a man who in his
in his views as far as intervening
abroad was one of those who said unlike
the generation of the sixties the
military leaders of the 60s are always
telling the president look
just use armed force turn loose the army
turn loose the air force turn loose the
marine corps and force will solve your
problems meyer and a number of the other
military leaders of his generation are
saying you better be careful look before
you leap
don't uh
don't intervene unless you know what
you're doing
the lesson is not to intervene at all
but you better know what you're doing
before you intervene because a lot of
consequences are going to follow once
you do intervene now whether the
institutions will really learn in the
sense that they will truly
see all the bureaucratic problems they
have which which created which were
behind a lot of the army behavior in
vietnam
six months only in command the so-called
ticket punching you had to have a
battalion in order to to to get promoted
to full colonel uh you had to have a
brigade in order to get promoted to
general and so you had officers rotating
in and out of these command slots six
months at the time learning nothing all
those other bureaucratic patterns
whether the army is going to come to
grips with those things and really learn
from them i don't know i think only time
will tell and the army is an institution
and this is true of the air force as
well will have to learn from itself
last call for neo-shan chicago heights
illinois
yes mr shannon i never read your book
but
i read a book in 1981 by a four-star
general marine corps was in vietnam and
he was in korea also
and you know very well and i wish you'd
tell the public
the reason we didn't win korea in
vietnam and news media and people write
your books and kind of leave it out
the reason is is because already taunt
salt one assault two
american people aren't really aware of
that we have rules the enemy don't have
any
we have a dmz line we can't take real
estate how you gonna win a war can't
take real estate
you know that and not only that
the general wrote book and there's you
probably read the book i bet
have you or not which general are you
talking about sir which book
he wrote the book love a tower
11th hour lou
i know general walt and i've read one of
his books it's not wasn't called the
11th hour though
i read an earlier book of his on vietnam
uh i think your your view of korea is uh
i i did know general quite well on
vietnam uh and and talked to him talked
to him a number of times with him quite
a bit there but to go on i think your
view of korea is somewhat oversimplified
we had a problem in korea because
macarthur went into the mountains of
north korea with an army uh that was he
and was fully unprepared to take on
about 300
hundreds of thousands of chinese who
were waiting for us there i recount this
in my book because john vann was
involved in in in korea and
we were defeated in the mountains of
north korea in the winter of 1950 and
had to retreat 125 miles down that
peninsula the longest retreat in
american military history uh and in
vietnam again you have a very
complicated situation with the generals
fighting the war in the worst way
possible the army generals against the
advice of the marine generals including
initially general walt and so you you
you have really a a pretty complicated
business i'm afraid you're looking at it
in a much too simplified way
time's up neil shane the author of this
book a bright shining lie john paul van
american vietnam published by random
house neil shin thank you very much for
coming and joining us for an hour and a
half of calls and to our audience thank
you for your comments and questions have
a good evening
[Music]
if you have further questions or
comments for our guest you can write to
neil sheehan in care of random house at
201 east 50th street new york new york
the zip code is one zero zero two two
coming up